the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
welcome everybody to day one of the 2023
Superbad chess Classic held in beautiful
Bucharest Romania we started a day in
front of the Grand Hotel Bucharest the
place where all the magic happens this
is where the games are being played this
is where the battles are being fought if
you find yourself in Bucharest make sure
you check it out now let's go to the
studio and start day one action
we welcome you to the first step on the
2023 grandchild store and our coverage
of Superbad Romania we come to your life
from the San Luis chess club
hello and welcome to our show I'm
International Master Nazi Pai kids and
I'm here with Grandmaster yasu sarawan I
can't believe this is happening I know
you as a player who's who are at the
board winning U.S women's championships
and it's the first time I get to do
commentary with you welcome welcome
thank you so much I'm very excited to be
here me too hello everyone and welcome
to a new season of the grand chest tour
and you know that starts in Bucharest
Romania in fact let's take a look at all
the events of this year's tour we begin
as always with the super bet chess
classic May 6th through the 15th in
Bucharest Romania that will be followed
by the super bet rapid and Blitz in
Warsaw Poland just down the road May
19th through the 26th then the super
United rapid and Blitz July 3rd through
the 10th in sagreb Croatia and then we
bring the events Stateside as St Louis
Missouri is going to host the St Louis
rapid and Blitz November 12th the 19th
and then the granddaddy of the mall the
sink fill cup November 19 through the
December 3rd where we will be crowning a
new grand chess tour and let me ask you
the question Naji who's here right we
have the strongest players in the world
competing in this event let's start with
our tapseed and last year's winner of
the grandchild store alireza ferruga
from France
representing Fida at two-time World
Championship Challenger
and our new world champion the English
ran from China when the champion and
Challenger number two and number three
you know it's going to be a strong event
please continue we're followed by the
top us players Fabiano caruana and
Wesley so then we have Dutch number one
Anish giri French number two Maxima
Shiela Graf and the defending champion
of the Bucharest Romanian tournament
welcome back mvl right Poland's number
one young Crystal Tuda thank you and top
two Grandmasters from Romania Richard
rapper and back then Danielle diac a
fantastic field to be sure and our
format format of this event 10 player
round robin with a classical classical
time control 90 minutes for the first 40
moves 30 minutes for the rest of the
game and 30 second increment from move
one
players are not allowed to offer any
draws they must fight until the end and
we have our regular scoring system one
point for a win half for a draw and zero
for a loss and our schedule of our
kickoff event right we'll have nine
rounds round one starting today and the
players will play five rounds in a row
and then on Thursday May 11th get a rest
day wonderful and complete the
tournament with four games in a row and
we're very very fortunate to have it in
studio we usually see him sequestered in
the production team Grandmaster of uruga
nicobian welcome to the show VAR it's
good to see you thank you Yasser hello
everyone I am very happy to be here
covering the games from this very very
strong tournament we have some of the
very best players competing in this
event and in particular we have
dingleren and Yani promise you these two
players just played in a world
championship match it was tied 727 after
the classical games but then ding one in
the tie breaks to become a 17 World
chess champion
we have yanny pomachi 32 years old URS
rating 2787 representing fide two times
winner of the candidates tournament who
was very very close to win a world
championship this year
then we have ding Loren 30 years old URS
rating 2787 representing China
2023 World chess champion
if you're wondering where is Magnus he
will be playing in the next event super
bet rapid and Blitz in Warsaw Poland and
then after that you will be playing in a
super United rapid and Blitz in Zagreb
Croatia
and we're gonna go to Romania to our
friend Grandmaster Christian chirilla
from Bucharest for all the latest from
the tournament venue
good to see you guys great to be back
here in Bucharest Romania my home City
it's always a pleasure to be here but
it's such an incredible price to be here
for the first leg of the 2023 Grand
Chester it's a new season we have
Renewed Energy here in Bucharest Romania
it's just an incredible atmosphere and I
have to tell you yesterday at the
opening ceremony we had so many
celebrities and we had one in particular
Gary Kasparov was here as well he gave a
speech he made the first ceremonial move
to uh open the tournament and all the
participants were also there as well
everybody everybody's eyes were on the
participants and I have to say I was
looking for the energy levels of two
players in particular that is and dingly
ren who just finished a world
championship imagine I have to say I was
uh surprised by Jan I was expecting not
so uh and high energy yawn nevertheless
he was energized in this one he had a
fresh cut he was ready to battle I have
to say and of course tingly ran after
winning a world championship match
getting that boost of confidence you
could see it on his face you could feel
it in his Aura but we have so many
spectacular players guys participating
in this event we have alireza firuja
coming from a quite significant layoff
his last tournament was in September in
St Louis in fact at the singfield cup he
won that grandchild store here just an
incredible player all around we have
incredible players in this venue and I
am very excited to see what they're
going to bring over the chessboard and
the games are going to start in the next
few minutes
thank you Christian sounds like an
electric atmosphere over there and you
look really good too Christian
lay the table for us now that we know
the roster of the players tell us about
today's pairings imagine all right we
have very exciting matchups our newly
crowned Champion dingley ran against
Maxima Sheila Grove starting with the
bang as we have Champions and champions
going head-to-head right we have Fabiano
caruana against the youngest player in
the field
against Robert something special about
that one too is Richard Rapport was part
of the dingler in entourage right and we
have Duda against giri and firusha
against Wesley so we're going to be
seeing Fighting Chess or oops as Gary
gets ready to make the opening moves
and
uh
old world champion uh helping a new
world champion so excited
certainly
as uh what do you think he's gonna play
D4
D4 that's going to be my guess
after just playing this world
championship match I'm not sure I would
want to go into the night or
especially against mvl's Nigeria
I don't know if they're gonna end we see
Richard Rapport on the right
NATO
leaning back in his chair
they look a little bit nervous
yeah it's the butterflies and it's crazy
all my career uh and there we see uh
farusion the question we were having for
ourselves now he is is he into fashion
design or is he a fashion model maybe
both maybe both we really like to find
out he's looking good there in that uh
suit he's wearing
[Applause]
um
they were fighting for we'll get into it
prizes later as we get a sense of the
playing haul there
our
photographer with the blue hair yeah
well then it's a bit of a fashion
statement himself absolutely always
bright and afternoon
and Gary's making his first one right
you all right well he may take it back
in the second
group
[Applause]
ding looks like he right he'd like to
just get the clock started and get it
out
the game's gone
I don't think he's taken back I guess no
he's locked it on the board that is for
sure
I don't know we have another uh
another D4 we'll just have to ask our
friends in Romania who he is
I didn't recognize it and look at the
Bobby quickly takes it back okay that's
professional not giving them a chance to
uh they're gonna be fighting very hard
what are they fighting for they're
fighting for a lot of money right
this winter is going to get hundred
thousand dollars second place 65 000
third place forty eight thousand three
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
total prize money that's pretty darn
good all the way down to 10th Place ten
thousand and the players will also be
playing for grantchester points win
clear first and you get a bonus of one
grand Chester point for 13. tie for
first the 12th uh Grand chest tour
points will be divided amongst the
number of players who tied for first the
leader or winner of the grandchester or
at the end of the tournament at the end
of the tour will get a hundred thousand
uh bonus so those grand Chester points
very very very handy and again as we're
just kind of taking a break I'm going to
be asking ourselves who we like to be uh
who are we going to guess as this year's
winners for
um Bucharest now since you're
uh first uh time in the studio we're
gonna let you go first now I was
thinking about it hard yesterday you
were because tough choices honestly
anyone you pick has a good chance to win
clear but I'm gonna go with the
Frenchman MPL
that's why you're expecting a repeat
Champion yes marvelous in Borussia
erosion we're gonna put you on the spot
who do you like I'm gonna pick ding
Loren yeah sir I think uh he's very
excited that he won the World
Championship and he's got some good
preparation so I think uh I'm gonna have
him as my choice it's remarkable I was
gonna go uh yesterday I really like
Richard Rapport I had it I convinced
myself that Richard had been a part of
ding Loren's training that he's full of
them and vigor and the fact that his uh
player if you will was successful had
convinced me however I remember one very
Salient thing
I had been working really really hard to
become a grand master and I kept coming
close failing clothes failing
the moment I became a grand master then
I had like six grand master results in a
row right now that Ding Loren is world
champion
I think he wants to show that it is a
new moment and I'm gonna go with your
pick as well VAR I think dingler in is
going to bring you know the best quality
game he can and
you know yeah we're gonna see a great
great uh
uh tournament by the way Queens Gambit
accepted I mean I look at this and I
just have to smile to myself mvl had
made a very very promising career with
the grunfeld which as we know is an
extremely sharp risky double-edged
defense as black and I always played the
Queen's Gambit and Queens Gambit
accepted the old slow take it easy and
now I'm seeing Queen's Gambit accepted
by mvl uh he's becoming an uh an old man
fast is the way I look at that how about
you uh VAR what what games have you been
following
um
let's take a look at the fabianos game
here he's playing against deck and they
have the names of Indian defense
and
and Fabi played Knight F3 he didn't play
E3 the Rubenstein or the queen C2 the
classical he decided to play the move
Knight F3 and uh
there are some interesting variations
here B6 is one of the main moves here
with the idea to put the bishop on B7 so
in particular there is one line Bishop
G5 Bishop B7 and E3 H6 so we could say
something like this happening after
Bishop page four G5 and uh 94
for example and very very sharp
positions so this is one interesting
variation we can see uh in this game and
we can take a look at the nepos game
here so it's very interesting we have
the French defense actually which we
don't we don't see too in this opening
in this tournament so E4 E6 and he
decided to play the 92 the tarash
variation and we see a lot more often
the move Knight C3 the classical which
is considered to be one of the most
challenging openings uh but here he
played Knight D2 so
and now C5 the most critical move so a
little bit of surprising choice in this
position
well thank you for that uh VAR and I
noticed that after we had started with
the game between dingler and and mvl
there's a big pause after D5 takes C4 I
haven't seen any moves by ding as he he
must be very surprised yeah he's truly
because uh this is actually a very a
crucial moment now I've always felt
whenever I was playing the Queen's
Gambit accepted as black D5 takes C4 I
was always happy when my opponents
played E3 and Bishop takes C4 like and
we went into let's say yeah the
conventional say main lines but I always
felt that when I played the move D5
takes C4 as
black I was giving up control of the
center and I've always felt that the
move E2 E4 is the most challenging by
far even though it's extremely deeply
analyzed I'm not saying it guarantees
white at an advantage or anything like
that I just always felt that E2 E4 was
the most challenging in this position
and I'm sure that's what ding is
thinking about right now deciding if he
wants to play more quiet positional
right response with E3 or if he wants to
go into the sharp theoretical lines of
E4 exactly so he's really been suffering
this one through let's just walk around
the whole I want to mention something in
the game and he promised you against
Robert yep I believe we had this exact
position on the board in the world
championship match just a few weeks ago
exactly when dingley ran surprised the
end with the French defense exactly and
the funny part is that the French
defense has been a part of Yan's
repertoire
for a number of years and for Richard to
challenge him
in his own repertoire oh uh this is
going to be uh quite the clash and what
do you have for his car uh there are two
things that pay my attention first I
want to show you the we we have the game
of uh Duda versus Anish giri it's
another Queen's Gambit uh accepted
opening so and there we did see the
movie E4 yeah the most challenging movie
four is played in this position and the
black responder with E5 and Knight F3
Bishop B4 and again it's a very
theoretical line and Knight F6 is played
so we have two Queens Gambit accepted
games and this should be very
interesting uh how this game will
develop here for example Knight takes E5
there are some B5 uh very very
complicated variations F3 perhaps A6 and
uh you know black has a lot of Pawns on
the queen side but white has the control
of the center so it's it's hard to tell
who is better so
and the lifetime between these two
players we have zero wins for Duda one
win for anishkiri and four draws so
Anish has a slight lead in this matchup
right and another game that is very
interesting we have
a very unusual move in this popular
opening the game between alireza firoza
and Wesley so so it started off with
E4 E5 Knight F3 Knight C6 Bishop C4
normal Italian and here we see the move
D6
which is uh not the most popular move
Knight F6 is a much more natural move
but perhaps black is keeping his options
open here maybe he will play 97 at some
point so but D6 is more rare in this
position and now C3 played with the idea
two different ideas at some point before
could be played and also preparing the
D4 break so that's why black played the
move Bishop B6 that way if D4 is played
for example the bishop doesn't have to
move already you already prepared for
that and also before move doesn't come
with the tempo it's very interesting
here guys the Knight G5 moves actually
the possibility here putting pressure on
F7 and now sort of forcing the move
Knight H6 and after that you can try to
play castle and it's not it's not going
to be that easy to remove the knight
from G5 here because you definitely
don't want to play the move F6 here
because that's going to allow Knight D6
attacking the queen and it's one one
option and also even if I Retreat for
example then you cannot Castle because
you had weakened the position and if you
play the move let's say castle in this
position then there are some options
like H3 to try to restrict the Knight
and we know the Knight is very badly
placed on H6 here and it's going to be
very hard to bring him into the game
perhaps white can also play the move
King H1 after this and then play the
move F4 so I kind of like this like this
for white but we will see if he will
play the move Knight G5
and here is the head to head between
these two players one win for each and
then one draw it's a little bit
surprising guys that they didn't play
that many games in classical chess only
three games between these two very very
strong players that feels kind of even
to me yeah it's also very surprising
only three games I know you would have
expected these uh two heavyweights yes
exactly
um well things are heating up and I just
refer to the game of Fabi versus dioc
for just a moment because the Moon
Knight F3 in a root in uh in limzo
Indian I mean to say
it's a kind of intimation that with this
move you're you're playing something
different I don't know a reminiscioning
system with UT G2 G3 uh fabi's looking
for adventure let's also be an invite to
it for black to play D5 and transpose
into ragozen exactly d75 and just as you
say I mean how how deep is your
theoretical preparation right uh
castles Bishop to G5 C7 C5 and now the
move Rook C1 now I've had this WOW ages
and ages ago I I haven't even checked my
files uh for a long time the idea behind
Rook C1 is as simple as it looks uh many
times the double pawns on the queen side
Bishop C3 B take C3 can be vulnerable
Knight C6 and so on the fact that we
already have you in a pin and your
Castle kingside generally tells me that
you're not playing H6 and G5 so the move
Rook C1 first of all takes away
any possibilities of doubling uh my
pawns and after takes takes this really
suggests to me that the bishop is going
to be coming back to E7 very shortly one
is a prophylaxis move and now black
doesn't have a good reason to take on C3
because Rook C3 would be too good for
white developing Rook I could possibly
go to g3 at some point right clicking
unless there's a weird line here let me
just let me just see this one okay if I
go G5 Bishop G3 Knight
um E4
I wonder if this has been played before
well in that case let's turn to our
resident expert here avar we already
have uh a question for you uh is dioc
going to play for G7 G5 or is he going
to solve his pin with the move Bishop E7
what's Theory tell us yeah let's take a
look here in this position after Bishop
page four this position actually played
117 times wow according to my database
and the main move is D5 here okay uh
plate 71 71 times G5 actually very rare
only played twice so let's take a look
G5 uh I think it's a little bit risky
since he already canceled as you
mentioned so to play the move G5 so
Bishop goes on G3 and then if you play
Knight E4 we normally can play like this
with the King on it then I think just to
move E3 and actually we know we don't
really want to take on G3 anymore in
this positions because if we do it then
after Pawn takes we're gonna have a
problem with the H6 for example you know
you can play King G7 but it looks uh
quite risky even even some options like
Knight DB5 and then threatening to play
A3 and also Knight D6 so I think the
white is clearly better in this position
but instead of G5 he can play for
example the the main move which is uh
Diva D5 here which I think makes sense
because as you can see white is a little
bit behind in development here so he
needs to play a couple of more moves in
order to complete the development so I
think D5 is is the correct move and
actually very interesting after take on
D5 now actually G5 is actually strong in
this position because now we're
attacking the bishop and that way we're
unpinning the Knight on F6 and now
Bishop goes on G3 and we can play When
the move Queen D5
and we're sort of playing for a quick
development here and white again still
struggling with the development here for
example E3 yesterday I think you will
like this move Queen takes A2 picking up
the pawn so it's it's possible it shows
it's all zeros here but uh
if you don't want to give up the pawn
here after Queen five you can play the
move A3 for example but then I already
we have to take on C3 because we cannot
Retreat we will lose the queen and also
if we play Bishop A5 we'll have B4 so
that's why Bishop will take on C3 Rook
takes C3 and here's even E5 could be
played
uh where many moves away from completing
the development and Castle something
like this will give black a very good
play here so it's interesting to see if
he will play the move D5 here in this
position
so another option would be I I
personally would play something like E3
here just try to catch up on the
development and but again E5 is actually
a strong option here attacking the
Knight and if the Knight moves away
then actually here G5 is a possibility
to attack the queen attack the bishop
Bishop G3 and then continue with the
development Knight C6
and in Black looks fine in all this
lines so I think uh so far is a good
good opening Choice uh for deck I think
all right well thank you for that verb I
mean that move D5 and G5 and recapturing
the queen I thought we're going for
Knight takes D5 but let's jump over to
Bucharest as Christian is with a special
guest in studio
oh
thank you Yasser we are in this with a
very special guest the 13th world
champion and The Mastermind behind
granchester the one and only Gary
Kasparov Gary welcome to the show
Welcome to our renewed Studio here in
Bucharest this is the fourth year we
come here in Bucharest every single year
it seems like the organization steps one
notch above do you feel the same way
absolutely absolutely and today I spoke
with Augusta dragic she's in charge of
the organization and she was still you
know complaining that nothing was
perfect you know said look gusta if
everything it was perfect now what would
you do next year so let's see always in
room for improvement but as I mentioned
in my in my remarks at the opening
ceremony it's just it's it's phenomenal
event and uh and you could just you can
appreciate the uh um the attention paid
to every detail by the organizers and
again immense respect that the game of
chess receives uh here on Bucharest of
course we know it's in Saint Louis
that's the that set up standards but in
Europe I can I can hardly recall you
know the same
um Devotion to to the game of chess and
to chess players and you can actually
see the the face of the chess players
you know they did I think they were
thrilled you know so this is it's this
is again a moment I've been dreaming
about for so many years when I was on
the professional chess Arena that we
reached a point where chess will be
treated with this respect and this
honorable given to the game and the
chess players from both sides of
Atlantic and I have to say yesterday
during the opening ceremony first of all
there were no seats open absolutely uh
and the opening ceremony was Pat I like
iPhone being in television it's the you
know it's it's it's really the moment
where we could see that the game of
chess is spreading because it was so
many years again we heard this
complaints I just was so popular on
Fisher plates basket when uh kaspora
played carpool when just you know it's a
long time ago
um and I think people missed missed
these the the dramatic increase in in
numbers in the Wall of China the
following
that kept growing but it was not on the
front page this was not on on Main
television news
um and I think now we see that that how
all these changes you know on the ground
changes they have been uh translated
into uh into Big Splash so we we have
attention uh and also we we can we can
brag about about achieving success it
both in America and in Europe so Italy
now uh God this is the I think the the
most powerful uh most impressive network
of of Chess tournaments uh Bucharest
Warsaw Zagreb
um that's they ever had maybe again it's
a long long time ago but now it's um
it's so spectacular or the events are
glamorous and the wild Bucharest is
setting our standards but we also
are about to see the impressive event in
Warsaw and of course that group there
must be something about having the new
world champion as well as the Challenger
one let me finish the world championship
match how did that came about and how do
you feel about how do you see their
energy and Aura as well
look up
it's as we discussed just briefly
briefly before the interview that's it's
the first time where the world champion
plays in Romania yeah because macros
never played here so that's why because
Rubina urbailings are thrilled and they
knew in advance they would be a world
champion one way or another whatever
whatever uh would be the outcome of
matching a in in astronauts so it will
end up with a wall chamber and the
runner-up playing uh in uh in Bucharest
including Also let's not forget the
winner of the previous branches too
yeah so
um and um
I think that is just my impression but I
think ding still doesn't believe he's a
world champion because the moment you
say world champion I think he looks
around
yeah it's yeah it's it's interesting
Dynamics but um but I think it's again
it's important we move forward and uh
and uh while again I think everybody
myself included were disappointed by
Magnus decision but it's his call and uh
and again life doesn't end and um and I
think the fact is that we have all the
best players Magnus will join also the
tour in in in uh
uh so it's it's we'll make it make this
year branches tour the most
representative one so it's the it's a
really you know professional chess
Network established uh over years uh
that has every professional component uh
uh
from every organization of detail to you
know a whole um
um suspense of the event because it's we
we always try to build it um to keep the
the momentum not disappearing until the
very very uh uh last game in Saint Louis
and and I could tell you that this is
with this kind of success the branches 2
will grow uh again I don't know what are
the plans on the other side what feedy
is going to do but but we are very
comfortable we have strong sponsors uh
growing interest and I I would think
about expanding ranchers 2 to Western
Europe uh next year you mentioned that
thing might actually be incredulous
about being the world champion how did
you feel the first couple of weeks after
becoming a world champion yourself
uh
was there an adjustment period okay yes
it's uh yeah maybe not so much because
look I I became world champion in 1995
playing second match with scorp so what
I I already had so much time to to to
fantasize about this moment because I
played a long match with carpool you
know I played candidates so many things
happened almost by Miracle so Magnus
dropped then let's remember the last
game you know in in candidates he beat
Nakamura again there was another miracle
so it's the uh I mean Hikaru all he
needed to draw and and the game was so
Jewish so again this is the Stars you
know they work for dig and how many
times during this match against nepo
dink probably does okay that's horror it
was it could be over so many times so
this is and eventually everything worked
for him and I think he's still you know
he's he has to digest it and that's
that's look it's uh they're very bad
after madness he is very big excuse to
to feed them and
he understands his responsibility he's
not yet ready for that but look that's
something that you have to you have to
live with and but by the way I can tell
you it's not just about me but um I I
realized I was a world champion just
almost instantly but but many people you
know just destroy me they still thought
about Corporal it's like a psychological
so many years so it's again everything
takes time and the narrow again the
thing is in a very odd situation because
yes he is the world champion he's
undoubtedly he's a 17th world champion
it's legally just you know followed all
the rules and procedures that's why I I
always said that you couldn't compare it
to 1993 moment it's more like 1975
moment but Fisher left carpool was you
know the world champion and and uh he
was the dominant player he quickly
established his domination dink has to
perform at a time where there are many
competing forces and you have Napoli C
or Fabi is here and also alireza and you
still have madness madness is there also
so that's that creates a very new
momentum for the game of chess which
again fantastic as as someone who's
watching the event so I'm
I'm really happy that we have this new
uh new Intrigue Gary it's an honor as
always to have you in the studio you
will be here for a few days
yes first for Rounds so when I'm just uh
let's see what happens in in in the
first round I understand now we have the
delay yes we try to we try to cheat the
cheaters Yes
okay thank you
Christian thank you Gary
um wonderful insights on becoming a
world champion what that's all about and
indeed uh we are going to see a new era
as Dean Lauren uh plays in his first
tournament after winning the uh World
Championship let's jump to that game as
he is in a Queen's Gambit accepted he
did decide after being a little
surprised by D5 take C4 he did decide on
the conventional stuff and he played the
move b2b3 this is an old favorite of
mine it comes from Akiba Rubenstein the
Rubenstein variation of the Queen's
Gambit accepted and is it funny because
akiva's name is associated with so many
of these uh lines where you go for a
small Advantage when you play the move
B3 B2 B3 you no longer want to play an
isolated Queen part right your idea is
to play Bishop B2 Peter has become quite
popular it has I've seen it at the U.S
championships players played pretty
often so yeah because it gives white a
small but very clear idea okay he
recaptures with the Knight Bishop B2
castles Retreats uh from C4 uh the
Bishop from C4 the idea from White's
perspective he wants to play Knight D2
Knight C4 establishes Knight on this
great square and that's why black plays
the move B7 B5 but this allows white
also to play the move A4 and after takes
takes we can see that White's
more harmonious got a little bit more
development it's easier for white to
attack this Pawn on A6 than it is for
Black to counter and attack this Pawn on
B3 and when I see the move Bishop B7 I'm
thinking to myself boy I'd love to put
the Knight to A5 if I could go D2 C4 A5
I could really put a lot of pressure on
this bishop it may be one day in in the
near future sneak Bishop F3 the the
problem of course is that a lot of
pieces go off the board and it's not
that difficult for black to equalize but
for the moment uh I like deng's approach
varro what approaches do you like
yeah we have a lot of interesting moves
yes sir in particular we have a novelty
in this game between alireza and Wesley
so so the move A5 has just been played
and it looks a little bit unusual to
weaken the B5 square but I think the
main idea is after Knight C4 he wants to
play the move Bishop A7 just try to
preserve the bishop more more often we
see the move A6 played in a position
like this just with the same purpose to
to go back Bishop base 7 but I think the
the idea perhaps is when uh Bishop goes
back
on A7 then Bishop C2 white cannot expand
with the move B4 so this is one idea I
see here but it it does look a little
bit strange a little bit weakening the
position so I think uh maybe white is
slightly slightly better here he can
play maybe the move A4 here try to fix
the structure here and then he has a
good Square for the Knight to go to on
C4 for example Castle Knight C4 is one
idea Bishop A7
you definitely don't want to allow the
move Knight to B6 and here Bishop E3
so and after if you capture then for
example Knight takes C3 is an option
here very very small small Advantage
here but we have also some interesting
development in the Nepal game against
richer report in particular here in this
position we see Bishop B5 plate it's
lots of theory as you can see to almost
2300 games played and here we see the
move C takes D4 plate already uh very uh
rare move in this position the main
moves here Bishop D6 for example and in
fact I've played several games in this
in this position so he plays C takes D4
and knock we need to check Queen E7 and
here's Knight B3 played now
and now white is trying to recapture the
pawn on D4 and after Queen takes
E2 Bishop takes E2 white will capture
the pawn on D4 and I think it's a very
nice Advantage for white I think
definitely nepo is happy after the
opening outcome here he will have a
slightly better position we can play a
few more moves here just to see now
Knight F6 Castle
it's a bishop D6 and uh Rook D1 even
after capturing on D4 black will have an
isolated Pawn but with the queens of the
board it's going to be very difficult to
create any any attacking chances here so
I think uh nepo is going to be pressing
for a very long time in this position uh
let's take a look at this other game
here we have we actually this this is I
think a very sharp and interesting
position the game between Duda and giri
here so if we go back here so in this
position he takes D4 as I mentioned is
the most popular move here but he played
the move Knight F6 very rare immediately
we see there about 500 games played in
this position but Knight F6 is is very
rare So Knight takes E5 played B5 now
you essentially traded your Central Pawn
but now you have a uh your panel C4 is
protected and F3 plate just to protect
there is no good way to protect the E4
Pawn in this position so that's why uh
he had to play the move F3 here
to protect and now Castle plate not so
many moves played in this position but I
think white is perhaps slightly better
if he can play the move A4 here putting
pressure on B5 and here black can play
C6 or C5 so C5 is uh more uh aggressive
here to try to put pressure on D4 and
now Bishop E3 is an option to develop
and now C takes D4 Queen to D4 and I
think white is slightly better here but
still need to you know try to find a way
to get the bishop out in Castle to make
sure the game position is safe here but
you have to be a little bit careful here
for example if let's say you play the
move D5
for example if you do that it looks like
you have a strong sensor but then there
is a some tactical ideas for example
Bishop takes C3
B takes C3
and now Knight takes E4
F takes E4 and queen H4 check
so if you play the move G3 then Queen
takes E4 checking the king and now we're
gonna pick up the Rook on H1 and you can
try to play King D2 but then uh you can
play Queen F4 check for example and then
uh take on if even King C2 there is also
Queen E4 check so this looks extremely
dangerous for white so you have to be
careful uh uh still in this position so
Bishop E3 is the correct move here and
if you play let's say C6 try to uh
defend on before I think this will allow
white to get the development Bishop E2
Bishop E3 cast and I think white will be
enjoying a slightly better position
because of the the center here and that
will give him some good chances later on
in the game lovely imbalances for sure
you want to turn your attention to the
game of coffee for just a second because
that became a real surprise we were here
and VAR was explaining the move D5 takes
and I don't know about you but weren't
you stunned by the move Bishop takes E3
check because
that move would have never entered my
mind in the sense that whenever I have
my opponent in an absolute pin and by we
we understand pinned pieces I pin your
piece to your queen but an absolute pin
is a pin in which the pin piece is
pinned to the king that night wasn't
going anywhere why did he take them and
white hasn't played A3 yet not asking
the bishop to take so that was
surprising it could be that he
misremembered the prep maybe
but it became a really crazy position
anyway so after takes on C3 now actually
I might have paused if I was in Fabby
shoes because this move was so
surprising but he did play Rook C1 with
a reason right he wanted to defend the
night so he recaptured pretty quickly
G5 and now we get to the position and
queen takes D5 and this is where VAR was
saying yes you're going to love this
queen takes A2 but did you see this next
move on tap F to F3 and Fabiano's
playing so fast right this is all hour
and 31 minutes so he must still be in
his preparation no question about it now
with this move F2 F3 quite clearly white
uh it takes the E4 Square underneath
it's preparing to play E4 Bingo right
he's going to play E4 and I wonder if uh
black attacked the Knight on D4 after F3
which did happen well I did play E5 it
did so I'm sitting here saying I mean
I'm hearing var's voice in my head he's
saying so you got to develop get your
king out you know E3 Bishop E2 castles
and this move F2 F3 I think is being
kind of hyper aggressive right like
you're really throwing a gauntlet in
your opponent's face and saying I'm
gonna play E4 and what are you going to
do about it go ahead take my pie I also
think that white couldn't have played E3
because after E3 it's still hard to
develop the wide squared Bishop because
of the G2 Pawn so for example if I wait
just to show what you're talking about I
do want to play Bishop C4 by the way but
you did mention that I would be hanging
before fitting my G2 Pawn maybe I have
some Tempe for it but okay F3 really a
stunner move E5 kind of makes sense
right because one of the things I
realized that if you did play Rook to d8
like take my knight uh there's a problem
you might be losing your Bishop at the
end of the day right last rank is
unprotected exactly so okay okay it's a
F3
e E5 Knight C2 and we're caught up to
the players before we go to Christian in
Bucharest to ask him about his uh pick
for winning the event is this still
Theory bar I mean because Fabi has been
moving with great alacrity
no I think it's a new position here
after Knight C2 I can give you exactly
in this position so there was there was
one game played it looks like and the
move Knight B3 was played here this is
according my leeches database okay yeah
so but Knight C2 looks like a new move
in this position at least uh I think it
makes a lot of sense this move because I
think later on what Fabi is hoping to
achieve is let's say if the exchange be
able to play the move E4 and I think a
knight will be very well placed on uh E3
in this position but it's not so easy I
think black is doing fine here Rook d8
uh check for example King E1 it's very
important to play dynamically here to
play 95 immediately to put pressure
because let's say if you play the move
Knight C6 I think now after E4 the
Knight on F6 will be a very bad PC
because it's going to get restricted you
cannot go to G4 and D5 yeah it looks
like we have one game played in a more
comprehensive database yeah but we're
gonna go to Romania to Grandmaster kirua
thank you VAR well I see that you guys
were quite courageous Yasser and VAR
picking up of course the world champion
it reminds me of Maurice who was always
picking Magnus well there's no Magnus in
this event but I have to applaud you uh
Nazi for picking uh mvl so good job in
that regard I'm going to have to go with
a good friend of mine and I believe a
player that will have a Resurgence in
this tournament I'm talking of course
about Fabiano caruana and you know I'm
getting some help because I see that
he's getting a very comfortable position
out of the opening I'm seeing that he
definitely knows what he's doing he has
great preparation and as you were
mentioning bar that end game that we're
most likely going to see after Queen
takes the one king takes D1 black has to
be very precise you cannot play natural
moves such as Knight to C6 to just
depend upon on E5 because if you allow
me to go e493 then that's just simply
going to be a very beautiful very
comfortable end game for white two
Bishops a lot of weaknesses in your
position uh that I can Target with those
two Bishops I'm going to pick Fabi I
think he's going to have a great event
here in Romania
thank you Christian and it I I'm I'm
hearing you you're uh talking about your
pick and you said anybody can win this
tournament and you know when you say I'm
gonna choose Fabiano you well yeah I
mean I can understand why I mean you
know he's been the number two player in
the world for quite a number of years uh
but this ending that he probably has
today Knight C2 versus knight B3 if you
don't mind me asking you VAR uh Knight
C2 is fine but I've got to tell you I
don't see a problem with Knight B3
either because uh sure maybe the night
after the movie E4 could potentially be
very nice on E3 but I'm seeing the same
kind of ending that you were mentioning
takes takes check let's say we get
something like this this night could
also be very useful on the C5 Square so
what why isn't this a nice ending for
white uh yeah I think after the move
Knight B3 for example black and take on
D1 right and kink takes D1 a very
interesting move here is actually to
play the move E4 immediately try to
prevent white from playing E4 as
mentioned earlier if white can get this
move panel E4 it's going to be really
really strong and it will restrict the
Knight on F6 and also open up the
diagonal for the bishop but once you
play the move E4 yourself now you make
it a lot harder to develop this light
score Bishop here for example it's it's
very hard to get the bishop out if you
play let's say E3 that is going to run
into the move Knight D5 attack in the
rook and also picking up the pawn on E3
so it's gonna make it really difficult
to complete your development and you
have to play some strange moves like for
example Knight D2 and we know we don't
really want to play so many moves like
this while we're still undeveloped and
we have the King on D1 so this makes the
this will make things a lot harder for
example Rook d8 now pinning and it's
it's risky definitely to play like this
and now again this 95 move we see very
often in this position it's a crucial
move here to try to attack the rook and
create create threats so I think that's
the reason uh he played the move Knight
C2 because
if we go back
here Knight on C2 is better place
because it will be controlling the B4
and E3 squares just in case in a same
same position for example 95 plate the
Knight on C2 is well placed guarding the
B4 and E3 square and again he's hoping
to play the move E4 and then put this
Knight on E3 eventually
thank you for that for a very very
subtle differences there I I'm still not
sure I grasped the nuances between the
C2 and the B3 square but I can
understand that on C2 I am defending E3
what got your attention so far uh in the
in the five games
impressed by service preparation of
course not surprising but still very
impressive that I think Knight C2 he has
analyzed this before and he knows that
subtle differences make all the
difference right let's go back to Ding
and mvl scale okay I want to see how
this is
going yeah we left it around these parts
D takes it's funny because it's exactly
here I thought was maybe a key moment
Rook takes A4 that's a kind of a move
that plays itself but there was also
something to be said for Bishop F3
Bishop F3 would have provoked Rook A7
and then the black play Knight D5
instead of okay seven yeah either way
we're we're more or less heading to
similar
um middle game position I want to say in
the sense that I'm heading for the old
standard s Square
A5 and I've included the move Bishop F3
in the game ding decided that he didn't
need it and he played the movie he
allowed just Bishop B7 and in the game
instead of putting Knight on A5 Dave has
put his Rook on A5 yes that's what I
wanted to say is he came up with Queen
A1 which is one of those moves uh that
you really like I've always liked the
batteries you know doubling up you know
putting whether it be on the diagonal or
doubling up on a with the with the major
pieces in this particular case the queen
is the best supporting actress if you
will on A1 she radiates her energy
towards the A6 Bond like give me Bishop
takes a six is a possibility at the same
time on the long diagonal towards G7
after Queen A1 well Knight C5 that's a
nice attractive move it defends upon on
A6 it attacks the rook and just as you
were saying Naji the Knight doesn't land
on A5 The Rook lands on A5 I wouldn't I
wouldn't have been on that one but Rook
A5 what's your thoughts or is this
Knight gonna go now from D2
I guess uh I guess
before and maybe the night is going to
end up getting traded on e4 not sure I
do like the Rook on A5 you do it's
surprised me that it cannot be attacked
at least not yet right and it looks like
a pretty strong piece putting pressure
on A6 and C5 right and maybe before B5
is coming
exactly exactly I I see that the other
thing I do like about The Rook on A5 is
a move that might be attractive at first
blush would be a move like Queen B6 more
or less keeping A6 defended key and then
you stop and you go wait a minute why
did I why did I walk into Knight C4 with
a gain of uh Tempo against my queen so
there are there are things that black
still has to solve here
um and this Pawn on A6 is again as
mentioned before
I find the pawn on A6 much more
vulnerable than the pawn on B3 and I I
like it when I can attack my opponent's
weaknesses and they're having a hard
time attacking mine uh back over to VAR
I see you've got the Anish game up on
your board
yeah let's take a look at this position
now and we have a very interesting so
this position has been played uh several
times here and we see some uh the games
here in the database here and normally
uh White plays the move A4 here
immediately to put pressure on B5 and in
a previous analysis I showed C6 or C5
can be played but instead of that do not
play the move Bishop E3 and one thing to
mention if you look at the clocks here
Anish is definitely in his prep here and
he has already significant advantage on
on the clock at this moment so after
Bishop E3 played and uh we have a move
C5
Bishop E3
and C5 played now putting pressure on
before and now we have A4 so I think
this is very important to try to create
weaknesses here on B5 and it's all about
timing here I think black has to play
very quickly here to try to take on D4
but again computer is showing an
advantage for white and again Queen
takes D4 actually you want to trade
Queens in this position this is for
example already a very big advantage and
we see this structure that you know
we're trying to get in a fabianos game
as well the 1906 is actually a very
badly placed here because it's simply
being cut off here cannot go to D5 and
G4 so
and now uh back to Yasser for Romania
nice
um I like the queen trade there but
let's jump to
um Bucharest and Christian who has a
special guest
thank you yeah sorry yes we are indeed
with the Romanian Chess Federation
president Vlad Ardell Vlad first of all
Welcome to our show how does it feel you
must be proud you've seen this project
start four years ago now four years
later how do you feel about the progress
that has been
so thank you for having me
um it's an honor and a pleasure and I
feel Joy at heart that we are the fourth
time here in Bucharest it's a dream come
true we never thought initially so far
but uh here we are we've seen yesterday
an opening Gala which was amazing
um I'm just coming from the playing hall
now and it's filled with
um with kids with Young Generation
chess is having a momentum and
grantchester definitely helped raise
this momentum here in Romania so a big
thank you speaking of the Young
Generation we have the world champion
here for the first time in Romania we
didn't have Magnus Carlton but now we
have the England here in Bucharest how
important it is the new generation to
see their Idols inflation balls it's
very important so we've seen yesterday
uh how many kids came to play the um the
simultaneous game uh where ding liran
has also participated and I heard
feedback so it's amazingly important I
just spoke with couple of friends who
happens to be chess instructors here in
Romania and they're just telling me they
are fully fully fully booked so they
don't have time for their weekends any
much longer because the Young Generation
is just very hungry for chess I think
this is a um a follow-up to these
fantastic events that grantchester is
bringing to Romania and it's really
moving the um the community from the
from the from the ground up so it's very
important
now tell me about the challenges you've
been running the Romanian transpiration
for quite some time now what were the
biggest challenges
um taking it from where it was to where
it is right now making that progress
well I would say it's down to the team
first so um
we've created a fantastic team that
worked together now everyone knows what
they have to do and we have
responsibilities for each and every
project that was one second was
definitely getting some sponsors in
because all any project needs blood
needs money so money it's the blood
running through the project systems so
um with the foundation superbet
Foundation one United Property is now
the largest bank in Romania is coming to
the Federation so we see and also big
telecom companies so we see a top five
top 10
big Romanian corporate coming to uh to
chess coming to Romanian Federation as
umbrella sponsors which is definitely
great so these are the two pillars on
which we we can build projects and yeah
I think we can say that we had a very
busy years very busy last year and they
started very uh in a very great momentum
this year as well we have our uh Grand
Prix festivals which are really
um Coming uh coming up they they bring
more and more
performance chess players in Romania so
I think it's um it's it's going on the
right track Vlad you're a player
yourself as well you're a fan person
foremost how do you feel the atmosphere
in the playing Hall ah it's fantastic I
just coming from there and it hopes that
my humble
chess skills could read uh almost four
games out of five because one played by
firuja in Wesley so it's E4 I'm a D4
player but all the other four matches I
can decode
um and then be in the game so it's a
fantastic feeling and you can you can
feel it in the air everyone appreciates
and I think grunge's story is really
welcomed here in Romania and more and
more people are following it up either
here the whole or in digital media live
Transmissions everything Vlad thank you
very much for everything you do with the
grand Chester with the Romanian trans
Federation thank you for having me thank
you
thank you Christian thank you Vlad
indeed a nice president of the Romanian
Chess Federation you can feel the
enthusiasm of what's going on VAR I
wanted to say that in your absence uh
Tom found darush
Schwartz a Grandmaster who's keeping an
eye on the Novelties and daru said that
in the game of Wesley so and Ali Reza
this is a they've transposed they they
got to this position and for me and the
novelty is Bishop takes E6 that's a real
surprise move because in these oh um
well I want to say the Italian games
truthfully white tries to retreat retain
this bishop the light Square Bishops
keep the tension as as much as he can
sometimes just backing off with Bishop
C2 are the times playing the move Knight
C4 to avoid the bishop trade also
trading and allowing the pawn to well
kind of cover some key squares open file
uh surprise
yes but I think alireza knows what he's
doing sure and after Knight C4 which he
played yeah he's trying to exchange
blacks uh black Square Bishop which is
pretty unpleasant looking at f2 so that
if black goes back I think white can
follow up with Bishop E3 Bishop E3 okay
fair enough to go into the Four Knights
position right because that's exactly
what it is right it's going to be uh
well it's a four night position with 16
pawns on the board so it's a closed
position uh but this trade on E6 I don't
know how did it strike you of our uh
well-timed poorly time great idea
yeah I think it's it's an interesting
idea definitely your move Bishop
situyaser will is is a fine move as well
but I think what he's trying to do here
is after exchanging only six Knight C4
played he's trying to play Bishop A7 and
now Bishop E3 quickly and if Bishop
takes E3 uh he can take Rook takes E3
and trying to play this move d4 uh
quickly trying to try to break the
center here and uh perhaps the pawn on
A5 is a little bit weak the pawn The
Square Room B5 we can try to play A4
also later to try to establish a nice
Outpost for the Knight on C4 because
it's gonna be very difficult to play the
move D5 in this position but for example
here black actually can play the move A4
which is a top move by the engine so
this not only uh stops the move A4 it
also now controlling the B3 Square so I
think but now white can play D4 so it's
very interesting now for example you
have to take now after D4 is played you
really have to take now because you
cannot allow D takes E5 in this position
so after take e takes D4 C takes D4 and
now you have to watch out for the move
E5 and D5 in this position so Queen D7
but now white has the nice open C file
for The Rook to go to so I I prefer this
position for white I think it's uh
slightly better here for white very nice
uh thank you for that for a game also
that caught my attention uh I always
loved this when I was a kid I like
moving my king in the opening don't ask
me why I loved it loved it and after the
move Bishop before check I'm referring
to the game between a nepo and Richard
rapport
yeah Bishop D2 Bishop takes I love this
move King takes D2 uh I'm retaining the
idea I'm just going to win back by Pawn
on D4 and I thought that the move Knight
F6 was perfectly fine Knight takes E4
and then I was just stunned by the move
Bishop D7 uh that was really shocking in
fact going back to this position I'd
expected nepo to play the awkward move
Rook F1 why because after Knight E4
check I wanted to move my king back to
C1 and keep the pawn on F2 defended I'll
take this I'll win the tempo back with
F2 F3 but I was thinking that after
Knight takes e4s saw in the game Richard
would play check everybody would play
check you would play King E1 because you
have to defend F2 and then after you
move for example like castles the root
would go to E8 and White's marginally
better how would white try to fake
Castle here F3 F3 King King F2
absolutely but this was a real shocker
for me was the move Bishop D D7 and
darush didn't like this move at all
either like he was like what what are
you doing uh because it's one of those
positions when you get an isolated Queen
Pawn you're the one who wants to have
play
the bishop on D7 pretty passive yeah it
feels really really passive so this is a
game that's turning I think into nepo's
favor we'll keep an eye on this one and
I wanted to say also darush pointed out
another novelty this is in the game
between dingler in and mvl
everything's fine we got here to Rook A5
where we were thinking okay let's see
what we can do
to
make the A6 Pawn the focus of the attack
and you're thinking to yourself well is
black you would like to do moves I don't
know Queen D5 Queen D7 Rook C8 maybe 95.
maybe Knight D5 you know get your pieces
and go go go
and H7 H6 novelty what was that move I
I'm I'm mystified what the idea of H6 is
I'm mystified because I mean okay if I
said maybe a waiting move to see what
White's plan is certainly it's a a
waiting move from that perspective and
you make lift but I'm sitting here
saying that white has got a lot of ideas
of activating his pieces including the
move Rook C1 just putting in immediate
pressure if you will against the Knight
on C5 again that Knight on C5 is making
some defenses of the Pawn on A6 if the
Knight were to go back that would be a
full disaster this is not what you
signed up for or when you played any of
this uh can I go to E4 after one or sure
let's lose the A6 Pawn well that would
be the first thing I would like to ask
is uh and I think the answer is frankly
yes uh also don't don't forget I might
just play for the two Bishops with
Knight C6 so I'm questioning this move
H6 I'm uh I'm not I'm not a happy camper
if I was mvl but VAR you've got the game
of honest Geary what's going on there uh
well uh interesting moment here yeah sir
now white has to make a decision here
and uh Duda has been spending a lot of
time here as you can see he has 54
minutes versus 120 so he's not quite
sure yet how to take back on the floor
so it's like a decision time for him
here but I think it's it's to me it's I
think pretty clear you have to try to
take with the queen because that's going
to allow you to exchange queens and
develop more pieces here and if you take
with the bishop you're again moving the
same piece twice and again there are
some there are some problems after the
move F3 the king is a little bit
weakened for example if you take with
the bishop it also looks very strong
because now you're threatening to take
on B5 but now it's actually very very
strange move but it looks like the best
move here is Queen D6 not an easy move
to spot here the point here is after
Queen D6 you want to play the move Rook
V8 here so for example if you capture is
one of the the fascinating lines is Rook
d8 now putting pressure on the bishop
and now you're gonna give you have to
give up the bishop actually here play
Knight takes C4 and now Queen takes D4
Queen captures D4 Rook takes D4 and now
we have this move Knight B6
now attacking the rook and again the
line doesn't end here it still continues
after a takes uh
B6 Rook A8 and Bishop D6 and uh again
the evaluation shows zero zero zero at
this point so it's it's incredible
position that uh with all this material
imbalance it still shows equal at the
moment in fact it's actually funny Rook
takes A4 uh Bishop B4 it's uh uh
possible possible repetition we can have
in this position
so but uh yeah so we're still here at
this moment and I think I think Queen D4
is just being played so uh natural move
here by Duda and uh Anisha already has a
nice advantage on the clock but I still
like White's position here and in fact
the best move here for black would be to
play the move Queen E7 actually keeping
the Queens on the board with the idea to
play Rook d8 here to put pressure on the
queen so for example the line will
continue a takes B5 Rook d8 attacking
the queen now you're sacrificing another
Pawn but you're trying to get the
development here Bishop E6 and very very
complicated position it's it's very very
concrete Queen E2 and now Queen C7
putting pressure on the Knight and also
on C3 and only moving to play Knight C4
here and you will play an ibd7 and black
has a very nice leading development
engine still showing slightly better
position for for white but very
complicated
and back to yeah sir wow VAR that's just
a crazy double-edged line there with all
those Pawn sacrifices I just mystified
Queen C7 hitting C3 and so on since my
bandage might still be in his prep yeah
and the move he did he ended up uh back
to yuvar he did capture on B5 and Rook
uh rook d8 and they're going down that
Primrose path that you were just
dictating to us uh we're expecting Queen
takes C4 but for for for me both players
seem to be in their prep you can just
see that uh anisha's just played the
move Bishop E6 with hardly uh a second
thought and we were gonna see Queenie
too just as you prescribed
here we go
you're a Nostradamus yeah well I have
the engine helping me right of course
but yeah it I would be a little bit
scared in this position actually because
it's I know white is up two pounds but
uh developing as you can see black has
already completed his development and we
still have the queen on an awkward
position Bishop is still stuck on F1 and
uh it seems a little bit risky for me
and you know the amount of time Duda has
spent I think his
sort of on his own maybe he had studied
this line long time ago trying to
remember but he has already spent 30
minutes and an issue is definitely still
in his prep here and it's easier to play
for black I think rookie C8 is coming up
and you have to be really really careful
here so white has to play some very
precise moves for example like Rook A6
it's one of the best moves in this
position but not easy to spot the point
is now if you play let's say Rook ac8
then you have Rook C6 idea just try to
blockade a C file but again not not easy
to play moves like this when you have
your king side undeveloped here your
queen is black eating and you're long
ways you know you need a lot of moves
here to complete your development so
that's the that's the scary part I think
for white in this position thank you VAR
as we get uh prepared for our first
break we always like to stop in uh at
our friends at Q Boutique our local
favorite gift shop and we've got a
special uh going on available right now
qbt is this GCT men's jacket it is a
lightweight cotton zip up with pockets
featuring The Grand chest logo on the
front left and it's available
exclusively
at Q Boutique St louis.com
and we're going to go on our first break
and we're going to see you on the other
side all right we'll be back after a
short break
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
it's 2023 and the grand chess tour is
back for its eighth trip around the
world inspired by former world champion
Gary Kasparov the grantchester hosts the
top players to compete for top prizes
eight of the world's best joint
tournament wild cards and travel to four
different countries to fight for a 1.4
million dollar prize fund the tour kicks
off in Bucharest Romania for the
Superbad chess classic then things speed
up as we move to Warsaw Poland and
Zagreb Croatia for the first two rapid
and Blitz events the tour then makes its
way to St Louis Missouri for the final
two events we're back in November for
the St Louis rapid and Blitz and the
illustrious sinkfield cup when points
are up for grabs the best players show
up who will be crowned the new Champion
find out when the grand chess tour
returns
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everyone as we are here in
round one and these are the pairings
that we're looking at
Rosie I have to say uh we've got five
really exciting games the I I love uh
the positions that we're seeing here
early as we're getting underway
um in particular let's just Dive Right
In in the game between nepo and uh
Richard after the move castles long well
mepo said don't mind if I do I'll put my
knight on C5 Rook E8 and this is a kind
of one of those visual moments like all
the pieces in the center of the board uh
go for it but I think the Salient factor
in the position still to my mind is the
isolated Queen pod for example from the
passive Bishop on D7 bingo if
I'm playing the isolated Queen pawn and
if this bishop were anywhere where it
was really active let's say G6 I would
think that I have
um
compensation for my structural
inferiority let's just say I play a move
like b2b3 and I look forwards to playing
Knight to D3 in trading pieces I think
it's a long-term Plus for uh Jan he
plays easily there's no there's no risk
comfortable Advantage exactly speaking
of comfortable advantages let's jump to
the game of Fabiano uh when we left it
we left it around the uh this moment
after King E1 Knight D5 Rook D3 the
players very quickly got themselves to
this Bishop's two Bishops position and
again I feel that it's a favorable
position for white that white is making
um
well I play on one goal that's that's a
little a little bit stronger I just like
white pop is going to go for H4
well let's take a look the last move was
night Rook trade let's see it H4 uh it's
one of those things do we get a chance
to use our Rook now that we've opened up
the H file where do we go it'd be better
if we had two Rooks right now being the
double up that would be great we're
missing one but here it seems like why
it shouldn't have enough for any kind of
attack on the king side right I mean if
you if you had the follow-up Rook H5 so
it I mean
if this gets us nowhere
then I'm not sure H4 is going to be one
of those moves that I wouldn't have
rather have substituted with a move like
I don't know Bishop F2 let's say I
played Bishop F2 uh this is the idea G3
yes precisely uh just driving to my mind
when I play strategically or think
strategically I really reduce it to the
following I ask myself the question
what's your best piece right what's your
worst piece what's my best piece what's
my worst piece so something about the
Knight on F4 is Black's best piece but
there's something about the bishop on G3
it's my best piece too
it can be right and so that's why I'm
thinking let's let's get rid of your
best piece let's improve my best piece
and so on and maybe finally develop the
king side and exactly right exactly and
uh let's go I forgot white can have
Castle King already moved yeah King's
gonna go back to D2 this is the crazy
game that uh VAR has been talking about
the game between uh Duda and Anish as
Anisha sacrificing Pawn after Pawn bing
bing bing bing bing but he's got a lot
of compensation with this move Queen C7
uh you know attacking both nights
precisely uh the knight in C3 as well as
the Knight on E5 and the move that we
thought was
forced
forced was Knight C4 and VAR had been
pointing out that the move Rook A6 with
the idea of Rook C6
should net white as a pull I'll say
unless dude already knew this position
finding Rook A6 and Rook C6 at the board
yeah
that's pretty hard I think B6 is easier
to spot well this is a question because
uh both players have been playing pretty
fast Anish even more so but the move B6
boy that's a challenge bar that's a move
in your face what did the engine say
about these six
well B6 is actually I like this move a
lot I think it's a really interesting
move and it's going to try to simplify
the position so let's take a look at
some of the lines now so sure uh again
Knight C4 was uh one of the top engine
moves but again from practical point of
view it's very difficult to play but B6
now uh the main line is Bishop takes C3
B Tech C3 Queen C3 check and now you put
your King on F2 okay and now if you take
on A1 this very nice move B7 Now The
Rook is trapped on eight and you have to
play the move Knight bd7
and now in this position white will take
on A8
forcing Rook takes A8
and now we can try to simplify the
position after taking only 797 and now
we need to get the development here and
you can play the move Queen A6
now try to trade Queens but black
doesn't want to trade because if you
take on A6 after Bishop base6 I think
it's clear the white is better in this
end game because Rook will go to A1 and
there's a good chance you're gonna win
the A7 Pawn so you have to try to keep
the Queens on the board here and play
for example Queen B1 is one option again
it's a little bit more difficult to
complete the development here but you
can try to trade cool so it's possible
we could see some kind of repetition
like this because you also don't want to
give a black time to play Rook B Rook B8
and Rook Rook B2 check so so something
like this could be played I like this
move B6 I think it's gonna simplify the
position and now Anish is thinking and
trying to figure out what to but he he
really has to take on C3 there is no any
other good moves in this position
because if you take only five for
example then simply after B7 uh you're
you're in big trouble here because after
you take on C3 Pawn takes C3 Queen C3
check King F2 and now you cannot take on
A1 because the Palm will take the Rook
on A8 another game that is very
interesting right now is uh firusha and
Wesley so they kind of followed the the
previous variation that we went over
right here the move A4 was played again
it's a very logical move to prevent
white from playing the move A4 and also
control the B3 Square so the coin is not
going to go there so D4 was played
trying to get the control of the center
it takes D4 is forced and white wants to
put the Rook on C1 I think white has a
small Advantage here D5 was played and
by Wesley and now takes and Knight D2
yeah this is interesting moment here 92
it seems a little bit less natural for
me like for example for me it'll be more
natural to play the move Knight D5 but
again just after take if you take back
with the Knight
block can maybe put the pawn on C6 and
has a very stable Pawn structure so you
can play like this and the move Knight
bd2 actually you still have some work to
do because the Knight on C6
you kind of want to remove the Knight
and play the the pawn on C6 which is
going to take some time and there's
still some weaknesses but I think black
position is fine here for example he can
play the move Queen D6 and try to play
Rook 88.
great stuff across the board I'm seeing
all of these games uh well they're
they're all flowering and challenges uh
for uh all the players here
um I just want to
turn to the game of nepo and uh Richard
Rapport for a moment because he did play
the move b2b3 but darouch wasn't
satisfied with this movie you can
consider this an inaccuracy whereas I uh
I just felt like you know this is a kind
of a move that I want to control yeah
but darush felt that white had an
advantage and
a2a4 was the way to prosecute a better
way of Prosecuting the advantage was the
move a2a4 and I feel like and probably
nepo feels the same way that white
doesn't have to rush right because their
advantage is still comfortable and black
doesn't have any counter play come in so
B3 Sims yeah again that was that was my
uh knee-jerk move but I also wanted to
bring up something Vari that you said in
that game of Wesley uh I must say that
the move Knight nothing's wrong with
Knight C4 to D2 but it's it's such a
natural move in my mind to play the move
Knight E5 Knight takes E5 Knight takes
E5 and you mentioned after C7 C6 that
Black's position is pretty solid and
I'll grant you that this it's not like
uh it's terrible or anything but if you
were just to put one or two more moves
on the board Queen to D3 this night on
E5 is eyeballing a very beautiful Square
on G6 you've already made a a rook up
and over you're about to play Rook G3 or
maybe Queen G6 and my gosh I mean talk
about an attack for free I haven't even
said I can't catch up very quickly here
it was Knight E4 Knight E4 okay
uh attacking F2 and kind of also
provoking F3 you do right I'll fall for
it I think in the future I will have
Queen H4 and maybe have similar ideas
Queen G5 possibly right but for the
moment your knight is hanging right will
you jump into G3 or will you
six F5 also looks interesting okay okay
so yeah again it's what I just I don't
know I just felt that
I was attacking maybe it's one of those
optical illusions you know like you
think you've got the doubled e you know
your doubled Rooks on the E file and yay
yay and then suddenly it all goes wrong
but still I
oh it does look better Knight E5 uh what
did the engine say about the move Knight
E5 conversely to Knight D2 how did it
judge those two the differences in those
two moves so far
yeah they're very similar and I think I
also agree with you yeah sir that
position with Knight E5 looks a little
bit better for white it's like 0.8 at
the end of the line so 95 is I think a
little bit slightly stronger move in
this position uh
now let's take a look here he has to
take and actually engine also gives
another another possibility actually
even to take with the Rook ah yeah so
this is another option
um try to just have the the control of
the e-file but uh Knight takes E5 we can
I think the line that you guys were
looking at it's it's fine uh instead of
C6 immediately black can also start with
the move Knight to E4 immediately to put
pressure this is maybe slightly stronger
here because there is no need to play
the move C6 at the moment now you're
attacking on F2 and you don't want to
really play the move Knight F3 because
now you're sort of retreating and now if
you play the move F3 Knight will go both
moves are actually very good here you
can play Knight D6 but also you can put
a knight on G3 because knight from G3
can go back to F5 put pressure on the
rook and also on the weak pound on
before and again it this shows that the
buck is actually absolutely fine here
there is enough control play after
Knight F5 against the on on deforge okay
that explains why maybe Knight D2 to
stop this Knight E4 stop a second it
looks like I could have taken with the
Rook on E5 as far mentioned yeah I have
slightly better position rookie five
doesn't
look that natural
I somehow I like leading with the knight
in Queen D3 and all of that good stuff
let's see how our new world champion
dingler in is doing against our
defending Champion uh so as he predicted
he played Rook Z1 Rook C1 Rook C8 and
even though
um I like White's position the time the
clock times are actually quite favorable
for nbao and this state has really been
taking everything is used to having
two hours
right world championship match right the
time control in the world championship
match is very very different from the
classical time control that is used here
in this uh Grand chess tour and uh
dingler and it doesn't look like a a
player who has his next move ready like
sometimes you you can almost sense the
hand is ready to go in this case not not
so much so Rook C1 C8 what's going on so
I just realized that our picks are
playing each other in the first round
yes I picked up on that too I I take the
white pieces
right Rook C1 Rook C8 just defending the
night on C5 and again that night on C5
was doing a very good job at defending
the pawn on A6
um
so it feels a little precarious right
like if white gets B4 and he he gets to
do what he wants to do what shall we
still have a look the problem with
before is that when we played B4 trying
to win a six Pawn yes we're also hang in
the before Pawn because that's the
problem it moves The Bishop's attacking
okay so but where do we go with the
Knight probably E4 all right let's do it
Knight to E4 let's take this guy
Queen takes okay let's take this guy
yeah and I'll take back with a knight
okay and let's take this guy
here I can either take one before right
away be careful or say go 96 because if
you take on B4 right away I did hope I
did have a cheapo in mind no Queen E7
Knights assistant that's the Cheapo I
added mine
didn't see that oh but suddenly I right
I suddenly realized that the queen on A1
I was saying that the best supporting
actress right she was attacking A6 but
she was also attacking G7 well that line
actually worked out favorably for white
maybe black she'll take on A6 first and
then okay let's do it let's do it we'll
take on A6 first
and then we'll take on B4 yes but at the
same time
there's still some double attacks maybe
with knights of six Bingo that's exactly
right feels like oh I have to be careful
I'm in Black so let's just see are we
doing something wrong here for MBL we've
played the move Knight E4
and we're trying what one of the things
about the move Knight E4 that may be
wrong
is it does open up the diagonal I'm just
wondering maybe you should go back to D7
in this particular case
and by the way guys B4 has been played
B4 has been played I was worried about
Bishop takes A6 and then possible Knight
C6 mode
yes Queen and Bishop on d87 so we so B4
on the board VAR and where Naji is
saying Bishop takes A6 did you want to
play Rook C8 or not or do you just want
to take it I want to keep the queen on
d8 for now don't have 96 options see
because the the thing is is I I didn't
know which is more disruptive right we
go Rook takes if we take with the queen
for argument's sake we do have
get a little bit craziness Now The Rook
is hanging
um jump in on this one uh VAR the move
B3 B4 is very concrete and what are the
engines telling us
um I think um yeah I think I feel like
this game is probably going to fizzle
out soon to a draw I think Knight cd7 is
the correct move and then there will be
liquidations you know white will take on
a six and black will recapture the panel
before we can take a look at some of the
lines
Knight cd7 for example now again the B4
was an interesting option to remove the
Knight but as Nazi mentioned in a lot of
these lines you're not going to be able
to protect the pawn on before you're
probably gonna drop that upon so if
let's say you play on C Rook takes C8
one of the options Queen takes C8 Bishop
A6 simply Bishop takes A6 Rook takes A6
Bishop to B4 now attacking the Knight on
D2 you do have the move Knight C6
putting pressure on the bishop and again
you cannot capture on D2 because of 97
idea but black can simply just Retreat
here after the move Knight C6 to both
moves are fine you can play Bishop C5 or
you can even just play Bishop D6 and uh
uh actually there is important moment
Knight C4 now could be played attacking
the bishop and it seems like now you
don't have a good Square to remove the
bishop to a 97 check but now Knight C5
actually a good move attacking The Rook
on A6 and if you capture on these six
Queen takes uh Queen will take on A6
this also could be avoided uh black is
doing uh black is winning here in this
particular line but if black doesn't
want to allow this you can also just
play the move Bishop C5 and uh it's
really hard to see how white will make
any progress here black will play Queen
B7 and bring the Rook on C8 couple of
more accurate moves and I think it will
just be equal but I want to take you to
the Nepal game because looks like he
might have made a slight inaccuracy here
he played the move King C3 here
um C3 is the better option here but I
can understand why he didn't want to
play this move because I guess he was
trying to maybe avoid this position but
actually surprisingly here after this
move C takes D4 he answer white has a
really really big Advantage here because
it's it's very hard to remove the knight
from C5 but from practical point of view
you don't really want to allow this
opponent has isolated pawn and now you
just have a symmetrical structure but
this particular position white has a
really nice Advantage Rook ac1 is coming
up and it's again very difficult to
remove the knight from C5 but instead he
played the move King C3 and
now
let's see here here black should take on
D4
and King takes only four it looks really
beautiful the King on D4 but now King
goes on C7 for example
and uh it's not going to be easy to
attack the pawn on D5 when you have the
King on D4 and black still has the
Knight on F6 if the knights were off the
board yeah I would feel very safe about
this putting the bishop on the tree it's
it's ideal but with the Knight on the
board you still have to be careful one
day if this Knight lands on F5 you could
be in a big trouble so this position
still white is a little bit better but
not that much here so Bishop D3 could be
played for example you can play Bishop
C6 and now you're ready to start to
maneuvering the knight uh possibly you
can play Knight H5 and uh you know white
is still a little bit better but uh not
not that much so in this position C3 was
a better move and the computer
evaluation is plus one in this position
if he plays the move C3 you can play the
move remarkable thank you for that far
and by the way we always enjoy your
questions to ourselves we love it when
our audience tries to poses questions
and catches and there's a way for you to
join the show and join the conversation
that's to hashtag us and ask the
commentators at St Louis
chess club and then it's hashtag
superbetchess classic so join the
conversation any questions you would
like uh for Naji myself or VAR now's
your time I'd like to draw your
attention back to the game for Jan for
just a second because I always felt that
a good General leads his army into
battle you know so like when I saw the
move King takes D4
I I like this for white and then I think
VAR was saying King C7 and I'm sitting
there saying well wait a minute
I have the more active King let me play
Knight takes D7
now you play Rook takes D7 or Knight
takes D7 I don't care which I will play
Bishop B5 yeah
so you're Exchange in a lot of pieces so
that we go into the end game with King
on D4 which is a big advantage that's
exactly what I had in mind so maybe you
want to play Knight takes D7 what do you
think of it and in in any case anything
where I trade trade more if I get a
straight
Rook ending well I got my king on D4
it's got to be worth something right I
think you're right I think Richard was
afraid of this exactly and he did not
play King C7 to avoid these exchanges
but he did trade on D4 Bishop C6 to
avoid the other trade uh he was maybe he
was a little bit worried yeah about
Knight takes D7 Bishop Bishop to
whoa
um however now can white start a pawn
storm on the queen side yes before B5
yes exactly that was my thinking as well
like did the is the bishop on a good
spot on on C6 I don't know
um would you like to play A4 Bishop B5
or would you like to play B4 B5
B4 B4 okay because my Bishop is better
than his and I don't want to exchange it
on B5 okay at least for now right if I
have time to play before B5 I think that
will bring white a huge advantage
I must say to my eyes I I love this King
on D4 I I like everything that's going
on in the position I'm not even sure
that Bishop C6 was a good move for
Richard so you're not at all worried
with King on D4 to eventually get
checkmated in the center not immediately
one of my favorite uh games of course it
was Nigel short versus John Timmon where
he moved to King up the board but people
don't know the evil twin
there's an evil twin to that game Nigel
short moved his King all the way up the
board against uh Big Al Alexander
bellyevsky and walked into Checkmate in
one they all remember the game of John
Tim on where Jan was forced to resign
but they forget the game where it was
made one and what happened was
billyevski made the move meeting one and
Nigel was going to respond
oops oops that realization
yes you have just been checkmated so
Bishop C6
um
do a double take on this for us uh if
you if you don't mind because seriously
I'm thinking we're thinking that yawns
for choice
yeah I think in this position uh White
is slightly bit slightly better 0.5 only
yeah 0.5 and actually the line you guys
were looking at after King C7 I want to
point out something here so King C7
they're about the same uh Bishop C6
working seven and after Knight takes D7
you absolutely have to take back with
the ninth here the line that you were
showing Yasser yeah Rook takes D7 Bishop
B5 is actually completely winning for us
yes like plus three here because after
you take only one Rook takes E1 and now
you have to move your Rook you cannot go
to Islam because Rook will take it and
you have to put it on D6 or d8 in both
cases white will enter on the seventh
round and let's say you play King B6 and
now A4 keeping the bishop there and now
getting ready to pick up the pawn on F7
so you can play A6 just to go a little
bit deeper on this line Bishop D3 now
again if you drop the F7 Pawn you're
gonna lose the game you can play this
move Rook D7 but now Rook takes D7
Knight takes D7 and both both moves are
very good you can take the pawn on D5
and you're up upon here but if we go
back to the game after Bishop C6 I know
you guys were looking at the move uh
before here here you you have two
options you can play the move B6 which
is very natural and the idea here is if
you retreat with the Knight this is a
very important move here I think you
need to put the bishop on A4 here to
prevent white from playing the move A4
A5 so here Bishop is actually going to
put some pressure here you don't really
want to take immediately because of a
takes B3 but you're just gonna prevent
uh White from playing the move A4 in
this position
um you can also play the move King C7
and actually uh I'm not quite sure if
you really want to play the move B5 here
because if you play B5 as we know in the
end game end games we have to be very
careful pushing the pounds too forward
because later on black king can try to
attack the spawn so here you don't
really want to play B5 I think you can
perhaps play the move A4 here this is
another option but I do like the B6 move
for black better with the idea of Bishop
to A4 nice thank you for that uh bar
just for clarifying one game that seems
to be racing towards a draw is the game
between dingler in and mvl as you say
our two picks
and here we see after Bishop takes Rook
takes Bishop takes Knight C6 Queen to B7
Bishop takes Knight takes and uh the the
pieces are being fast uh we removed from
the board definitely takes Queen takes
four Quick Draw exactly and they are
playing quickly pending force a queen
exchange as well
candy how
that's a good question
it doesn't look like maybe just Knight
of three
four Knight F1
four versus four now again as you said
at the top of the show there's no draw
offers right so I mean uh I think in
conventionally uh four versus four or
night night they would make some moves
and offer a draw but in uh our grand
Chester they can't they can repeat moves
yes for example here maybe Rook A8 and
they're looking for a repetition
yes and they're they're so professional
the figure the figure out
one way of doing it Rook takes a a queen
takes A8 I'm assuming Queen f8 will come
on the board yeah
and then wow okay this is all going on
very very quickly so we do expect that
this game will end in a draw uh we
haven't uh we haven't followed it that
closely but uh Christian's pick was
Fabiano and when we left it we thought
that Fabi was nursing a bit of an
advantage is that still the case of our
uh I think he is slightly better still
uh but it's it's not so easy black just
played the move A5 trying to play A4 to
create some Contra play Let's Take a
look uh some of the moves played here so
uh we left off around here so E4 was
played white managed to get that and now
Knight F4 Knight is actually well placed
here and uh it's it's very it's very
difficult to remove it you never really
want to take one F4 because he takes E5
will be played so Fabiano played Bishop
F2 a very logical move trying to play
the move G3 to remove this knight from
F4 but the problem is he's still behind
in development and now Bishop E6 came
with the tempo immediately attacking the
pawn on A2 and now you have to try to
react to this move so he played the move
B3 and uh immediately A5 played in this
position trying to play the move A4 and
creates some weaknesses on B3 and also
opening up the uh the line for the Rook
here so I think a position is about cool
it's 0.2 essentially just the equal
position here I think unfortunately for
white he needs couple of more moves here
to have an advantage here like for
example if you had a move like Bishop B5
uh and our first result on the grand
Chester A draw I think
for mvl it's a good day's outing uh yeah
with black uh Queen's Gambit accepted
true against the world champion Dragon
World Champion no particular issues uh
for for for
MBL in this game VAR he he had an easy
game absolutely yes a very comfortable
drill for mvl he opted for a very solid
opening Choice Queen's Gambit accepted
and perhaps avoiding some of the
preparation in grunfeld and made a
relatively easy draw here so he should
be satisfied with the result but let's
continue on this position now A5 move
played by the act just the clock
situation is not as much an advantage
for Fabiano 109 versus 51. uh A5 is a
very natural move with the idea to play
fortnite C6 is another option and I was
as I was mentioning it it's it's white
can play a few more moves in a row then
he will have a really nice Advantage but
unfortunately black always has control
play with this A4 move here for example
Bishop B6 is one of the top engine
Choice here to try to put on the eight
Knight will go to C6 and now getting
ready to play the move A4 so for example
you can try to put the Kink on C3 with
this idea kd2 A4 and now put the King on
City just to try to control the light
squares and here
black actually has a move G4 trying to
create a counter play on this side of
the board it's it's still a lot of
Dynamics here but I think block is fine
in all of these lines
interesting stuff I always thought that
when we played Bishop F2 that the idea
was to play G3 drive this Knight away
but the engine doesn't seem to be
particularly concerned about the Knight
on F4 intriguing let's turn our
attention to the game of Duda and Anish
Gary that was that move B7 B6 that
really actually
surprised me you know I I when we when
we get here and I'm I'm looking at you
know the attack on the Knight on C3 I'm
looking at the attack on the night on E5
I thought Knight C4 was forced and uh
dude I played the movie yeah uh a
different Choice V6 and the players went
down that whole uh path that we had
looked at earlier takes takes takes
takes takes takes Queen A6 remember this
one
and now just Queen B1 and I think uh
you've already even mentioned it as far
as Queen B5 here as well yes I think
Queen B5 uh yeah Queen B5 is uh actually
the next move here and there is a good
chance it will be a repetition here
because black doesn't really want to
exchange the Queens so for example Queen
B5 now the if you move the queen on A1
then it's just gonna be a repetition
after Queen A6 and if you try to you
really want to keep the queen on the
first round to prevent white from
developing the bishop and bring the rook
in because if if he can get the bishop
out Rook comes to A1 or C1 clearly white
will be better because of the two
Bishops and possibly the weakness on the
A5 this Pawn it's it's not going to be
that strong yet it needs to really be on
A4 to create some some threats so I
think Queen D1 could be played
and uh Queen D1 and
then Queen D3
and now again if you can try to trade
and to advance the a pawn for example
this is a possibility but I think black
will probably try to keep the queen on a
uh keep the queen on A1 just go for the
repetition because even though it shows
equal here I would prefer to play this
position with the white pieces yeah the
two Bishops very attractive and let's
jump to Bucharest where Christian is
with our new world chess champion
thank you Yasser we are indeed with
dingly ran our new world chess champion
first of all uh ding welcome to the show
but also it's our first opportunity to
congratulate you officially so
congratulations what an incredible match
tell us a bit about your journey from
Astana here to Bucharest was it
difficult uh are you tired how do you
feel uh emotionally as well as
physically right now after this very
difficult Workshop instrument yeah after
a watch after match I'm exact date
and but at least I have several days to
rest in Asana and then I I come there
yeah
the flight was at midnight it's quite
late
but I feel
pretty pretty good after arriving there
I
yeah and definitely such an important
Victory gives you a boost of uh
confidence how do you feel right now as
the world Channel
yeah but the parliament continues and
there are many tournaments ahead
so I will try to yeah
take it one step at a time just to
adjust to this new status of yours tell
us about the first game
um here at the Grand chess tour against
mvl
well he plays this line did he surprise
you with
taking on C4 yeah I expected him to play
the green fields
here
yeah play B3 which I played many times
uh
a million times online and offline
yeah the last time I played this
variation was I remember was over the
board game against Hikaru in 2019 where
I played Knight D2
continues B5 Bishop E2 Bishop B7
this time I played Bishop E2 what are
some of the ideas of this move Bishop
uh
A4 instead
you also maybe have some ideas of Bishop
F3 yeah but not now if Bishop F3 uk7
okay seven and that's good for for black
so A4 you immediately attack this Pawn
on B5 yes the change of the structure
yeah
take take 92 and here I was expecting 96
oh it starts uk6
maybe I
Bishop takes uh some Knight C6 would
have been a blunder uh in fact for for
evil but he did see it I I guess he
played the move Knight d7. yes it's
quite good
to put the Rook on A5 yeah H6 maybe he's
still in preparation since he plays his
move within 10 minutes yeah it's almost
that surprised me but maybe the idea is
just to wait to play a waiting move or
are you surprised that he was ready for
this particular line no I was surprised
for just this move H6 to do nothing on
the queen side to make waiting move on
the king size
so what's White's plan what was your
plan and here I had many many moves Rook
D1 Rook C1
is uh two most
hmm
uh seemed to me most
a nature move
yeah so you play The Rook C1 yes if I
when Rook D1 the idea to play nicely for
and open up yeah and he told me he was
going to play Queen B6 and then it could
be seven Queen C7
and this in fact seems to be the best
way for him to continue as well so maybe
it's the best also the best way for me
to
to try to get the playable position not
like the game yeah
and you play The Rook to C1 after some
thought through the C8 yeah actually
here when playing before I decided to
make the Quick Draw just to make a quick
draw after before simplifying the
position yeah
um how do you feel about your chances in
this tournament
um I know you must have spent a lot of
energy in the previous month but now you
have to get back in the saddle yeah just
step by step at least and today I
I feel much better than the previous
tournament normally I
I pray very bad with the first White
games I lost many wise games in the
previous tournament so today at least I
got a job
thing congratulations once again for uh
your incredible Victory and we're
looking forward to see what you have in
store for us in this tournament okay
thank you thank you guys back to you
thank you Christian as we have a single
result thus far uh doing drawing with
MBL our congratulations as well as we
get our first chance to congratulate uh
world champion and Dean Lauren along
with the King and uh our first result
and this was really a confusing I'm so
confused by the game uh between
um
alireza and
um Wesley because we got this position
and we've been talking about nitrates
yeah so one one variation that we had
been looking at was Knight to E5 Knight
takes Knight takes and the way we went
from here we had Knight E4 and other
ideas for black as well
only reason I played Knight D2 and the
first move that came to my mind is
whenever I see these types of structures
with black I always dream of the move A3
and then having this very very powerful
knight uh land on B4 so I was always
thinking that you play A3 here and
whether you take it and Away you go like
this is just the kind of stuff I like uh
when I saw the move Knight D2 I kind of
expected A3 he played Queen D6 okay he's
in my room yeah he's ready to play so
Ollie raiser played A3 and then well
Wesley said well let me put my queen
here it's a much more active Square than
d8
and then uh daru she's saying oh I
really love this movement I love it too
you do
I love it
what the heck improve your princess this
Knight is going to C3 attack in both A4
and D5 Pawns that improves your pieces
okay so check this out so when we play
the Knight to D2 we're trying to play
all four nights on the board right now
imagine I fall for your Insidious idea
and I go Knight F4
what the heck is going on so you went
night on C4 to D2 in the front position
right right you went backwards then you
went back again no no no you're ready to
trade nights and it's like you say it's
a slightly different position I guess
you could take with a pawn if you prefer
I think a rook take looks better okay
I'm concerned about if I take with the
pawn am I living A3 Pawn completely weak
and abandoned for the future
that's a good point okay so Rook takes
right so something
somehow I remember we had a queen on D3
we were doubling Brooks on the e-file I
find this remarkable uh that you're
moving the night around and then you're
agreeing to trade nights so one thing I
don't like in Black's population in the
current situation after Rook takes a
three is the Knight on C6 it's awkward
exactly placed and for that reason I
wanted to ask you your opinion on the
Move 985
so the idea again if you want to put
your knight on C3 and be very boastful
about it I wanted to put my knight on C4
night on C4 versus the Knight on C3
pretty big difference right
and uh how do you like these this looks
like a big Improvement for black exactly
exactly the night went into a very nice
position so I don't know what's going on
with this game
uh Knight to let's say Knight to A5
right
okay can we do something here because
this is what we want to avoid right
Queen takes A4 Knight here and this this
is a Tempo against the queen oops and a
Tempo against the real clubs so we want
to avoid that
um what should we do here 9c3 9c3 3
Knight C4 and then just drop back with
the Rook okay
oh my is it my birthday today rookie
five here yeah did I get it right
it's not my game
[Laughter]
good point uh Rook if I didn't see that
coming so your idea is if I take the
Rook take with a pawn that's a nasty
Tempo I'm threatening Queen takes D5
with a check that's awesome more pawns
on the queen side okay okay so rookie
five maybe I have to
me to pull in my horns just a little bit
with the move C6 just ignore the
sacrifice huh well I do what I get every
fiber my being wants to capture it can
go rookie E7 actually guys uh sorry 92
here it's actually trapping your Quinn
oh
wow okay that's good morning St Louis
whenever we uh blunder our Queens uh
it's an early morning for us here in uh
the beautiful city of St Louis Knight E2
Rook E5 came with a double threat isn't
that nasty so beautiful it really are
trapping Our Queen on the open board
Knight E2 rookie 5 and 92 I didn't see
it just blindness nice okay then well I
think the players avoided this line as
well
did they cut they caught up with our
analysis from earlier and this is where
because your instincts were right he
recaptured not with the pawn he captured
he recaptured with your with the rook
and Nashi uh take us through the
thinking because you said you were a
little bit concerned about the A3 Pawn
A3 Pawn eventually Black Knight is going
to make it to C4 right and I don't like
to have Rook stuck on A1 defending A3
for the rest of the game clear
and so the only advantage of taking with
the pawn however is that we have an open
B file so maybe but we also protected
the pawn right and you were about to say
unless you could exploit the open B file
but it doesn't seem like white can do
that so P takes it through would only
benefit black in my opinion okay
so if yeah for for me I would have been
very very tempted to take with the pawn
as wide taking with the pawn in my mind
means that the pawn on D4 is a little
bit bolstered allows this Knight a
little bit more freedom I think I prefer
my Rook on the e-file but you're making
a pretty good argument that if the
knight ever did land on C4 then a rook
is going to be Tethered to the A3 phone
and that's not a lot of fun he took with
the rook and we're up to date and what's
the current prognosis uh bar yeah I
absolutely agree with Nazi taking with
the Rook on C3 it's very important
because the night it's not it's very
difficult to move the knights from C6
another thing I wanted to mention the
Rook on A8 is tied up to the A4 Pawn
because you can really move it freely
because you're always going to have the
the pawn hanging on A4 another thing is
I wanted to pay attention on the clocks
56 minutes for alireza versus 28 and
Wesley is taking a lot of time in this
position it just tells us that he is a
little bit uncomfortable with the
position here so Queen D6 is played
actually one of the best moves in this
position try to consolidate and again he
needs to somehow move this Knight and
play the move C6 to stabilize the
position here but just because of that
now Rook ac1 is a very strong move also
very natural move between The Rook into
the game and now you can now move the
knights into six because you're gonna
have problems with your C7 Pawn here and
again it's slightly better position for
white and easier to play as well you
have to play something like Rook F4 in
this position try to generate some
counter play against the pawn on D4 so
it's uh it's about 0.5 Advantage here
for white in this position so you can
play Rook E3 now we can switch on the E
file try to create some threads with
Queen E2 Rook E6 perhaps so
a little bit a little bit preferable
disposition for white
I think
so let's let's take a look now at uh
another position that we have here
and here we we don't have any moves yet
still so after uh A5 uh this is the game
uh carwana against uh deak uh and tears
actually G3 was played Yasser your idea
because I think the whole point of the
move Bishop F2 is just to try to give
the option to play G3 and that's what he
is trying to do trying to follow it up
with that plan so G3 was played and
Knight goes back to H5 the best square
and now he played the move King D2 the
idea if you play A4 he wants to play
King C3 to maintain uh in the B3 Square
so but again actually black is
absolutely fine he can play here Knight
C6 for example he can also play G4 in
fact it's it's the engines are showing
slightly better position here for black
because again you're you need like a
couple more moves here to develop this
bishop and bring the Rook into the game
and I think black is gonna have enough
gun to play
wow I wouldn't have her guess that black
could be better by breaking up the king
side with G4 as we move to a break
we're going to show you is some of the
opening ceremonies uh that took place in
Bucharest that was hosted by our
colleague Christian we hope you enjoy
our footage
foreign
[Music]
fans to the opening ceremony of the 2023
Superbad chess classic Health here in
Bucharest Romania this is the beginning
of the grand chess tour season the
atmosphere is absolutely electrifying we
have the best chess players on the
planet right here right now getting
ready for the opening ceremony let's get
the party started
yeah I think the opening ceremony was
quite spectacular clear there's been
lots of efforts by the organizers that
was a
everything you know you hope for there
are speeches there were some singing so
good stuff especially with Gary being
there and all the other great Romanian
sporty people it was a very amazing and
well organized opening ceremony I really
enjoyed ever
tradition We Gather here in Bucharest
the game has great future because we we
know we have solid supporters that are
making sure that our game will be always
treated as it deserves so it always
gives me a great pleasure to to land in
in Bucharest because I know this is a
place where game is treated our beloved
came treated so well thank you trust
fans the opening ceremony has been
absolutely electrifying everybody was
having fun everybody was relaxed
speaking with their colleagues but you
know in the back of their mind round one
was definitely there we had a lot of fun
we had assignment with the 13th world
champion Gary Kasparov as well as all
the other players it was relaxed but
right now we have the games going see
you guys soon
[Music]
the muni's premier season bursting with
comedies romance and Magic Begins June
12th with the muni premiere of beautiful
the Carole King musical
the Epic Summit continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
Sister Act
single tickets are now on sale at
muni.org
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back everyone and our first
result uh it was a draw as ding Loren
got surprised in the opening by mvl's
Queen's Gambit accepted and they've
decided to trade off all the pieces of a
certain crucial moment and that's our
first result of the grand chest tour in
2023 and I'm looking at this game
between Richard rapport
and uh Jan nepo and I just saw this move
Bishop D3 and the more I'm looking at
this position maybe it's just me but I'm
falling in love with White's position I
mean
I've got all my pieces going forward the
night on E5 makes a great impression the
King on D4 I'm about to play I've just
played the move Bishop T3 that was my
last move yeah so Jen decided to not go
for the queen side attack with people
before and and so on I think in his mind
that's something he can return to
whether it be by C3 and B4 or by Bishop
B5 but in the meanwhile The Rook on A1
is not working so I'm about to play the
move rookie too I'm about to play Rook
A1
to E1 and then black has a real question
to answer for himself what does he do
what is White's threat exactly after
doubling the Rooks
I have no idea but what I do know is I'm
putting all my pieces in their best
squares right and something will present
itself if I if I maintain a very large
grip on the center rookie two rookie one
I don't know if I'm threatening Knight
F7 I don't know I'm threatening Knight
C6 but something will occur maybe it
will actually be once my Rooks are
doubled Knight G4 and I'll just play a
bishop ending with this very Advanced
King on D4 in the meanwhile I don't see
the counter play for Richard so again we
just have the movement can you find all
the accurate moves to
make sure they the position doesn't get
worse and to maintain quality
if it is even equal right right okay so
we go rookie two and uh VAR Jump Right
In on this one for us too because we're
sitting I'm I'm getting more attracted
to White's position and I don't know if
it's the position itself or it's just me
I'm thinking Richard has to
find some good moves help me out yes I
agree with you I think white has a nice
Advantage but the next one is actually
instead of rookie two which is I think
is fine Rook E3 is actually a Little Bit
Stronger okay so uh the idea here is
actually you really need to play Knight
D7 here otherwise this Knight only five
is very very annoying so Knight D7 okay
and now actually
um you don't really want to double up
the Rooks here because if you do this
the main idea now black has the move
Knight f8 and uh Knight is going to be
very very strong on E6 here so they're
like this line in particular Knight
takes C6 will allow Rook takes E3 Rook
takes E3 Rook takes E3 King takes E3 and
now B takes C6 and we don't really want
to allow this I think we'll lose our
advantage in this case that's white but
if we go back now to the move rookie 3
the difference is if he plays Knight D7
here we can play the move F4
and this is very important because when
he plays the move Knight f8 to play
Knight E6 you need to be able to play
the move F5 to prevent that so we want
to make sure we uh prevent the move
Knight E6 it's very very important and
now if you place F6 for example we can
just call Knight G4
and our Rook has protected on E3 by the
night and not where our Rook isn't on E2
where it would be pinned yeah and now
okay D6 if we just continue a little bit
more on this variation Rook ae1 yeah so
Rook takes E3
Rook takes E3 and now we capture back
with the Knight and uh White is white is
slightly better but it's not going to be
easy to break through but at least it's
pretty clear that white is present here
in fact I think C4 could be a very
crucial move in this position because
now if Pawn takes we have Knight to C4
check and then the A5 Pawn is hanging so
this rookie tree is very important to
play I think here and uh
slightly better it's not like a very big
Advantage here but very very comfortable
position and in particular this idea
with F4 F5
and uh yeah their head to head is one
win for Yan one loss and nine draws they
played 11 times and uh pretty evenly
match up so far wow uh in a couple of
the head-to-head matchups that you've
been showing as far uh some surprising
results were that are dead even that is
a surprise yeah it was nine draws
between these two Gladiators who are you
really uh used to throwing the patties
uh Rook E3 and that whole variation that
you were showing where the Knights Wings
itself to D7 to f8 and E6 and the
necessity of having F4 and F5
so that we can Safeguard our King on D4
I like that a lot Rook E3 uh I actually
thought you were going to be showing as
Rook E3 because you wanted to play moves
like F4 and Rook G3 not because you need
to safeguard your king nice points we we
left it some time ago it was about here
we saw the move Queen A6 we liked the
move Queen B1 and somehow we did not
repeat with Quinn before right somehow
we kind of convinced ourselves that a
repetition was brewing none of that
happened after Queen B1 Rook G1
defending the Rook so that the bishop
can move and so does this mean white is
playing for an advantage yes absolutely
I think VAR said it best if the pawn
were on A4
A4 I think we could be talking full
equality put the black Pawn on A2 we're
talking about a black Advantage put the
pawn on A7 and the two Bishops then I
think it's easier to play White NOW good
question yes and black take on H2 that
hanging ball exactly so he he definitely
uh you know the Rook defended the pawn
on H2 and when you played Rook G1 he
played the new Queen B8 with the very
expressed intention of capturing the
pawn on on H2 he played Bishop B5 and
like you just said you know like hey man
did you overlook this move Queen takes
let's take a look
um for the mo for the
for the first part I thought we were
going to take
maybe I'm doing something wrong
but now I realize Rook B8 Rook B8 I was
thinking Rook d8 but Rook B8 looks
better yeah I know that that was where I
stopped unless if you play Queen D7 and
then Bishop D2 Maybe
ah
so if you've played Rook ah but now you
can defend your
you Rook huh oh boy okay just a second
hold on okay so Queen takes H2 right
let's do it again Bishop takes D7 Bishop
takes D7 Queen B7 now the move that had
me pausing
was I did not see Bishop to T2 watch who
just pointed out and actually that looks
like a piece right yeah okay so you
thought Rook to B8 right
so should I play the old game of gift me
The Rook
I guess I have to play episode
so my idea is I want to be able to play
checking right recapture with check
so maybe I take on G5 and unlock D7
does the check give me anything Queen H4
or is it just one check
well it does appear
my mind just to be a single check
um here I will have to take on D7 and
allow you to retake the checks right
still black should be fine
I would think so I mean there is a
slightly annoying like my passer is
maybe more dangerous than than but yeah
I mean I I I'll be grudgingly suggest
that that's that's uh that's equal uh
VAR is there a hanging Pawn on H2
yeah I think he already took the pawn on
H2 and I think this game is probably
gonna head into a draw here uh you were
looking at the correct line after taking
on D7 so let's take a look
um definitely yeah we we have to play
after Bishop Bishop takes D7 yeah
um Bishop takes D7 definitely we need to
play the move Rook d8 which is the only
move here Rook B8 loses a piece just
after Queen D7 as you mentioned so we
can go a little bit deeper in this line
so Rook d8 now
um for example if white just wants to
make a draw you can play Rook D1
now a very important move here is
actually Queen H4 but also you can start
with this clever move yes sir Bishop E8
now it looks like you're blundering your
Rook but after he takes back you simply
give a check right on H4 King F1 and you
pick up the Rook on d8 and after Queen
takes A7 this will just be a draw
because opposite color Bishops so this
is this is one line and that's why I
think the game is heading towards the
draw here so uh Queen B7 Rook d8 so if
you just play Rook day but Bishop G5
might be a little bit more challenging
because now you're attacking on d8 but
here I think you can play this move
Queen B8 it's not the only move but I
think this is the most precise move now
if again if you just uh play Rook B1 for
example
Queen takes B7
Rook takes B7 we cannot move the Rook
because we're going to lose the bishop
on D7 but we just simply play F6 right
Bishop will go to E3 and again
um
you can play A6 for example
we continue with Bishop
B6
and you cannot move the Rook you will
lose the bishop so you'll have to play
the move Bishop C6 and Rook takes G7
check King takes G7 bishop d8 and again
uh White has a little bit of better Pawn
structure but opposite color Bishops
equal pan so this should be a draw as
well
so there are different ways but I think
uh the game is most likely gonna fizzle
out to join about uh five six moves
because they're just not going to be
enough material so there we go we see
Bishop takes D7 plate
and Bishop will take on the seven link
Queen B7
it's a very nice forcing lines there
with lots of Trades better draw it does
seem to be the inevitable outcome and
and let me again invite our audience I
think we're all waking up here in St
Louis Yay good morning St Louis to join
the conversation uh challenge us we are
we're formidable and
give us your questions and there's uh
and ask the commentators hashtag super
bet chess classic uh to ask Raji R
myself any questions that you might have
as we are seeing the game between Duda
and Anish well sadly fizzle out let's
just jump into the game of um nepo for
just a second as I'll bring that up on
my screen
played G3 instead of No rookie two three
no Rook E3 G3
something similar so that after Knight
D2
F4 Knight f8 F5 and in this case we
don't play next it still works we don't
have to play Knight to G4 to defend the
Rook on E3 but the problem with the move
G3 is it doesn't particularly bring the
Rook on A1
into play right whereas the move Rook E3
would have done that
I don't know maybe there is a difference
but between heavy Knight on F3 versus G4
because knight from G4 was going to E3
attacking the weak Pawn in the position
here if we play that uh variation we're
just looking at Option Knight F3 okay so
let's do it again g397 F4 Knight f8 F5
yeah
what if black just plays King D6
and then says Knight on F3 it's just not
a good piece
it's not impressive is it unfortunately
uh you're right the Knight on F3 doesn't
make the greatest impression
um and Ken Block come back with 97
Knight E5 yep that's definitely on
Black's agenda
I'm just wondering yeah pretty equal
yeah but
do I have Chances with the Rooks on the
board or Rooks off the board so for
example let's say I go here
would you like to compromise drag my
knight back right so the difference I
that I had in mind
was somehow you got to E5
yeah and you're threatening let's say
Knight F3 check
I suppose you would just go 1967 yeah
yeah that's why King is kicked out from
D4 yes the price Advantage goes with it
exactly I I was dreaming of an
opportunity of playing my knight to H5
and the timing is just uh wrong
and that does look like Richard
well Richard equalizes in that case uh
VAR over to you uh yeah you guys
absolutely right the line you were
looking at
um with uh
and a nepo game I think G3 was
inaccurate and I think Richard is is
about to equalize the game but let's
take a look at this game here we have
Fabiano Carona against uh Bogdan deak
and uh deak is playing really well I
think he he just played this G4 which is
a very important move now creating some
weaknesses and uh
F takes G4 played Knight F6 now putting
pressure on G4 and E4 Pawn immediately
creating Contra play and now Bishop D3
played and here he a little bit uh
played a surprising move here because I
was looking at the move Knight takes G4
which just feels a little bit more
natural because the bishop is already
well placed only six putting pressure on
B3 and Knight G4 will come in with the
tempo here and uh definitely black
doesn't have any problems here if if you
play the move Bishop B6 Rook C8
check now the king will go to B2 and
here actually you have a very clever
move here to remove this Bishop from B6
you can play the move Rook C6 attacking
the bishop and now if you take the
Knight on the eight black and play Rook
D6 attacking both Bishops and black will
be slightly better after for example
Bishop 2 Rook d8 it's it's pretty clear
that black is the only one who can be
better here so you probably have to take
on G4 and Bishop G4 so but instead of
doing that he actually took back on G4
with the bishop and this might have been
a slight inaccuracy because now okay
he's threatening to play Bishop F3 but
for example Bishop B6 could be played
here another move is night before still
close to equality but a knight G4 would
have been a little bit more stronger for
black
yeah that uh gaining gain in the tempo
against the bishop F2 Knight takes G4 is
very compelling but exactly for the
reason you said VAR The Bishop's very
good yeah on E6 looking at the B3 Pawn
defending G4
lots of interesting endings uh somehow
the late middle game early end games uh
turning our attention to our number one
seed which I found intriguing that
nobody picked alireza farugia our
defending grantchester Champion is not
feeling the love uh in this first event
uh when we actually really like his
position I think he has a big Advantage
do you okay because after Rook C1 we
were just on our break and I was
thinking uh I was talking with bar and I
was saying well I find the move Rook F4
very compelling uh wanting to double my
Rooks on the f file put pressure on the
Deep Run and virus said yeah well Rook
F7 similar idea but at the same time
um just defending the pawn on C7 might
even be better we can maneuver okay and
he he did it in Rook C2 and money like
what just like wait what so why Rook F7
first well I understood it was a kind of
like a pass and I thought uh Wesley was
intending to play Rook f8 now that the
pawn on A4 is not under attack right
Rook F4
um not quite sure I understood this
Nuance here maybe I'll ask of our
declared the cobwebs
confusion Reigns over here are yeah it's
it's not so clear to see the exact idea
but as we see here a lot of maneuvering
here at some point the white is probably
going to move the Rooks on an e-file so
let's let's take a look at some of the
lines here after Rook F4 um you you
Rooks are nicely placed here yes they're
on a C file but you can't really make
much progress here you can never really
take on C6 and we we don't really have
the move 95 here because we're always
going to have the D4 Pawn hanging so
that's why we need to do something and
bring the Rooks on an e-file here so it
doesn't really matter which move you
start with so you can start for example
with Rook E3 here okay and now uh Rook
E4 perhaps black wants to trade one pair
of the Rooks to reduce some of the
pressure from the C file and if you play
Rook ce2
and Rook takes E3
Rook takes C3
and now again still there is a pressure
here and the problem we see here this
Rook is still tied up to this Pawn on A4
and this A4 Pawn turns out to be a real
problem in a Black's position because
you can't really move the rook and you
don't really want to play the move B5
because that really weakens the position
here so you can continue with Queen F6
but after Queen D3 white is enjoying a
very nice Advantage here threatening
also the move Queen B5 so even perhaps
trading the Rooks it's still not going
to solve all the blocks problems in this
position so it's it's not an easy
position to play for Block here and
still a lot of a lot of difficulties uh
long ways away from the equality here
for black okay uh thank you for that
varai trading a pair of Rooks I think is
advantageous for white because of what
you've just said after the move Rook F4
and if we play a move like Rook E3 I
thought that the move Rook F4 was the
designed to put pressure on the D4 Pawn
so that after for example a move like
Rook E3 I could play a move like Queen
F6
do I maybe have G3 or is that a big
mistake oh I'm not sure
G3 okay uh
wow I'm I'm just kind of I guess I I
have to go Rook F5 you can't play a
rookie four also yes sir and I can play
rookie four so no G3 doesn't I'm not I'm
not ensnared and in the same manner as
what uh or it originally pointed out I
could play rookie four but I was I was
thinking to to try to force your Rook to
go to D2 so that at least you're not
doubling up on the E file and maybe my
Rook on F4 is actually more useful than
one of White's Rooks in that line
actually white can play very directly
after the move Queen F6 here in this
position so you actually you're one of
your best options is to play the move
Rook C5 here very concrete putting
pressure on D5 and it seems like now
black can just take on D4 but at the end
of that line there's going to be a
slight Advantage for white after the
move Rook C7 Now The Rook is on a seven
track and that's exactly where we want
to have our Rook Knight X F3 right Rook
takes F3 and
when you take Rook text F3 and here is
actually important part actually instead
of taking the Rook you have this in
between move Queen takes D5 check
picking up the pawn first and if you
play King H7 for example Queen takes F3
Queen takes F3 GTX F3 and uh still uh
black has uh throwing chances here but
wife will be pressing for a very long
time and another line here after Knight
X F3 Rook takes F3 if you take back with
the
Queen here Queen D5 is if black plays
the move actually Queen F7 that's a
funny move yeah because if we take back
on F3 now the C7 Rook is hanging so we
have actually two options we can take on
F7 but we also have this move Queen
takes B7
leaving we're down a rook right now but
it's temporarily black will take on C7
Queen takes C7 and play the move Rook B3
and
looks like uh should be able to hold
these positions two Rooks are pretty
strong and the other variation if we try
to take immediately on F7
Rook takes F7
and queen C4 again black is a little bit
tied up here because you're you're
pinned and you cannot move the Rook from
A4 but on the other hand it's going to
be very hard to make progress for
example uh black even can just give up
the pawn on B5 just to get get rid of
this uh dangerous pin and he should be
able to hold this position because as we
know the two Rooks are pretty strong and
blocking is pretty safe here thank you
for that I like the visual of Queen F7
you know like go ahead yeah better take
my queen why don't you so interesting
games but nobody's breaking through not
yet not yet not yet of the remaining
games uh need your intuition
and Anish are following exactly our
variation we'll see if Anish plays Queen
B8 here probably will probably will of
the remaining games which one in your
her judgment has the best chances of
being a decisive game or do you see any
of them having I wouldn't say at the
moment that any of them could be
decisive but right I do see chances for
alireza and possibly in the game again
Fabi against Bogdan
maybe black can if white over pushes and
doesn't apply carefully
well let's just uh jump into that game
of Fabi because that Fabi us Christians
uh pick to win the tournament and we
left it we
Vara had been explaining to to us why he
felt and I agreed Knight takes B4 was a
nicer Tempo than what dioc played which
was Bishop takes I in I'm if I can
Channel my inner diac he's hoping to put
his Bishop on F3 and to perpetually keep
white tied up to the defense of his Pawn
on e4 Knight B4 Rook C8 check I think
we're up to date with the players I
think on the next move black is planning
to play Bishop F3 okay so let's say I
drop back Bishop to F3 let's say I
defend however temporarily it may be
rookie one
now it's hard to come up with a move
that
pressure on e4 right well you've got
just well maybe Knights of six yeah I
was about to say the night on d8 doesn't
make that great an impression now I
thought that
um White had played the move Knight
before because he wanted to trade uh
pieces let's just take a quick Gander at
this
um where am I moving this fellow fruit
to A7
Rook to E3 I wanted to do something of
this nature
it's hard to improve for either color
exactly it really really is
uh and we do have by the way King B2 on
the board and I didn't know
did you want to trade Knights well you
want I thought in my mind yeah I I
thought you might want to go here to try
to keep more pieces on the board or 96
Knight G5 oh there we go we have another
piece
exactly exactly so and the the thing is
White's Bishop is constrained I mean we
would love to play Bishop G3 we can't
and how do we target this guy
Bishop F3 on the board by the way so
okay we're going to reach this position
exactly do I have to be
so compliant
maybe can I just have a quick Candor at
this for just a moment
so what's the idea if I take with with
the Knight
oh
okay
gift Bishop G2
okay so first of all I don't really I
don't I don't run a risk I do
kind of want to trade my weak Pawn for
Maybe Upon that's not so weak but here I
also had I was thinking about Knight D5
95. with two different threats 97 and
Bishop B4 right six yeah so I wasn't
sure
yeah exactly so uh maybe the move Rook
F1
it's a little bit you can take with the
bishop on e4 right okay let's have a
look at that one
take with the bishop E1
okay he was being compliant right so if
you go Bishop E3 I take on D3 first yeah
now again I'm gonna win my Pawn back
uh does that mean that I equalize or
stand well G6 yeah that's a good move I
like number six and still seems equal
seems equal right yeah nothing untoward
he did play rookie one
wow uh tough stuff and let's just uh
jump into the game of Napo and Richard
for just a moment when we left it we
left it after the move G3 move we kind
of felt was maybe not
on point F4 Knight f8
whoa Rook F1 we so now I have five we
thought F5 Knight D7 The Rook F1 check
Knight C5
aha I I see a potential for repetition
here King to D4 Knight to E6 check
was this uh VAR was this the
head-to-head
that had one to one with nine draws yes
yeah this is how do these two guys make
nine draws with each other I mean I find
that a virtual impossibility I mean yeah
I was also surprised to see the score as
Richard ever drawn nine games against
anybody else in the world I mean come on
that's uh that's really remarkable
probably not probably not but it seems
like Janice made some innocuous and uh
Richard is going to be completely fine
now and in this position actually uh you
know black doesn't even have to repeat
if you go back in D4 he actually can
simply take the bishop on D3 because uh
the next move is actually going to be F6
you you don't really have a permanent
Knight on um E5 here so you have to take
back with the pawn here which is the
best move and now just F6 removing the
Knight and uh
if you play Knight F3 right simply Rook
goes to E2 and B3 Pawn is a little bit
weak H2 and it becomes pretty clear that
uh black doesn't have any problems he
can put the King on D6 maybe at some
point maneuver the bishop to D7 and F5
as well so black is actually slightly
better now after this so he did that's
why he didn't play the move uh King D4
he actually just played Rook 81 and um
here again he can simply just take on D3
and uh
if let's say you take back with the Rook
F6 right yeah if you take on C6 then you
know you actually worse in this position
because black has the control of the
only open file and it's going to be very
difficult to to prevent rookie too so
white has to defend in this position so
you don't want to take you have to go
back Knight F3 and trying to put the
Knight on uh D4 but here actually black
even can play the move B5 because now if
you capture Bishop takes B5 and now
you're losing an exchange because you
have both Rooks on this diagonal and
you're going to be losing material so
after the move B5 you can play Knight D4
but after taking on A4 we are creating a
weakness and we're gonna have a lot of
Contra play for example if you take back
with the pawn we can play the move
rookie one here
so it's pretty clear that Jan misplayed
this position and uh nepo is going to be
you know the report is going to be
absolutely fine
um yeah I I feel the fizzle I feel the
fizzle is happening
um
again a game that I'm personally finding
really confounding is between Wesley and
Ali Reza at certain moments I just
don't quite get what's going on so we
just saw the move Rook E3 then we saw
Queen F6
attacking the pawn on D4 kind of the
move though we looked at G3
here
Rook C5 I think is what right and then
Rook D3
so we do went rookie three Rook D3 then
in response to Rook D3 we have rookie
eight which move I kind of shied away
from because I just I I don't want to
get in this situation where I'm forced
to end up after for example Rook to D2
it looks really doubling Brooks on the
closed file you know our great strategy
right but but it works yeah if we force
your Rook to go back to uh then you're
gonna ruin the days wanna Tempo correct
why did we play rookie eight uh so the
question we have to ask ourselves is
after the move Rook D2 what did Wesley
have in mind is it rookie four or this
is not a chance he's playing in B5
maybe he didn't want to keep the Rook on
A8 forever
right well let's jump over to our friend
and colleague in Bucharest and as
Christian update what's going on my
friend
yeah so let's start with the general
atmosphere I just came back from the
playing Hall and right now we are three
hours in to the games and I have to say
the playing hole is still completely
packed so there's that there's that
excitement coming from the fans and you
can sense that as the players as well
the players are on the stage you can see
that and you can see how packed it is
it's just a beautiful sight to see for a
chest tournament here in Bucharest
Romania and in terms of uh players Fabi
I'm sensing some disappointment because
he got a great position out of the
opening at least from a practical
perspective sure maybe that managed to
maintain the balance for the duration of
the game but there was definitely some
pressure coming from the white side from
Fabi right now it feels like dark is
finally getting out of trouble still
white has the two Bishops nevertheless
black you can see that bishporn F3 that
night on F6 they're coordinating very
well to uh keep a white species hostage
to the defense of the Pawn on e4 The
Rook on E1 and the bishop on D3 and that
just doesn't allow white any resources
try to go and attack Black's weaknesses
for example the pawn on B7 maybe the
pawn on E5 as well it just doesn't feel
like this is enough for Fabiano so he
must be disappointed got a good opening
on the board but unfortunately Dak was
uh just Rock Solid in that one I'm
sensing some tension coming from Jan and
I spotted that at the beginning of the
games as well he was not facing Richie
Rapport let's not forget Richie was an
integral part of dingley wren's opening
the team preparation into the world
championship match he was his second
there in Astana and everybody was
talking about a thing but everybody was
talking about a Richie report as well so
there's definitely some tension between
team young and team a ding even going
into this tournament only a week after
the conclusion of the World Chess
Championship so there's some tension
there and one thing that I was
definitely having my eyes on is also
how is he going to come back after so
many months of inactivity so many talks
about his second career in a fashion
design things of that nature how is that
going to impact him and I have to say
he's looking focused he really is
looking focused he's not walking around
the playing Hall a lot and right now
he's putting some pressure on Wesley so
so definitely an interesting matchup
going on in this one but it does feel
like alireza is just picking it up where
he left it he won the grand Chester last
year he is the defending champion and
he's definitely looking
um to prove that there was no fluke in
that one he definitely feels like the
champion he wants to prove that on the
chessboard
thank you Christian for the update there
uh it's a it's actually
a very funny position uh that's going on
in the game between Ali Reza and Wesley
in the sense after the move rookie the
move I'm not really that comfortable
with move Rook C5
I thought had a a fabulous trap it's not
that obvious but you can lose a rook
after the move Queen uh to D6 I myself
am a pawn grubber I freely confess I
love grabbing pawns and when I see this
position the first thing that goes
through my mind is can I take this Bond
Queen takes A5 it looks really good the
Knight is pinned to The Rook there is no
uh back rank here
until we do have a Hanging Rock
you see this one and it's somehow you
know if you're not looking in that
direction it's kind of a really easy
uh blunder to this it's not a typical
pattern we don't really want to afford
that often like what yeah and queen
takes and the pawn on D4 is pinned uh by
The Rook on F4 and there goes I moved
his Rook back yes I think
he he spotted the Trap there that had
been an interesting position for the
last about 10 moves both have been
shuffling their Rooks back and forth
slightly improving yeah it would it
would appear So In This Moment uh again
Queen takes A4 unless there's a rook
takes F3 and a rook E1 but for the
moment I would imagine that if I was in
Wesley's shoes that I don't want to see
the a pawn just disappearing I mean you
know there might be a G2 G3 is a Prelude
yeah to capturing the pawn
not really what I had in mind either if
I had to go here and somehow this little
jockeying for position uh I think white
is improving matters for himself can
black play Rook F2 E4 right now
defending A4
indirectly yeah by the back rank mate
yeah
that is nice so I like it Brook fe4
correct answer is yes yes E4 that looks
like the best and Wesley just played
rookie four okay
and let's imagine
um that I played G2 G3
usually in such positions it's nice it
just kind of put my king on G2 I'm
inviting rookate rookie too
do you want to me too yeah now maybe
Knight A5 guys night activate the Knight
to C4
give up the pawn and just put the Knight
on a very good Square yeah yes
I like Black's initiative here me too
me too I love the I love the fact that
it takes B2 and pawns for the initiative
yeah my favorite thing so yeah and it's
one of those things too that when you do
grasp the initiative like this and you
you you're creating those threats
it's that turn around right you're at
the board and suddenly what was what
white was nursing a positional Advantage
has now become a little bit of a chaos
rookie four on the board
can I play something else except yes
beside G3 yes
well I'm kind of all ears
Physician's quite cramped crime don't
have that much space right now right
okay it's a little bit well it's not a
little bit it's a lot a bit awkward but
King F1 no I know King F1 Maybe
uh yeah the what was going through my
head was a moment ago you were always
threatening this back rank mate right I
played Queen H2 here just because it
looks cool actually it looks more than
cool it looks like a stone cold winner
that's
who had that great line that's Purdy
that's Purdy I like it I like it a lot
Queen H2 you don't see a visual like
that every day VAR
um
is Ali raise a working himself into some
awkwardnesses of art yeah I think he
played a little bit too slow maybe too
much shuffling too much maneuvering
instead of going for directly some of
those lines we were looking at with the
Rook C5 putting pressure because it
seems like now Wesley uh has activated
all his pieces now the Rooks are on the
open E file and in particular this move
Rook Fe Warriors is a great move because
you cannot take on A4 because of the
background
and a lot more activity we see from
black and evaluation also dropped and
actually one of the best moves in this
position is actually to go back now Rook
C1 to try to control this the back rank
now but you can also play the move Rook
to E2 for example yeah and in this case
actually if you trade one pair of the
Rooks it's it's okay because now you
immediately activating the rook and now
putting pressure on the forehand uh
black black will be fine in this
position because there will always be
enough control play against the D4 Pawn
so perhaps just a lot of Shuffling from
alireza and Wesley managed to activate
his pieces because if we go back to the
move 22 if we look at it here after OKC
one we see the white Rooks are already
lined up and still blackrook is still on
a on A8 and in the next few moves we see
black made a lot of progress here and
that's why uh evaluation is actually
just showing uh zero zero here in this
position exactly it's like we went as
white we put the Rook on C1 on D3 and
black doubled Rooks on the E on the open
E file a big
the Improvement for black
less of an improvement I would say for
alireza Fabi
um I was listening to Christian and he
was saying that Fabi came out of the
opening with some nice advantages and
maybe is a little bit disappointing
disappointed that he hasn't turned it
into something even concrete but I
didn't see a moment VAR was there a
moment that Fabi missed something I
didn't see it no I think it's just one
of those positions he asked her that it
just looked good for white but black
just had enough Dynamics to be able to
get the equality one thing I wanted to
point out is the time situation because
we know dayak from the previous
tournaments he spends a lot of time so
he's got seven minutes right now and
it's still there's still 10 moves to go
and he still needs to make some dishes
decisions here and white still has the
pair of the Bishops even though
evaluation is is showing zeros but still
he has to make some precise moves to
make sure uh the white doesn't get the
advantage here so for example here
Bishop C5 just played by Fabiano I like
this move because for example now if you
just decide to take on before he can
take and try to bring the bishop to C3
and just try to create some tricks
because opponent now is got six seven
minutes with 10 moves to go uh make it
more difficult for him instead of just
directly simplifying like for example
taking on C6 here so for example he
tried Knight D7 that has been played in
the 97 okay yeah that's already maybe a
slightly uh inaccurate move because now
he can play for example Bishop D6 okay
now the bishop is very active here and
if we have a chance we definitely want
to play the move Knight D5 with opponent
also having six minutes on the clock he
wanna we wanna keep more pieces on the
board now he has to trade for example on
before and now Bishop takes B4 and it's
a little bit better for white it's a
little bit better two Bishops are still
remaining here and there is no line that
is just simply forces the equality like
if we look at the move Knight C5
Bishop takes C5 actually taking Rook
takes C5 and now we will remove this
Bishop from F3 by playing the move Rook
F1 now Bishop has to go to C4 and now I
think it becomes pretty clear that white
is actually pressing here because
there's a pressure on F7 and you have to
start defending something like Rook C7
then we can play Rook F6 activating our
Rook King G7 and even Rook B6 I think
something like this will give Fabiano
some chances here and black now has to
defend so I think he still has chances
here in particular because of the time
situation
yeah Knight D7 felt inaccurate and as
you said Bishop d as you prescribe for
me Bishop D6 on the board and uh Now you
kind of feel that if the black Bishop
that had been kind of forlorn on F2 gets
to the C3 Square where it's actually
pretty active uh Bobby
and again with the time situation being
favorable to White might get something
turning our attention to
um nepo and Richard Rapport for just a
moment because we do have some
developments here Naji I mean uh first
of all a new imbalance has appeared on
the board we did see the move Knight
takes uh D3 so now we have
would you say a good night versus bad
Bishop definitely looks like that feels
it but there was that move B5 right so
it was F6 and here this is the moment
that um
Vara was suggesting that B5 was a a good
enough for equality let's say Richard
had a different approach he played
rookie two H4 and Rook E3 inviting the
move Knight D4 shall we have a look it's
what happens after people but I am
concerned about Black's Bishop exactly
if it never gets activated the good
night we know what a good night versus
bad Bishop looks like it's not a very
pleasant movie uh for the person holding
the the the bad Bishop so Knight D4 now
we've got to take on D3 right right okay
G2 thought that you want to well you
wanna at least if you go back to E4
then it's just a bad bishop and The Rook
is just a temporary but I was afraid of
Rook F3 and then Rook E3 why because I
had in the E file so let's say you get
that and I get that so more or less so
long as I keep the rook in your camp
I think I can I can navigate the bad
Bishop
and we do have Knight D4 on the board
Fortress for black white cannot really
take advantage of e-file or even the
Knight on D4 it looks very pretty on D4
exactly it can't go any further
pretty as a picture as well as we used
to say
um
so
this Rook bothers me like big time if I
could just trade the Rooks off the board
I might think I was just winning with
white okay so imagine I would apply dry
92 with the old Shuffle idea of oh you
still have D4 check in such a case even
if I was to manage like one guy played
D4 oh because G3 yes exactly so even in
this position after I play Knight E2 and
I make a silly move waiting move and I
make another silly waiting move
this is still not a threat that I have
to take seriously because G3 is hanging
I think uh I think Richard's got an easy
draw in front of him are we right bar
oh absolutely guys uh yeah I think Jan
just misplayed his really nice advantage
that he had early on and now this Rook
is going to be it's very important to
keep the Rook on G2 to put pressure on
G3 and I think white also needs to be
careful there are some violations there
he could he could be actually worse
right because this Rook is very active
so I don't see any problems in this
position for a report and I think uh you
know it's it's a good good Escape for
him definitely right and we also getting
reports that Duda and Anish are well
we've been saying that for some time
it's not a really big surprise it was a
bishops of opposite color position and
uh anisha's
exactly exactly they seem to have that
body posture of like okay where's that
repetition that we
that we can please the crowd
yeah I think we will see guys now Bishop
takes A7 picking up the pawn and now
black needs to just play the move King
E8 to protect the bishop and then we
will see next move Bishop E6 played and
once the Rooks come off the board it
will just be a draw they will find a way
to repeat so uh very interesting game
but it seems like both players played
accurately and there were not that many
chances for either side exactly even
though the opening itself
uh featured a great imbalance you know
why it had the big Center blackhead the
queen side majority uh it looked like it
was going to be spicy but it it it had a
fizzle to it just looking at the game
between Wesley
and Ali Reza when we left it we're just
about here and we played G3 yeah we
weren't really sure what white was
supposed to do but moves like G3
followed by King G2 followed by Queen
takes A4 at least is a plan and we have
Rook E2 on the board and Rook D2 that
Rook on E2 really is very very strongly
so would you exchange here for the black
or keep keep the double Rooks on E5 I
think I have to trade unfortunately if I
go back I do think at a certain moment
that a pawn will be captured unless I
blunder a rook you know but yes I okay
the problem is is that after Rook takes
D2 Queen takes D2 something similar
right I mean should I just go rookie
four and queen F6 you know and you know
you keep you tied down to the pawn on D4
can I improve my night I would be
desperate to improve the night I meant
for black five nights before but I think
I don't have time because white might
quickly play Knight E5
here yes okay
uh I do recognize that H3 is hanging no
I guess uh
okay and uh VAR you have an update for
us on the game between Fabi yeah let's
take a look guys this they're actually
following the line that we looked at it
a little bit earlier so here if we go
back to the move Bishop D6 so uh Bishop
D6 he took the ACT took on B4 and
actually he's he's down to less than
three minutes on the clock here so I
think Fabi is getting some real chances
now Bishop takes before and now he
played Knight C5 which looks very active
and uh but now I think it's Fabiano's
turn here so he has to take I think it's
important for him to take on C5 here to
eliminate this Knight he does have
another option Bishop C4 we can look at
it after this but he can just take now
Rook C5 and now again remove the Bishop
from F3 by playing Rook F1 and the
bishop goes on G4 and then activating
this bishop now to C4 putting pressure
it's it's not a huge Advantage but it's
just gonna be uh more pleasant for him
to play after Rook F6 but considering
the time situation I wouldn't be
surprised if he tries to complicate the
matters here by playing the move Bishop
C4 because now opponent has only two
minutes on a clock and now if he takes
let's say Knight to E4
there is a rook F1 here immediately
trying to create more imbalance here and
if let's say Bishop goes to H5 then we
have a rook F5
so now white is actually clearly better
so after the move Rook F1 black needs to
find the strong move B5
the idea behind it if you just capture
he has the move Rook B8 now now we have
both Bishops hanging and again even this
line it's not so clear still y perhaps
has some chances after the move Bishop
C6
so I think this is an important moment
and I think a moment where Fabiano can
take his time here he's got 24 minutes
spend maybe five six minutes and try to
come up with the move Bishop C4 to
complicated mirrors and as you can see
24 minutes versus about three minutes
for deck and they are on a move uh
the 32 so still eight more moves to go
all right well thank you for the update
there uh or I'm looking at this game of
Wesley so for some reason it's not
coming up on my screen there it is and
uh he did trade uh kind of a surprise he
didn't follow up with Rook E4 he played
Queen G6 is this a blunder because what
if white plays Queen D1
right just uh going back to the central
question it's all about that Avon right
uh East oops excuse me I wanted to say
you stop uh any incursion with Queen be
one check you you threaten A4 wanna
follow up with King G2 maybe because
plan is if y takes Queen A4 well I can
play Queen B1 and take on B2 clear
yeah that makes sense but I think I'm
going to play King G2 and queen takes A4
you know something of that nature but
then there'll be a rookie too so but
what does black do for a passing move
maybe rokito is not so scary because it
only attacks B2 Pawn right
you guys you mean you mean people
there was a there was a line
I want to lose the a pawn I don't want
to lose the C7 Pawn right okay so no
Knight A5 to C4 ideas for me by the way
that would also invite Knight E5 okay so
what can I do here after Queen D1
hmm
yeah looks like guys this move Queen G6
was a serious inaccuracy yes and
valuation jumped almost plus one now for
white wow yeah he really had to play uh
the move that we were uh you know he had
to play like Queen E6 here or uh Queen
E6 for example trying to create some
Contra play on the e-file uh or or queen
E7 but by playing this move Queen G6
perhaps he maybe overlooked this move
Queen D1 it's very strong now A4 Pawn is
hanging and uh you have to play some
awkward moves here like the best moves
are Rook B8 or Rook d8 but they seem
very unnatural and you don't really want
to play that and uh you don't have
anything directed you can try to do
because if you let's say you try to play
Queen E4 then rookie 3 will attack the
queen you will go back on G6 and after
trade I can just pick up that A4 Pawn
finally here we do have King G2 on the
board as a reaction to Queen G6 we
played Queen B1 Queen D1 to cover B1 and
I get that but uh King G2 doesn't matter
Ken black play Queen B1 now
and I'll chase you away with rookie one
right Rook C1
unless you're gonna go Queen A2 and go
now that's a little bit that's a bit
much peculiar to say the least but can I
go Queen E4 inviting rookie one yes and
then what you do six because I'm happy
to exchange the rugs
you're happy to exchange the Rooks think
what how do you defend A4
well I have B5 if needed but I was
thinking more of starting counter play
possibly once you take on A4 I can play
Queen E4 okay so you could go Queenie
for I'll take on A4
and
oh B5 no
maybe B5 oh yes and if you take I have
queen of three yes yes
anishkiri let's jump to uh the game
between Duda and Anish as they are in a
bishops of opposite color position upon
down and I think the players are looking
for a repetition even though White
has an extra Pawn it's really uh nothing
and
the players are going to make offering a
drop I think this was one of the most
exciting openings we had today no
question about it I mean it started and
it it it it started to be an incredibly
dynamic position right here out of the
opening on move eight nine I thought we
were really going to be faded and then
there was this amazing moment of B6 that
really was a shock or move because we
were looking at Knight C4
but the crazy part was the preparation
of both the players were outstanding
both players played very accurately they
they knew the variation they've been
working
with their teams uh for the grand chess
tour and it seemed like they had worked
out this uh whole line with Queen takes
H2 our second uh result of the
tournament also headed for a draw uh
once again Richard Rapport The Rook is
on G2
um VAR said very very very powerful Rook
that should be a draw is black maybe
even slightly better now I wouldn't
doubt it I really wouldn't
that that Rook on G2 is just
it prevents white from doing anything
accurate active pardon me accurate
prevents white almond Black's Bishop was
slightly better right then black would
definitely be better
guys Fabiano has some very serious
chances to win now it looks like diaka
made a big mistake okay so Bobby played
the move Bishop C4 which uh we were
going to tried to be double-edged
exactly yeah keep keep the imbalance and
here immediately he played the act only
had to about three so he spent two and a
half minutes and played the move Bishop
H5 which is an inaccuracy because now uh
there are few ways white can have a nice
Advantage here but for example he can
just take on C5 eliminate the Knight and
after Rook takes C5 he can play Bishop
D5 attacking the pawn on B7 and let's
say if you try to protect it with the
move B6 then he will play G4 and you
cannot capture the the pawn because
you're gonna lose your Bishop after Rook
G1 attacking the bishop if you play H5
he will just play H3 another Bishop is
pinned so you will be losing the bishop
in this line and after G4 if you play
the move Bishop G 6 then actually white
can continue with H5 the H4 threatening
H5 and it's going to be very difficult
to get this bishop into the game here
and for example if you play King G7 then
now Rook will come to A1 and now
threatening Rook A7 with the Rook B7 ID
and this bishop is really really badly
placed so I think Fabiano has some very
very serious chances now to win this
game after the inaccuracy of Bishop H5
so easy to make
make mistakes in such time trouble yeah
exactly that's what happens at time
trouble to quote Maurice makes fools of
his all and in this case 39 seconds
absolutely no and when it rains it pours
right but I love what you were saying uh
the the steady incremental moves Bishop
takes E5 Bishop to D5 uh you know you've
been throwing out G4 H4 VAR but there's
also Rook A1 and trying to bringing you
know again just
um excuse me I think the bishop yes the
bishop is on H far H5 so you know
we get here right and uh just as an
example you know I can also Play Moves
Like King A3 to play King B4 put my
Bishop on D5 but what pharah was
suggesting was just very very strong and
straightforward something of like this
and let's just say we play here yep uh
this bishop is really it's gonna take
like a lot of moves to bring that Bishop
back into the game it's truly and at the
same time okay one okay seven exactly
White's taking no risks and on the
contrary with each movie seems to be
increasing his grip that he already has
on the position so maybe this is our
best chance of a win of any of our five
games
yes I likewise chance is here quite a
lot I do too Bishop H5 on the board
and yet even uh you know here I am
saying yeah oh I get it Bishop C5 Bishop
D5 at the board
maybe bishop C5 isn't my number one
consideration because of the two Bishops
right I'm finding myself you know not so
willing to uh make that trade and maybe
I find myself more attracted just to put
it out there and move like Rook E3 so
that I'm ready to meet Bishop to G6 with
Bishop D5 keeping my two Bishops not
realizing I should have been giving one
of them away I would be a little bit
worried that if I exchange on C5 I'm
decreasing my advantage right yeah the
engine tells us it's actually the
opposite because the B Pawn is being
targeted and the the blacks Bishop is
offside we're getting uh ready to go
over to uh Bucharest as we get as a
guest in studio with Christian but in
the meanwhile what's your take on the
position bar
yeah I think um I I predict Fabiano to
win this game and one thing I want to
point out yeah sir I mean we mentioned
we discussed this earlier that when the
app played this move Bishop takes G4
this this was the start of the problems
for him they had that stable a bishop
only six we could just leave it there
and just take back with the Knight and
uh perhaps this bishop G4 Bishop F3 idea
backfire for him pretty badly and now
he's in a pretty much losing position
right right at this point yeah where he
could just take Knight takes G4 and keep
that nice nice Bishop on E6 and you know
defending everything and also putting
pressure on B3 exactly this was the step
in the wrong direction that they are
basically it's not that he played a bad
game or anything like that it's just
that he got the wrong setup with his
pieces now if you imagine this bishop
was on E6 and this white square Bishop
was on D3 as in the game
uh that makes all the difference in the
world the bishop on E6 looks great no
problems at all exactly in the bishop on
H5 currently does look terrible as it
did we have Bishop take C5 played no no
he's taking his time that is uh that's
our analysis
and let us jump to a Bucharest with
Christian
thank you Yasser yes we are indeed with
Anish uh Anish first of all welcome back
to uh Bucharest how do you feel right
now re-energized you've watched the
world championship match what can you
tell us a bit about that yeah the match
was actually very inspiring uh I have to
say
so I was really looking forward to
glitches it's been a while I mean I
played a lot of Chess but not classical
so I'm you know quite excited and
sometimes you watch some tournaments and
they either you know slightly bring you
down or they inspire you and I think
what championship match was definitely
inspiring I'm not sure I mean it doesn't
mean that I'll play well but at least um
I'm looking forward to playing with that
give us a little a bit of insight of
what you were doing before because we
were you were posting on Instagram some
Seaside photos it looked like you were
maybe on a vacation maybe on a training
camp can you tell us anything about that
yeah I mean at some point I was talking
to the uh to Vladimir kramnik about
these things and you know it's of course
you're supposed to
work at the tournament prepare the
training camps and rest at the vacation
but um you know when you have a
you know an adult life like a grown-up
life let's say with the family and all
that sometimes responsibilities that's
called that things like start turning
around and you like end up resting at
the tournament uh working hard on the
vacation and uh so I'm myself not sure
whether it was a holiday or or a
training camp but um
a lot of fun yeah a lot of fun I mean I
you know very motivated to work on chess
and
um now I'll have a lot of tournaments in
a row so I thought the time between
February where I played uh WR so I
played bike and WR Masters in a row and
then I had a couple of months um
so I thought it was a good time to you
know rest
and prepare a bit combine business and
pleasure yes of course of course tell us
about the game today
uh was actually one of those computer
generated variations
um
like that some players know probably
like this B5 you know I mean this at
some point was rare actually I came up
with this long long time ago when it
wasn't completely new so I was really
excited about it and I had this whole
line that I played today worked out but
then of course many other players also
found it because we'll use the same
toast and by now I think there are games
I think Jordan played this variation
um I I would guess the Dominguez I don't
know if he got this position but he's
probably was aiming for everyone right
yeah you know well that one was P5 but I
think it's also played E5 Knight of
Bishop before but I'm not sure if you
know very often people want to play this
but they don't get to play it because
let's say uh you know some players play
Bishop D2 here and
myself after Bishop by the way yeah so
he played like literally the uh the most
fun line of all and the sequence I mean
from here the queen E7 a bit of d8 Queen
C4 Bishop E6 couldn't 2.7 it's a very
serial sequence I think main move here
is Knight C4 according computer okay
this one it says very high Advantage for
white but um a stronger computer of
course uh you know if you let them run
definitely felt like you're still in
Europe like yes if you just keep moving
forward at some point you get some end
game like not even zeros but you get
like um an end game like a piece down
but they're like three pawns against one
on one flank and it's like
0.25.50 you're on top with the King
Bishop against the kingdom yeah exactly
something like that uh Basics actually
um is an alternative I
I'm very logical one and I don't know if
he was prepared or not I assume he was
prepared because he could play something
else at any point which is safer but
yeah B6 was a nice practical so he was
also spending a lot of time yeah I don't
know I think he was trying to remember
or not and actually this position I've
um I think I've looked at it as well
um but I felt like actually over the
board that I'm a little bit worse so I
was trying to remember what was the
exact variation because
um you know if we trade Queens for
example
I suspect that my position could be
close to lost because my a pawn can can
be lost in this four against three with
two Bishops on like let's say if you
traded a pair of Bishops
um or I tried the Rooks yeah that's also
like uh difficult I don't know very hard
and uh of course if you trade the pair
of Bishops and like give the a pawn four
against three is drop it with the bishop
pair I've seen even sometimes even three
against three people I think three
little ones lost against
in China some tournament so I realized
that I have to
um you know often you will prepare and
then you realize what you prepared
during the game so I realized during the
game that okay I have to keep the Queens
on and I have to be active and initially
I like this Knight C5 idea which was
five crazy two very fancy then it goes
Queen B5 and I was thinking about this
kind of position Queen City orbital
and I was thinking that you know
of course I have potential to go A5 and
all that so first of all I was not sure
but even even besides I was not sure um
if this Knight MP3 is a little bit like
I'm banking a lot on that so I was
trying to play it a little bit
safer with Queen B8 and well I it looks
like the computer license so it's just
good I I think it was a little bit of a
safer move in a sense that I keep
coordination of my pieces I expect him
to play something like G3 try to keep it
then my idea is that in this position
I will go H6 or H5 then I have softened
him up quite a bit and it's a big deal
maybe I mean maybe it does feel like the
king is definitely much and likewise if
he goes H3 I suspect that 96 Knight H5
ideas as well
yeah maybe you know it's also a little
bit weak anyway let's say if he tries to
develop okay there are different orders
of the Knight H5 first or the computer
says G3 is prefers connection to First
in this position prefer connection first
but in any case it's clear I'm
generating some counter play and it's a
little bit more I found a little bit
more sound than with an item B3 yeah but
I the way he played I thought I
calculated that it's drawn you have to
calculate a few nice variations here so
first of all it's important at some
point another screen D5 and I had a bit
of a what do you mean you know about it
you haven't seen this position I don't
know I mean I know this one I don't know
this I was calculating this and I have
not to be honest with you
um this position in my file continues
for sure but I didn't recall because
very often you repeat so many lines and
your brain unnoticed it automatically
decides that okay this you will manage
yourself so don't remember and this is
one of those like sometimes when a
position looks very scary but here I
guess I thought that okay forget equal
material I'll manage myself you know so
I didn't remember I don't know maybe
Queen B8 is in my file it looks so nice
the company is so happy maybe it's in my
file but I felt like I came up with it
over the board I was happy with that in
any case yes here there were some nice
tactical variations
because of course I'm concerned that I
get thinned on the D file but here I
have connection for not Bishop E8 which
was also an idea ahead it's also okay
but I was thinking maybe 27 is a problem
here I was okay rookie Bishop c5h6 as
well but daring but I was planning Queen
H4 check here and then um yeah it's
easier and then I just move the bishop
and uh at some point I noticed the
smooth Queen D5 got slightly panicky
here because once of course he gets the
deadly Eternal pin on the D file is
tricky but I have Queen H4 G3 G3 then I
give a Checkers
the bishop I want to move the rook and
ethical G4 H4 and The Rook is defended
again so yeah nothing works and Buster
Bishop G5 I was just for fun
um trying to see how many draws there
are like I was thinking maybe F6 also
holds
um but I like 28 and here I think there
are multiple ways here I yeah I did at a
very clinical but I think also the good
old could be it also works Bishop F4
Bishop E6 some very nice variations here
so should be Bishop D5 is drawing if
Queen H5 if Queen H5 I have internet
with H6 otherwise Bishop P5
and if
Queen H5 I have a nice move Queen to B2
Rook H1 H6 and if he takes an H6 I have
green touches and then Bishop E5 I have
Queen to two and this is also draw so so
I like calculated all the possible draws
that are there and just okay one for one
of them I mean even right now it feels
like you are definitely looking for a
fight in this game maybe even in this
tournament what is the strategy in just
one one more thing it's quite kind of
cute that you can blunder with F6
um yeah because okay first of all Bishop
A7 King f8
no I was of course I'm looking uh
forward to play I also saw a no
championship match you know you gotta
gotta fight
because nowadays it's very hard to
uh to control the game as
it was the case the K4 a well prepared
players they could control the game
but the nature of the game is such
nowadays that
um yeah you gotta get out there and
fight because um
you no longer have the advantage of
being better prepared because the it's
too easy to prepare now anybody without
any understanding or skills just looks
at the engine and before the engine
would give you let's say five options
and if you had some better understanding
you would see that okay the first option
is not good the second option is not
good but the third option is the right
one or the most sound one but now the
engines they are much more Superior and
they right away put that one that was
third then they will put on First with
the margin and so anybody just looks and
writes down the same lines and so um
yeah you don't have that edge anymore
that people used to have back in the day
and that means that you gotta fight it
out behind the board I wish an
adventurous draw always great insights
thank you very much we'll see you in the
rest of the games
ah thank you Anis thank you Christian
and let's take a look at our results uh
our second draw of the realm this far
right we have two draws and we think
that the nepo game has been going
through a repetition uh between a nepo
and Richard Rapport so we're almost we
we kind of want to go on break but we
kind of don't because we think a third
game uh this game of Richard has been a
repetition yeah might end very very
shortly with a Perpetual check I thought
they just ripped him up 40. so they
might take their time to decide oh
that's a good point and now that they've
got the the 40th well Richard still has
to make his 40th oh I see but nepo has
reached it
and how is Fabiano's game going does he
still have an advantage well actually
the crazy part is
I think he combined the worst of Both
Worlds
unfortunately for him right about here
after the move Bishop H5
if he wanted a sizable advantage and a
simple one at that Bishop takes C5 Rook
takes C5 Bishop to D5 targeting this
Pawn followed by the move G4
age four you kind of get a little space
over there going before eventually
bringing the Rook to A7 would have
gotten him a sizable Advantage instead
he he played after Bishop H5 Rook C1
which in his mind is keeping all the
pressure and so on but now after this
move B6 and he captures we're not
obliged to take with the Rook we can
recapture with the pawn and he ended up
playing Bishop to D2 and maneuvering his
Bishop to E3 and I think this last move
by dioc is an indication that he
understands his Bishops offsides maybe
because Bobby thought that Bishop C5
would be simplifying the position too
much and since his opponent is in such
big time trouble yes he didn't want to
do that exactly and I think that that's
one of the things for our Spectators to
really emphasize uh to them is they go
wow I mean why didn't he take on C5
you're looking at an engine and I think
you said it just so very well uh just
now when you said you know I'd be
reluctant to play Bishop takes C5
because I would be thinking am I
throwing away my advantage why did you
give up your two Bishops yeah sir but in
this case it would have been the right
move VAR
uh absolutely yes sir I agree with you
uh Fabi should have taken on C5 and uh
and right now he still has an advantage
but it's it's uh not as big as it used
to be but we can take a look at some of
the lines here and first we need to look
at the clock again six minutes for Fabi
and 30 30 seconds for dx2 he has to make
four more moves to go but this bishop G4
is a good move he's trying to bring the
bishop into the game here so Bobby just
played the move before attacking the
Knight and um
Knight takes E4 needs to be played
and now he can take Bishop takes B6 and
now Rook B8 he will pay Bishop P5 and
still maintaining some Advantage the
pair of the Bishops end up in a pass
Pawn on B4 but it's gonna be very hard
to advance the sponsor for example
Knight D6 could be played attacking the
bishop Bishop goes on B3 and try to put
the Knight on B5 blockade the spawn and
also very important to prevent The Rook
from entering to the seventh rank
something like this Rook C5 played F6
now protecting the E5 pawn and white is
still better but it's going to be much
more difficult to make progress but he
didn't play this move he actually played
Knight D7
and again when you have that much time
you more want to play safe and defensive
moves but now I think uh Fabi can play
Maybe Rook C3
one of the best moves here and uh try to
look for some opportunities actually he
needs to move the bishop at some point
to trade so let's say H5
and but it definitely it's not as much
of an advantage anymore like for example
Bishop B5 if you try to trade the
problem you run into in this variation
yes you're going to be able to win a
pawn but you're gonna have to give up
your bishop and we know that this kind
of endings are going to be you know
you're not going to have pretty much any
chances to win after Bishop B5 so
definitely a slip by Fabiano but still
the ACT has three more moves to make so
still chances he's got 40 seconds now
for uh versus five minutes
thank you for the update there so we do
expect that the game between Richie and
Eon also heading towards a draw the big
surprise for me is the movie G7 G5 by
Wesley up until this moment the player
has been kind of going back and forth
shuffling not too much has really taken
uh place but when you see the move G5
this is like a Clarion Bell you know
like the cows are coming home absolute
favorite move I want is it two years
championships with that G5 okay what is
it uh that's so special about this move
well in this case Wesley is saying I'm
defending my Pawn on A4 tactically what
yeah if it was white to move
sorry let's make uh let's make it white
to move King h a queen takes a for Rook
C Rook F7 Queen comes back and you can't
dislodge this Knight on H4 without at
least sacrificing a piece with Knight
takes D4 it's not good at enough so
Wesley says aha what I'm going to do is
I'm going to play G5
I'm going to invite you oh excuse me let
me take this Pawn First and I'm going to
invite you to take this Pawn on A4 and
then when we get to this moment it's the
G5 G4 makes all the difference in the
world queen takes F2 and I think uh we
have pawn exchange on the board already
Yes HGH how does y defend from G4 that's
why I'd have to play Queen D2
all right let's take a yeah I didn't get
that far I was just
I was just trying to make sure that yeah
okay
um Queen D2 I I didn't know if we were
going to go Rook C3 or not Queen D2 gift
me this Pawn
well let's say I go G4
uh maybe you go Queen G5 or what do you
have in mind I was thinking any Queen
trades will invite me to play rookie two
right
correct and then black suddenly yeah
suddenly wait a minute you know two can
play for a victory here
so maybe just night age four
okay sorry so okay the queen G5 and
counter play But first you got to decide
where you're gonna
and by the way uh this game uh
was drawn as they have made their
three-time repetition they're confirming
it with the Arbiter Arbor just says well
done boys sign your score sheets
skedaddle
and uh that will be our third draw of
the five games and here we are we're
looking at the game of Wesley so we've
just seen him exchange on G G5 maybe
Queen D2 is the wrong step
then how do we defend against Rook F7
and G4
okay
so step by step right so let's say I go
Rook C3 just
in order to I don't know play Queen D3
by the way I think they did play Queen
D2 and GeForce on the board you're right
they certainly have so let's stop right
there and say queen D2 G4 situation are
they both in time trouble
furosha is really low on the clock he's
playing on 30 seconds so he's got a
couple of more moves to go I think he
just Regional 40. okay okay Knight H4 on
the board maybe this one isn't this your
idea but then you said Queen G5
okay so first of all where do you put
your cake let's let's pick a square
right right
and I slurp the pawn Knight takes D4 now
you are saying G5 check now
how important is this check okay just
uh I think white is happy with the draw
at this point so Queen H5 so you think
okay this is just one drop and let's see
if I
uh
uh from the start from we have covered
with Rook G7 exactly uh right here right
Queen G5 right
now
there's a check and C7 singing right
true but am I abandoning my king
completely
well that night on H4 is doing a very
good job a very important job of
covering the F3 square that is for sure
um we're kind of tricking ourselves
where we're falling into this camp that
we thought the move G5 by Wesley was an
attempt uh to tactically keep his
position what's going on VAR yeah I
think Wesley is playing for a win and
that's the reason he played the move G5
right I I like what he's doing and I
think in some of these lines he's he's
actually a little bit better you know so
let's take a look uh what can happen now
so um Knight H4 was played alirez I
finally made a Time control and now
Queen is sick Queen E4 check most likely
will be played that's a very natural
move and the 48th move for Wesley and
here actually you have to be already
careful here you have to play the move
key in G1 because if you start out with
King H2 yeah that's a mistake because
Queen takes D4 and now you have problems
with the F2 Pawn so if you just trade
Queens after Knight takes D4 black is
just up a pawn and if you play Queen G5
here just Rook G7 now you don't have any
more checks and F2 Pawn is hanging so
this will be a problem so you have to
play the move King G1 now and now Knight
D4 will be played
and now threatening also Knight E2 check
so and here actually you have to find a
really really important move here the
move Rook D1
so to put pressure on the night and
night it to the main line goes 92 check
King to H2 and now D5 Pawn is hanging
um there is also Queen G5 thread so
because of that Black's best reply here
is the move Rook E5 trying to
consolidate the position but looks like
white will have uh enough counter play
here it's still very complicated but it
looks like uh uh you know white should
be okay in this position but very very
complex position so and uh yeah this is
a very important line if you try to play
something else like uh Queen G5 in this
position immediately then actually King
F7 move is very strong
and now the threat is still 92 and
actually this gives black uh a winning
winning Advantage but we can look at a
couple of more moves we need to check
and simply King comes to E6
by the way I'm sorry to interrupt you
avar but King H2 the move that you
identified as being a mistake was played
King H2 and as you were telling us uh by
failing to protect the F2 Pawn he is
inviting Wesley to play Queen takes D4
and Wesley will snip upon absolutely
it's a it's the engine is showing plus
two a winning Advantage for for Block so
uh it's still uh not so easy but I think
now you really you have a problem with
this F2 Pawn so you you might have to
play something like Rook C2 but then
Queens yeah and just just you can play
rookie five or you can even just simply
play D4 this this should be a win again
for black
and let's jump to Bucharest with
Christian who has a guest
thank you Yasser we are here with
Rihanna report who has been an integral
part of the just included world
championship match between Ding and
Neville
um Richie you started playing with in
round one against Nepal player that
you've gotten to know so well over the
last few months tell us a bit about this
game yeah I was very surprised by his
approach no actually I of course I was
thinking to
to take some small experience with me
from the match and I
felt like he's actually quite vulnerable
in French I mean 92 is not because they
have to be you know the most dangerous
wine
um yeah of course I assume if a thing
would have gone for this um again
would have played differently but I
guess
you know knowing all
how the match concluded and everything I
think he was not too ambitious to go for
something
but yeah still I mean he got a very
pleasant endgame actually so let's talk
about it uh did he surprise you with his
Approach at all I was really tired
actually
so I didn't prepare much and I went for
um City xd4
here yeah I believe I saw this from from
yavana from my life it should probably
uh so not from the preparation you did
during the match which might be you know
um
speaking for the most quality
no I I think I'm not going to assume
what that means it could be good it
could be bad it's just a very solid line
for black and as it happened in the game
I ended up getting this uh as well and
game
um yeah like once I did the one-sided
game but okay some people used to lose
this some people used to draw this yeah
some people get you know in trouble with
weight
what was your comfort level let's say at
this point were you feeling like you're
worse
um but it's going to be an easy defense
how are you feeling yeah of course black
is clearly worse I mean if I would want
to be really mean I would say that
following the match I wasn't worried but
um no I mean of course black is clear
livers and I was
I was somewhat um
I mean I didn't get a good version in
general but I mean I think if you play
these positions extremely precisely as
black you shouldn't lose them so I was
thinking it's kind of up to me and if he
will be able to you know to to put up
maximum pressure which I mean I didn't
feel like he did so I don't know I kind
of he kind of let me let me of the
hooker easily and even things
kind of turn
is there ever any tension between you
know team nepo and team ding in any way
shape or form I've spotted at the
beginning of the game he wasn't really
facing you before you guys started the
game was there anything there I mean
from my side not really as you can see
from him it might be I don't know
like
yeah the match was not I mean I'm not
much to do with the match I
of course I if it was like this I think
half of the players wouldn't talk to
each other after all the version picture
matches that has been played already so
I didn't feel like dead but yeah he was
acting a bit peculiar before the game I
don't know maybe he was just nervous or
maybe interested in general not happy to
to be here um to play after the dementia
you mentioned that you were quite tired
did you do anything in particular to try
to
re-energize yourself after such a
difficult month in Asana yeah obviously
I'll try I try but you know as you can
see from my play I didn't feel like I
succeeded
so yeah
um I'll just take take it easy yeah have
fun and
since Astana was you know it was sweet
at the end but it wasn't really fun so I
know the work of a second you don't
sleep during the night things of that
nature yeah it's not easy here I'm
looking for for more fun actually I have
friends here so
yeah more or less nice my place is
probably very poor but okay that's
another story it's just beginning Richie
thank you very much for joining us we'll
see you in the next rounds guys back to
you
and thank you Richie Richie getting a
taste of World Chess Championship uh
tensions and how it can be very
exhausting we have three results all of
them drawn and it's not because the
games haven't been interesting they
certainly have and Richie saying in this
particular game he fell into a difficult
position but it he handled it very well
and maybe even he had some Edge at a
certain moment we've been trying to get
in a break we couldn't do it but we are
about to succeed yay we're gonna see you
on the other side of this break we'll be
back soon
sir
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program in the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grand Master
varusha nicobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019. the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 200 and 50 000
Scouts earning the badge since 2011.
students of chess can also pick up a
copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr Jeannie Karen
sinkfield anyone can learn how to
understand chess notation in no time we
view chess as a valuable educational
tool learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
thank you thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back everyone and we have three
results so far Ultras very fighting and
exciting draws indeed they have been but
uh nonetheless still
exactly two games remaining Fabby uh we
actually like this position going into
this ending the deox sacrificed upon in
a very nice way just at this moment I
think it was move 40. Bishop F3 uh
inviting Fabi to capture the pawn on F7
something that Fabi was eager to do
Bishop takes F7 King takes F7 Rook F1
winning back his piece uh what could be
sweeter until
dayak played this very important move B5
Rook takes F3 check King E6 and now
suddenly we can see what black has in
mind great I would post on C4 Bingo yes
that Rook on C4 will be at attacking the
pawn on B4 it'll be attacking the pawn
on e4 the Knight will jump to F6 Fabi
rushed to stop the knight from coming to
F6 Bishop G5 Rook C4 Rook E3 and
end game in fact after Rook F3 check
this Pawn on e4 so weak that uh King G6
would uh more or less compel The Rook on
F3 to return to E3 and then a draw would
be taking place after King F6 I mean
White's King being also cut off along
but passive King passive Rook exactly
exactly got a chance to win this so that
will likely be our fourth uh a draw out
of as many games but then the game
between West they saw Wesley snipped a
pawn VAR and how serious are Wesley's
winning chances because I've been
thinking on the break that if we do make
a run for it to the king side we're
inviting Knight G6 check
yeah I think I think Wesley is actually
just winning yes just winning yeah
that's it yeah he's just winning here
yeah 96 is out there but I think he he
will be able just to escape so I will
show you some of the variations now
yeah so now King H1 played actually if
we go back a second here if you play the
move Knight G6
simply King E8
and now Rook E1 check and King will go
to D7 and suddenly there are no more
checks G4 is protected by the queen and
Knight on C6 is doing a good good job
controlling the E5 score and and the
game is over now because you you don't
have a way to protect the F2 Pawn here
right so King H1 Rook takes uh F2 for
example so that's why he played uh after
King f8 he actually played the best move
uh firusha played King H1
so there are still some tricks in the
position here because uh there are still
threats such as Knight to G6 and you
have to play actually very precisely
here you need to play this move Queen e
Force check
King G1 and then play the move King E8
try to bring the king to D7 and this is
the precise way to play so let's take a
look here if you try to just take the
pawn after King H1 let's say Rook takes
it Rook takes F2 for example right then
actually a very nice move Rook E1 first
you want to cut the Kinks so the king
cannot cross to the E file then you're
threatening also Knight G6 now and now
evaluation actually dropped to almost
equal here so you have to play Queen F6
and then you lose the G4 pawn and now
still Knight G6 uh threat is out there
you have to play 97 so it's very very
tricky here so I like this move King H1
from alireza and he played it pretty
quickly here so now the pressure is on
Wesley try to come up with the best move
you can play Queen E4 also Knight E7 is
a really good move here as well try to
restrict the ninth movement covering the
G6 and F5 squares and here's if you take
for example on C7 then actually Queen E4
check first you give this check and now
if the King goes to G1 then you have
actually Queenie one check picking up on
F2 with the tempo so both moves here
Knight E7 or queen E4 check for first
follow the follow it up by King gate
will give an advantage
just while we were talking there was a
repetition in the game between Fabi and
and dioc and those players agreed to a
draw so again for results out of our
five games uh ended in a draw and you're
saying uh give us a valuation it was is
it like two points or so
um or how big is that I mean it's a an
extra Pawn but it's pawn and position
too yeah it's about a little bit two and
a half two and a half two and a half
inch here yeah I mean queen E4 in
particular I think it's a it's a very
natural move to play here because you
really want to control that move rookie
one because the problem here we see the
king wants to escape but white also
wants to play the move rookie want to
cut the king and threaten Knight G6 so
that's why we played the move Queen E4
check first right forcing the king to G1
and then I think simply you put the King
on E8 now you would like to bring the
the king to D7 here and if you for
example play Queen GA check I can simply
play Rook f8 and you don't have any more
good checks you really don't want to
play the move Queen G6 and go to an end
game because with four and two majority
you're likely to lose that position
right and uh Queen G7 for example to
keep the pieces on the board then Knight
D4 comes in as a very strong move now
threatening Knight E2 check and again
you don't have an option to take this
Pawn With The Rook because you're always
going to run into Queen E1 ideas right
and here actually you just get checked
right Rook takes F2 and Knight F3 made
so yeah if Wesley finds this move Queen
E4 check
and then Place uh
he did he played Queen E4 check King G1
is on the board bar
yeah so
yeah I think it's a
he has very good chances now to win the
game here after Queen E4
also sorry is isn't 97 also a very good
move I mean I I appreciate that King E8
is probably a simpler more precise and
get on your hiking boots but 97 awesome
after after King G1 97.
because there's this Queenie one check
if you take on C7 right yeah but now
actually if you play 97 here Queen H6
check oh and uh you go to E8 and now
very interesting move Queen to D2
just to consolidate the position and now
threatening the move Rook E1
that's funny yeah and suddenly if you
put the King on D7 Rook E1 yeah now
removing the queen from a very strong
position and then there is some strong
Contra play along the e-file here Queen
E6 now is threatened and actually uh you
know things can turn around here perhaps
even some some prices for white here
that's so funny because I wanted to put
the Knight on E7 to dominate The Knight
on H4 and I ended up tricking myself
hoisted by my own batard hate that uh
yeah so in fact it it's King E8 and only
King E8 absolutely yes King 8 only moved
to maintain the big Advantage here now
do we think Wesley already saw King E8
before playing 24 I suspect he did
probably because it's like one of those
things when you know you've played the
move G4 the king side's no longer safe
for the kid but the queen side is very
inviting there's a very nice uh
protective Pond Shield that the king
might be able to hide behind so I do
suspect that he has King E8 and King D7
in mind one of the things that I I've
always admired about Wesley's chess is
he's a very good closer when he gets the
positions where he feels like okay this
is this is a winning Advantage he he he
he plays them convert in his yes
confidently at that and by the way uh
what a big takedown that would be I mean
again the black faces with the black
pieces the number one seed the defending
Grand Chester Champion uh well let's not
count the chickens before they hatch
because we've already had four draws but
Wesley so in pole position and uh King
Ji King G1 if we did see King EA to
touch the king
I saw him on the camera yeah if we do
see the move King E8 and there we go he
he's played it uh how does the engine
recommend
that white make it difficult for us
opponent what's
what could Ali Reza do to make life
difficult for Wesley after King gate yes
yeah so there are a few different ways
he can play here he can play a rook D1
is is the the best option for him so now
putting some pressure on D5 and now
Knight D4 is the very best move here
activating the Knight a very natural
move but then you can play Queen G8
check okay Rook f8 right and the best
option is to play Queen G6 ooh letting
the letting the queen trade and the
Knight into F3 as well yes yeah again
this is this is probably just winning
for black but right this is one of the
best options because now you have the
90s hanging on D4 and also the D5 Pawn
so if Knight F3 check you have King G2
Rook F6 and
yeah if you play Knight F4 just D4 and
black should be just winning sure you
can try to play Knight H4 uh but now D4
is quite strong and take on F3 then you
take back with the pawn it's very
important you keep the D4 Pawn here and
to King H3 C5 and this looks terrible
black black should be winning here yeah
yeah this just looks like the pawns are
just gonna go straight and this is the
best Line This is the best line for us
well that's that that's not much
resistance very good for Wesley yeah and
and and the turnaround was once again if
you don't mind identifying where did
things go wrong for I'll erase it I
didn't think that G5 was that but maybe
psychologically it was decisive right
actually G5 is the top move in this
position for black I mean Rook F7 is
another option in this position but G5 I
like this move because it's actually
putting lots of pressure on future
because it looked like black was just
trying to play for equality the entire
game but now suddenly he's playing for a
win and feroza didn't have that much
time and he spent his last few minutes
after this move and the decisive mistake
actually answer is that king move when
we get there I will point out now G4
Knight H4 check and here yeah yes he had
to play the move King G1 right this
actually makes a big difference and
still probably it should be around equal
here but uh because you're not going to
have those problems with the F2 Pawn
hanging but after yeah King H1 but it's
interesting that he had time to think
here because this is the 41st move so he
actually could have spent maybe 10
minutes or so try to calculate the move
King G1 but he he played uh pretty
quickly King H2 and this was the big
mistake so if you played King G1 here we
can take a look at this line again
Knight D4 and uh it's possible that he
maybe didn't see this idea Rook D1 that
is putting pressure on the Knight and
also you move the Rook away from C1 so
the 92 is no longer that strong again
um you can play Knight E2 which is the
best move there is an option with Knight
takes F3 here but Knight F3 checks sorry
just Knight takes F3 GTX F3 and now
there is a queen G5 check and this lines
are just going to be about equal here
after king f8 queen takes D5 because the
F3 Pawn is strong but actually in a rook
end game this could be weak as well
after Rook F5 or Rook D3 ideas so this
this is just equal here for example in
the line Queen takes D5 Rook takes D5
rookie one check
King H2 rookie 2.
so Rook B5 is one of the options to
maintain the equality here right
um so it's all about that King age yes
two move made on made after the time
control had been made
yes
yeah the the last move of time control
is costing is the game that move 40. I
think this is move 41. very common for
chess players to make the biggest
mistake of the game on move 41. really
uh because my generation was always
taught the moment we made time control
we didn't care if your next move was
Queen takes Queen check you just got up
from the board you went to the bathroom
you washed your face and hands
and he came back with a Fresh Approach I
think he was carrying this idea
previously that he was going to go King
H2 and didn't really understand that
King G1 was necessary sorry I agree
however sometimes even when we do that
we take a break come back look at the
game with a fresh mind that actually
hurts us because we were before in the
game in the moment calculating
everything now all of a sudden we're out
of it yeah and we can make a mistake we
can forget about some lines that we
previously calculated and now they're
working gee I mean we were always you
know like this was our this is the way
we did things and you learn to accept
them do not question uh this way yeah no
we were always taught that I know what
you're saying you you your mind is
buzzing you you're trying to make the
time control you're you're under
pressure of the clock and so you've
you've calculated this this dream of
consciousness this
you look at your score sheet you made 40
you see the time you bounce and you've
got your extra hour and we were just
told just get up from the board just
just leave and just you know
recalibrate you know stretch whatever
and then you're right now you come back
to the game can't think of it you can't
remember a damn thing you're gonna
analyze you don't even remember what you
want to do but I have found that in my
experience that break
stop me
for making move like King H2 more often
than the
the reversed and in other words I did
benefit from uh just taking a completely
Fresh Approach by the way we do have a
different move after Queenie for check
King H1 King E8
um Queen D2 right in rookie one with the
threat of rookie one so can black just
keep going with the King to D7 and C8
yes
um yeah I was just wondering we can also
potentially just take over the e-file
but let's let's take a look because this
is uh the simplest right King to D7 and
so now we've got our running shoes We've
ran across the board by the way the
Knight on H4 kind of feels a little high
and dry right so if we go rookie one
Queen D4 I am assuming you know let's
trade Queens but can I use the e-file at
all no
Queen E2 walks right into rookie seven
and that
no or does it yeah I know I don't think
it does I think you can and you don't
have to take my rook and be a nice
person and walk
yeah you can yeah so rookie yeah no King
D7 looks like a pretty darn good move to
me 57 might be better just to not even
let white get the evening I like that
move too uh just yeah just taking over
the game completely actually in some
ways right because now we've got
you've got no threats this guy is off
yeah okay cannot even try to bring the
Knight back because if we move Knight G2
yeah and Black's night immediately comes
to the game via D4 or E5 and that looks
like game over yeah that is that is
definitely painful the White Knight has
to stay on H4 yeah
um it's actually
intriguing to me I I did this
when I was becoming a master player
I had the idea that the chess board as a
Battlefield
had squares that were optimal
what I would call Prime squares so
Bishops they're the prime squares for
the Bishops if you were white were E4
and D4 because they control the most of
the board and the prime squares for the
knights were always F3 C3 F6 and C6 so
if I'm black I'm trying to put a knight
on F3 I'm trying to put in Knight on C3
and vice versa so when we just reached
this position I mean I'm in my element
the moment I see this move Knight E4
because I'm coming to a price like for
Rooks it's a dream to get to the seventh
rank that's interesting for the knights
it's F3 C3 exactly that was exactly
right did you have those ideas too that
the the chess Battlefield there were
certain and the long diagonals for the
Bishops that that certain squares were
definitely yeah definitely mostly for
Rooks that seventh rank is the dream
right and for the Bishops to get them to
the center and open diagonals but
actually it's the first time hearing
about the knights on c3f3 and C6 F6 you
can claim it as an original
how about you did you ever have that in
your your Consciousness that this 64
squares of the chessboard some squares
are good and some squares are bad yes I
do especially the central squares I've
always been a you know big big thing for
me just to try to control the center
squares and here I think in particular
the night on H4 is we see is out of
place and the only thing it's doing
actually controlling the F3 Square
otherwise the knife will jump in on D4
immediately yeah and uh but here yeah
Wesley actually playing pretty quickly
too he just almost immediately played
them the best move rookie seven here
okay taking away that rookie one idea
and I think his couple of moves away
from just uh consolidating his position
and we see Rook D1 now played
um very very quickly d5.4 D4 again the
best move here and yeah it it's hard to
see what is really alireza gonna do here
the best option he has here uh I mean F3
is I don't think he's gonna play F3 I
think Queen G5 is the move that probably
he will try to go for try to bring the
queen on B5 perhaps but here actually he
can just play King D7
and now if you play the move Queen B5
just put the King on C8 now the king is
very safe now on C8 and if you take the
pawn on A4 now still there is a threat
of Queen A8 so again black will just
take his time to put the King on B8 and
uh he's he's getting ready now to also
activate the Knight on D4 and this is
just completely winning even though we
just gave the pawn back so let's say
queen C4 trying to keep it under control
just Rook D7
wow and again the d-pawn is very strong
and the Knight on H4 is just simply
offside here and if you try to trade
Queens the problem is now your knight
after I exchange Queens I simply play
Knight E5 centralizing my knight
Rook D1 and I continue with C5
and this evaluation is like almost plus
four here and it's completely winning
for black wow this idea of just uh
Johnny come lately you know give up the
A4 Pawn like is no problem I mean he
worked hard to win that pawn and just to
give it away like that I like the move
D5 D4 Queen G5 I'm not sure I would go
for this whole King D7 C8 B8 and let him
take my pawn queen G5 I mean Wesley last
four moves he made the best moves
quickly very quickly yeah Queen G5 would
that be in your approach just as VAR
described it Go King CA Queen B5 King
King B8 I think so because even though
King seems pretty safe on E8 we still
don't want to leave it there no no uh
I'm you know it was actually funny
because uh
my training
is whenever I was oops excuse me
whenever I was a head material I just
dragged my opponent to their Doom
by Trading so I see this move Queen B5
and I start looking at you know like how
can I you know trade queens and you know
get uh get something like that going uh
of course any exchange for black is a
big deal big deal right there is a rook
D4 threat if you play Queen E2 here just
just in case
look at that that's a nice visual
talk yes
and the Knight isn't a pin that is a
good point so that's why kick needs to
go to a safer Square to C8 and even B8
and I was about to say this was for me a
very computer engine move like uh VAR is
asking the computer in exactly at this
moment what is Ali Rey's best move
in the computer says F3
no human being is ever reaching for
their F Bond and going F2 F3 right here
right now no human players are going to
go Queen G5 and VAR insisted that the
move Queen g5b played and the engine
says well in that case just go ahead and
give away give back the pawn and your
and your golden because this guy's
really strong this guy's really weak and
look at all of these other factors in
your favor
big Advantage black white is almost in
this position because the Knight cannot
move the Rook doesn't have anywhere good
to go but no you gave back the A4 Pawn
how could you I mean sacrilege you know
uh you work so hard to win it but yeah I
I get it I mean uh just put your king in
safety as well that that that's a a big
part of it too D4
but who knows if anyone's going to play
F3 it can be firusha why why is it about
ferrugia that makes you think that he's
the type of player that would make such
a move well watching his games I think
first of all because he's a younger
player he most likely grew up with the
engines right so he's more used to
seeing moves like this okay so it can
definitely come to his mind and his
position seems so desperate right that
he might try something desperate you
know Desperate Measures being called for
but F3 poof that is such a so I what is
the idea of F3 exactly I assumed it was
to bring the Knight back into the game
for example after takes Rook F1 or I
don't know Queen F2 maybe uh in any case
the idea being that yeah that part on G4
versus the Knight and
the engine thinks that this is your best
chance whereas
a white king definitely a little weaker
but
an idea is that if we exchange F1 for
the g-pawn then most of the end games
we're looking at they were lost because
our Knight was really bad on H4 exactly
here it wouldn't be the case anymore if
we ended up winning the pawn on F3 with
the Knight on by bringing the Knight
back to F3 but as VAR was saying too I
mean that's a four versus two majority
right that should you know be be winning
and again uh now uh with one game
remaining uh again we encourage you to
join the conversation challenge our
panel of experts how little do they know
uh by uh tweeting us uh the social media
who's who's Manning the social media for
us
is doing it and a big shout out to our
colleague and friend Anastasia as well
so we're ready for your questions as
we're kind of coming into a dry spell at
the moment your take on the position bar
yeah well I think uh if eurusha is still
thinking right now and he's trying to
figure out what to do here he probably
realizes at this moment that it's just a
losing position but let's take a look uh
if there are any more options so he did
play Queen G5 so he he's going for that
line now with Queen G5 and um now the
question is if Wesley will play the move
King D7 if he plays this idea King D7
and bring the king to C8 I think he will
just simply win the game pretty shortly
here
um let's take a look at another move
here 95 for example because it looks
like a very natural move that would be a
move I would love to play yeah
um but there is a little tactic here
yeah so Rook takes D4
Queen takes D4
queen of E7
okay but this is a night ending I love
yeah but it's losing it's losing Knight
to F5 for for black is winning yeah
black is winning yeah exactly no the
problem is the king is just too far away
and you're gonna you're gonna lose your
queen Side Pawn so even though it looks
very pretty but I think at the end of
the line you're just simply losing here
so like if you play Knight E2
now the threat is Knight C3 checks so
perhaps you can just play King 2 C4 and
you have 93 coming up so right it's just
a winning end game easy so let's see
Knight G5 so if 95 um so Rook D4 doesn't
work uh the very best
95 he's done it
yeah the very best move here actually
for right now for white is to play Queen
F4 but again this is another move
probably we're not gonna see because
after the exchange on F4 now white has
double pawns and Knight C6 will be
played right and again we have four and
two majority here and Rook E2 is coming
up as well so
so yeah it looks like it's just a
winning Advantage here Knight G2 for
example
and now
this I love for black yeah because it's
such an easier yeah it has such an
easier feel to it than King cea King B8
and it's very human to win a position
like this yeah so I think 95 is also a
very good move and uh looks like Wesley
is on his way to win this game and grab
the lead in this tournament
who picked Wesley
none of us did I was shame on you shame
on you come on the show
well he was starting with the black
pieces against our top seeds right right
right right okay so wow uh nice move and
again
you know King D7 King C8 King B8 you
know
with perfect hindsight you get to that
position and you go wow it really is
good even though the material is even it
is really good for for uh White it
wasn't as being very practical yeah but
I find this move Knight E5
really attractive because I really do
want white to play roof fixed E4 because
I know that this is such a easy winning
night ending right you know and it's all
because black left the king in the
center
it's a really great centralizing move
too and it just shows the domination of
the night only five versus the night on
H4 precise and end game as you mentioned
yes there's just it's evident that it's
just completely lost that end game even
though we're losing the pawn but just
the king being on D5 versus the King on
G1 there that's there's nothing also
simply just black and white screen from
going to B5 which was the I only idea
behind Queen G5 and there's one last
thing and
this is what I would call a human factor
I carry the luggage with me of what
happened before computers don't they
don't care all they care about is the
position of the board
black almost from the start of the game
has had his Knight on C6
festooned in front of the sea Pond now
you get to play 95 for the first time
it's a kind of a Liberation you know
this Knight has been stuck on C6 for
this eternity now you're liberated your
next move is going to be C5 everybody's
going to call you a genius how did you
how did you attend and I might even make
it all the way to F3 and the night might
make it to F3 I mean so many things to
be said uh in favor of the move Knight
E5 I find that move to resonate with me
on a lot of different levels I like move
95 what does a computer now think of 95
I know King D7 was its highest valuation
but did 95 change it greatly one way or
another it's they're they're about the
same actually yeah and uh I think Queen
F4 is actually the very very best move
here
everything else everything else is like
plus four plus five now wow so you
really have to play the move Queen F4
which you really don't want to do but as
you mentioned yes sir once the black
plays the move C5 this game is
completely over now right it wouldn't be
any Contra play after the move C5 so so
he has to play you know we can look at
again this move uh Queen uh Queen F4
actually and uh Queen takes F4 once
again G takes
uh F4 uh again it's very important to
play Knight C6 here because you don't
want to lose the D4 Pawn Knight C4 also
gives you a nice Advantage but this is
the most precise move Knight C6 again
threatening rookie two if let's say you
try to play the move King F1 trying to
prevent this now uh there is a rook E4
move yeah activating the rook and now if
you play Knight G2 now you're back to a
very passive defense and uh simply you
can play King E7 for example
and white can try to Black can try to
bring his King closer to the center and
then eventually move the Knight to
Knight A5 and play C5 and again the best
move is rookie one here but we know once
we trade Rooks yeah it's completely
hopeless
yeah that looks really really tough and
here we see at the board what it's like
a little suffering going on we yeah
we've all been there we know that
feeling that is for sure clearly
announced that this is not going his way
and it's about to be over soon so yeah
and Wesley looks very calm and I think
he knows he's just by the way is it just
me but is isn't everybody the tournament
sporting new haircuts I mean this looks
like a new look at least half of them
yeah right I mean uh Ali razor looks
like he's sporting something uh
different than our grand chest tour
winner of La last year
yeah okay uh Queen F4 boy I don't think
he will play Queen of four I know that's
like accepting the defeat really right
going for Queen F4 however
what else is there yeah it's those
Alternatives that we start to wonder
maybe Queen H6
Queen H6 okay
per K what are we doing with Queen H6
we're anticipating C5 and we're going to
go across let's say C5 we go to D6 or
something like this let's say first we
give a check Queen h8 and then go from
the behind from Queen B8 maybe okay
still no threats though everything is
protected true exactly it's nothing for
white no black can simply push C4 or D3
yes yeah precisely
so Knight E5
um is down to six minutes what on the
clock wow that second time control yeah
I mean that went by in the rap
rapidly and as a reminder our schedule
right uh we have nine rounds and today
we're seeing round one uh we will play
five rounds in a row and then on May
11th we'll have a rest day looking
forward to the rest day already wait a
minute this is only round one and after
that four more rounds until the end
exactly
tournament will be completed Monday May
14th
um besides Queen F4 because yeah I I'm
with uh Najee on this one that feels
like a kind of a resignation everything
else is minus four minus five yeah
absolutely I mean you can play a queen
C1 Queen it's another like this another
one of the best moves but it's like we
can take a look uh if you play Queen C1
um
so again there are many ways to continue
here but uh you can play D3 which is
winning Queen D5 as well but for example
just D3 I think it's it's very natural
there's there's just no Contra play the
way the black pieces are set up the
Knight is controlling all the squares
The Rook only seven and uh here you
don't even have to move the king king is
actually absolutely fine on E8 in this
particular line again uh the best move
is now to play Queen F4 right to try to
trade Queens because the D trip on is
hanging but here uh we don't have to
trade there are two different ways to
continue but the best move is actually
Queenie two attacking The Rook and if
you play Rook D2 Queen E1 check
King goes on G2 and now simply you can
play the move B5 for example protecting
the A4 pawn and uh White cannot really
move anything there are no threats there
there's no check
yeah light is completely stuck and yeah
let's say you're playing try to bring
the Knight to F5 and then that's going
to run into the move Knight F3
7 and maybe one mate
yeah
looks awful
looks awful wow and just as a reminder
uh of the five games of round one four
have already been drawn all of the four
draws I must say had content to them
including that between being an MBL if
you replay through the game it looks
like a queen's gamut accepted that just
became drawn no no underneath is a great
deal of attention Novelties in every
game right including the game I just
referenced there H7 H6 uh
yeah
sure looks like the 200 years men in
Bucharest on stage right now well I can
tell you one man is feeling very very
very lonely is our number one seed the
man in blue or he's had what color is
that I think it's blue
right and queen back to D2
not not the
the move you know of Champions that uh
we came we expect Wesley to play C5
right away or can he even push D3 I
think he'll consider D3 as well well D3
rookie one
rookie one might have some now I'd
probably go with C5 myself yeah just
because I played Knight
if Queen A5
okay attacking A4 once again yes yes
it seems like uh
that that is kind of like it almost
feels like a one-trick pony but I love
my pawns I I'll just defend both the a
five Pawn as well as the C5 pawn and in
fact Knight on E5 is completely
dominated and the Knight on H4 just
makes such a such a sorrowful sight
Queen D2 uh we're we're torn uh VAR
we're torn between D3 and C5 and just
enjoying the position
yeah I think uh the there are so many
different ways to win here there is one
line I want to show you here guys so if
you play the move D3 yeah I know
yesterday you mentioned the move rookie
one here yeah but then there is a very
nice tactic Queen takes C1 it takes E1
Knight F3 check I'll take that you take
that and now Rook takes E1 and when you
take back now we have the pawn going to
D2 and threatening now to take the
Knight and the one is going to be
unstoppable so that wins the game on the
spot chess is cool because of that I
like the D3 move as the best because now
even if you play like move like Queen A5
now even a four Pawn is protected and
actually if you play this move black can
just simply played a very calm move B6
right it just shows how great these
pieces are the queen only four is
centralized at night it's just there's
just no threats in this position you
have to go back now to D2 and now you
can continue with the move Queen
uh E2 or you can even just play the move
C5 if you would like so the evaluation
is like uh almost plus eight right now
so but also you can play the move C5
which you guys were looking at and if
there is a move Queen A5 for example you
can just simply play a very calm move
Queen C6 now protecting the A4 pawn and
uh there's just one check here on eight
and you just put your King on D7 it's
it's very very safe here and there's
just no control play once again the
black piece are very very well placed
here in the middle of the board
yeah this is uh one of those cases of
simple domination uh the Knight on E5
versus the Knight on H4 to begin with
extra material as our friend uh
Grandmaster Roman jinji harshvilly likes
to say uh black has pawn and
compensation
which I think uh says it says it all uh
Queen D2 I I really like that variation
you just showed us with rookie one that
moved D3 and falling into the Trap of
rookie one that would be a beautiful
ending to this beautiful game exactly
exactly uh d3d2 would be a nice one this
time he has 10 minutes and alireza has
only three minutes left on the clock and
then the players will be completely
Reliant upon the 30-second increment for
the rest of the game which I think for
black in this position
Wesley could win this position with just
30 seconds on the clock yes yes exactly
and both players are so well trained
with these time controls of 30 seconds
uh bonus that they they 30 second
increment bonus they know what's going
on
and uh just uh let's take a sneak peek
at what the pairings for round two hold
for us right so tomorrow looks like we
have Maxima Sherlock against Wesley so
possibly playing the tournament leader
exactly and we have Gary against firoza
rapper against Duda
diak against nipomishi and our new
Champion ding
versus Fabiano caruana well we know
number one yeah yeah in the uh
um
the drawing of the Lots uh drawing the
number one number one seed you get two
whites in a row to start the tournament
it's a couple of times in my career that
I drew the number one seed and as far as
I remember knock on wood
I won those tournaments oh yeah starting
with two whites it's just huge because I
just felt in so many of my round robin
tournaments that I played into my career
the last rounds
were oftentimes draws so if you started
the tournament with two whites and your
last round was you had a black it almost
felt like you were going downhill the
whole tournament everything was going in
your favor so the drawing in my
experience the number one uh it was
really really favorable uh what was your
take in your career of our
yeah I also had a number one pairing a
couple of times I usually like to start
with two white in a row and I remember
doing well I don't think I won some big
tournaments but I think one of the US
championships I started with two whites
and I had a pretty good result but in
general uh I play much better with the
white pieces so it suits my style better
and having extra white in this kind of
events is I think very very important
nice and we do have some we have a lot
of reluctance after the move D3 Queen F4
put on the board uh by um I think now
taking on F4 is not a good move anymore
because it will hang the D3 Pawn
right so something like this this and
there's no trickies here you know some
wonderful D2 uh still favorable
[Music]
exactly what Wesley wants uh he would
certainly like to have more Queen F4
we're not obliged to capture we could
for example go Queenie too right
sacrifice that pawn on A4 that's been
oh
Evan helped me what did I just do did I
sacrifice the pawn on A4 Maybe not maybe
I did Queen A4 and you can just play
Rook D7 I think
Rook d7b5
uh B5 just because there is oops excuse
me
yeah you want to sacrifice a second Pawn
well sir no no no no uh
uh it was just that your queen no B5
Queen B5 C6 you could go Queen A4 back
yeah okay but check fine
uh you're just kind of like a little bit
offside over there your Rook is under
attack your knight is kind of offside
over there
and I still have these ideas of Rook F7
and D2 or just simply D2 I think or even
simply D2 so I think Queen E2 uh besides
Queen E2
I can also probably move the queen back
to C6
also just to not even give up A4 Pawn
right that would be the the greed Factor
uh I kind of actually like just
domination again right Queen on D5 there
was something about this setup of the
long diagonal the Knight on E5 but I'm
thinking Queen E2 uh is clean uh am I
are we right absolutely Equity is the
best move it's so it's very natural and
oftentimes in this kind of positions
when you have a pass Pawn on D3 you want
to have a queen uh closer to the
promoting square and here you're
actually putting pressure on the The
Rook on D1 so we can take a look at some
of the lines here whoa whoa whoa whoa
sorry very surprised a big surprise for
us he did decide take okay to capture on
F4 but you were about to show us that
Queen E2 was was a cleaner line yeah
Queenie 2 is just winning in every line
actually because uh if you play Queen
takes A4 check yeah just just d8 simple
and now you can't really move anything
so if you play Queen a check just simply
King D7 yeah Queen A4 check and now just
C6 yeah and uh white is stuck yeah the
best move is actually to play Knight G6
here to just give up the Knight and then
Queen D4 check pick up pick up the pawn
on D3 but uh otherwise also I have a
very strong threat of Rook F7 coming up
and right taking on F2 so this this
would have won the game uh immediately
but Queen takes F4 with his choice G
takes F4 Knight C4 Rook takes D3 is on
the board and I assume Wesley's
intention is to go Rook check and Rook
B1 he'd like to keep the Knight on C4
hitting the A3 Pawn uh how
is this also still fully winning VAR
after Rook check King G2 Rook
B1 I'm assuming this is what Wesley
wants he just took on V2 right away okay
now I can't guess at all
I give up Knight takes B2 how big an
event well is it a winning Advantage
let's put it down it's it's almost plus
two but definitely I see some chances
now for uh alireza and uh Wesley perhaps
rushed a little bit
and now Knight takes B2 and um Rook C3
is actually a very important move here
you have to try to keep the Knight away
from C4 Square yeah he played it okay or
C3 and
well the the setup I'd love is B5 Knight
C4
um I'm confused I I I get this part but
why didn't he take on B2 with his Rook
was there something I'm missing Rook
check King G2 Rook B1 so let's say if
you play a rook E1 check yeah in G2 yeah
B1 trying to take back with the Rook I
think there is uh there is some Contra
Play Now with uh
you can start with Knight F5 for example
Rook takes P2 takes P2 now he plays Rook
C3
P5 P5
see that I'm thinking C4 sure win the
game yeah right
uh C6 probably right because the threat
is Knight B5 no yeah C6 and then it
plays King G3 not to allow Rook B3 but
this might be uh still this is probably
still winning after King D7 so yes sir
this might have been uh more clean
because you do have that three on one
majority you should be able to which is
a kind of a dream right I mean but
Knight takes B2 I was talking about
prime squares for Knights it's actually
crazy but the worst squares for Knights
are the fianchetto squares like in this
case the Knight on B2 is like extremely
limited yeah it's kind of like a No
Man's Land I think maybe Wesley's idea
is to quickly force them more exchanges
with Rook D7 and Rook D3 because the
night end game would be completely
winning yes he would like to force that
that's most Rook D7 is the very best
move here and he needs to find this move
otherwise there'll be some serious
chances now Rook D7 it's very very
strong now Rook D7 the very best move
and still winning
he's made his life a little bit more
Awkward yeah he's still winning but it's
just much more difficult now I see and
this Knight needs to come to E3 at some
point so that's why engine prefers to
play Knight G2 and try to bring this
Knight to E3
okay well ignite in my estimation the
Knight on E3 would be excellent because
it has a kind of a domination over the
night on B2 right
and you're hitting G4 and you're hoping
to go F5 and
so do you think Wesley thought that this
end game was completely winning yes he
just made a rush of judgment and also
it's one of those things when you're so
close to the goal post and you say Okay
I want to make the simplest line right
you see Queen F4 Exchange in Queens he
thought he got rid of
older play right and just an extra 30
seconds to consider Queen E2 he would
have realized oh that is really uh
Finnish
um again I'm looking this night on B2
and I'm saying this has got to be one of
the worst squares you could be on it
exactly at this moment so black can
black play B5 immediately to try to
bring the knife back to C4 I think that
was actually our first move right once
we realized he was actually going for
Knight takes B2 uh didn't we play
there we go he found the only or the
best wow
that is not an an intuitively obvious
move at all if I if I gave this to you
as a puzzle rush I think a lot of people
would have reached for the B5 pawn and
and thought to themselves this has got
to be the correct answer the problem
with the B5 move guys is there is a rook
C5 move which is very strong and it's
very difficult now to
protector because I have C6 don't I bark
yeah yeah you have C6 but uh I can't
take but also I can start with the move
Knight G6 for example ah wise guy and uh
maybe try to bring the Knight only five
and take with a knight so let's say
rookie one check I go kg2
Knight C4
Rook takes C6
Knight A3 and
you know suddenly this F Pawn is is real
very quick yeah I mean F6 I mean not it
is real counter play I I agree I agree
this has not been
you know my finest moment that is for
sure
yeah and why is this move so much
Superior to b5r uh it's actually
allowing some of the line to play the
move Knight D3 as well in some positions
so you want to go Knight D3 C5 b5b
exactly yeah Knight on D3 and then you
start pushing C5 and B5 uh firosha needs
to bring this Knight into the game here
this is absolutely crucial here for him
either to play the move Knight G6 in
this position to bring it to E5 or try
to play the move Knight G2 bring it to
E3 so he has to play one of these Muses
down to less than one minute on a clock
so
um but he has some chances here
evaluation is not that large after the
move Knight G2 for example there are
some chances for him here to try to save
this game yeah I see the advantages
actually a mere 1.2 which I would not
have guessed I would have guessed the
mature 30 of three versus one the queen
side the double pawns I would have
thrown out two you know just like an
advantage of two for black he did not
play Knight
G6 to E5 or Knight to G2 to E3 play King
G2 did that injure his chances then yeah
I think now the evaluation jumped here
and again the main idea of this Rook D7
is now you play Knight D3 putting the
Knight on uh D3 attacking the pawn on F4
but the most important thing you want to
do is play C5 yeah for example and now
you play the move C5 okay those pawns
before is coming up yeah now those pawns
B5 B4 they look suddenly
and black doesn't have to worry
Unstoppable whites
fun because it's not really a past one
on that floor and not only that the king
is on E8 in great anticipation you know
you're gonna take three more moves to
trundle up the board to F7 and I've
already got your blockaded knight D3 on
the board hitting the pawn on F4 I'm
assuming that uh King G3 was ali
reason's uh idea that he wanted to
activate his King and after for example
F5 and King takes G4 somehow he got into
his mind
this position it looks like a race but
it's not really a race it's not much of
a race
another thing that night on the T does
really well it actually blockades The
Rook on C3 so you don't have a way to
actually bring it to E3 or try to give
any checks there exactly so and now just
not as active anymore the reconcity so
King G3 played and now uh
C5 is the most precise way to start here
because if you play the move B5 you are
allowing for example a move like Rook C6
which you don't want to allow in this
position
from your words to Wesley's ears after
King G3 C5 on the board
yeah they are blitzing out their moves
now because now they're on their
Intimates right 37 to five minutes and
alirez has been playing with just 30
second increments already last couple of
moves right and it looks hopeless for
white exactly let me stop B5 B4 exactly
I was looking at F5 B5 King takes G4 B4
is looking at takes takes hakasito now
I'm assuming
we're going to play Rook d8
because I mean this would be a dream
come true at least as far as you know I
I I'm probably losing but yeah I got
something going I I feel like I'm in the
game you know I'm competing uh the
problem that I'm having is actually
right here is this move Rook d8
then suddenly maybe Rook C7 hoping for
Knight G6 and some Checkmate ideas oh
okay okay okay where there's where
there's uh life There's Hope
that's boy it's probably 15 different
ways black and defend this probably and
uh more or less they're catching up to
our analysis I think I started with F5
as opposed to King takes G4 alireza
did no King takes Chi for himself
he's fine
excuse me
well
nothing else to be said maybe he will
try to bring the Knight finally back
into the game right now Knight F3
no he goes Knight F5
and that was an interesting kind of
swing with the Knight right and then
like night
I'm intimidating yeah big move there
big circular move sorry Knight F5 B4 a
takes C takes Rook C check can we just
play King F7 and not worry about
anything yes
yes
that would certainly be uh the it's
funny how I think it's like I am so
greedy it's not that I don't want to
allow you a check a check itself doesn't
scare me but the idea that your Rook at
night could somehow coordinate makes me
in Intuit the move King d8 so that after
B4 Abe you know somehow you're rook and
you showed me a moment ago a checkmating
pattern that just came out of the blue
but that was because you're Rook at
night coordinate uh but yes of course
you were right B4 a b CB check King F7
um
I don't see any Checkmate patterns here
no unfortunately but I do see two uh
connected I forgot I think Pawn on F2 is
actually hanging as well you never
really needed it but yes you were right
the power on F2 is hanging too so uh is
King d8 excessively cautious uh VAR uh
both moves are winning here you can
start with the King d8 just if you want
to prevent this Rook C8 idea but also
you can play the B4 move immediately and
I think that's what Wesley is trying to
figure out so if you start with the move
key in d8 now yeah Knight E3 is because
you really need the Knight into the game
to try to somehow prevent this Pawn from
immediately quinning so let's say Knight
E3 comes in you have B4 right now takes
Pawn takes and now you don't have any
more Rook C8 ideas right and you're
hoping somehow to get a position where
you can sacrifice the knife for the two
pounds of course that's that's the whole
but you're not going to be able to to
achieve that so for example Rook C4 if
you play now you can just play B3
giving up a pawn but after the move B2
the pump cannot be stopped now and okay
check just King C7 gotcha so
but uh actually Wesley played something
else here looks like he just played the
move
King F7
okay that was peculiar because I played
King d8 with the idea starting
preventing The Rook of the night from
coordinating you guys king of seven
similar idea if you play Knight E3 yes
to then continue or before yes yeah
before and
um
we know that we need to put the Rook
behind the pass bonds if we're trying to
stop them so for example we can start
with the move Rook C8 here right but now
again just the move B3 here
and uh if we play the move Rook B then I
think this is an important idea perhaps
uh Rook D4 I love it pinning the
opponent F4 but also at the same time
setting up the move Rook to B4 here
exactly so I think firoza made his move
with just three seconds on the clock oh
really oh we're gonna have to take a
look at the bird's eye uh view from the
yeah there you go you're right
he played King G5 and I think Wesley is
not Russian with push in B4 he's been
prophylactic he played Rook two five
pinned the night I think
no King E6
uh King E6 was the threat so Rook E2
preps right King E6 Rook E2 check
I think now simply B4 looks very
good then the question is why did we
move the roof The Rook was actually
pretty decent
oh sorry no you're right B4 because we
still have kingies yeah I have king of
six yes of course be careful guys there
is actually a mate there if you before
bill you have to be careful
so let's show everybody what uh
Naji has missed
King E6 now you rookie seven mate but of
course that's hilarious when you get to
this position you just play King E8
right and actually the Knight is being
pinned and there's just no way to stop
the pawns here yeah so
all right so white can't even play King
G6 or something there's Knight F4 so
yeah you have to play like King maybe
King F6 but then King B8 is a Tempo on
The Rook yeah and if you play
Rook B7 and here just
three three
and uh yeah this looks the idea just to
play B2 A3 and uh yeah
we have some some really uh let's say
off the Beaten Track moves here just a
second Let me refresh my border be right
back
I love the Knight on D3 me too I thought
it was a a monstrous night and he put
the Knight on E1 I think it's headed to
F3 now
it's logical he wants to play Knight F3
Knight D4 and get rid of why it's only
good piece knight on F5
okay but can he do this by the way Tony
white is time a factor here for just
nine
six
five
four
again again
four and three seconds he's
plenty of time Easy Does It uh the the
fellow who really amazed me was grishock
Wesley just won back 93 because white I
think had this very interesting idea to
play Rook H3 and go Rook H7 and attack
blocks came from ah
so as they realized he shouldn't allow
this and went back 93. I see and so then
Rook C2 came very quickly thereafter
right and now he can play B4 or King E6
King E6 rookie two check king57 I liked
King better on the queen side me too I
thought the King was going to do great
uh work on d8 actually just to cover
some of the entry squares
um is Wesley making this task a little
bit tricky VAR
I think he's just still winning he just
needs to just go for it right now you
know just just calculate that spend
maybe a minute and just play the move
before once he plays B4 you know this is
this is the idea of advancing this pawns
here and just try to get those two
connected past pawns so and it's
important that he does this right now uh
you can play King E6 and try to put the
King on D7 that should be winning as
well
okay so you think King E6
Rook E2 check King D7
now we can we can continue right
but after Rook chat King
yeah C6 I have no continuation yeah I
can just go Kingston by the way
uh he took your advice spent 30 seconds
to a minute and after Rook seat two he
did play the move B4
hey
now Wesley has less time first time no
way
slightly less yes remarkable
they both have about a minute and a half
Rook C7 check King E8 Wesley's beating
up the tempo a little bit he's going
back to d8 yes I I liked it there in the
first place uh but here guys I mean
again it has that illusion that there's
some kind of a race because there's a
Pawn on F4 but these pawns are just you
know squares away from touchdown
remember we'll say King F6 probably on
the board okay let's see what we got
King F6 let's go B3 Oh I thought you
were gonna run with the king king d8 I
was waiting for you to check me or
something
[Music]
um
maybe you do
we don't want this oh no I don't want
this yeah so King F6 pardon me you broke
the pin you're setting yourself up for
Knight G7 you're right I will
um
can you say now A3
A3 now how can I can I somehow engineer
a
I would be shocked if White Knight can
that's what I said yeah sacrifice yeah
that's my dream right that's my and he's
done the king F6 routine so far so he's
he's getting ready for Knight G7 check
hand games are so tricky we've been
saying how black is completely winning
but yeah on every move Wesley has to
still be very careful indeed and King d8
was played he didn't want to see Knight
G7 check 96 check King G7 now I put my
Rook maybe on okay seven black should
just play B3 A3 is a waste of time I
think so too yeah that it actually turns
out that it's helpful for me that you've
played A3 because that makes it easier
for me to try to sacrifice whether it be
a rook or a knight for one of the Palm
for both Pawns
so and uh Wesley blitzed out last few
moves so now he has two and a half
minutes on the clock yeah that that Rook
but the problem is The Rook I'm beat
seven is it's a magnet
yes he's playing the K7 it's a magnet
for uh the king to come to see what I'm
curious about the move B3 Ken black win
by taking Rook F5 here and then just
pushing B3
uh no uh my immediate uh
thought is absolutely correct because
the problem is that after Rook takes I
can't
because I wrote a check I have King C7
and I can't give up my
I I can sacrifice my Rook for the bond
he didn't play it he played B3 maybe
with the idea of Rook takes F5 by the
way
but I think you're right and by the way
if that is true then Rook F5 is by far
the best technical if it is yeah yeah
exactly yeah uh I'll throw that in as a
uh
but B3
um
what's the assessment VAR
um white block is completely winning
um that that line that tenazi suggested
actually it's uh we can take a look
represented tabled
yeah oh by the way we so was it
completely winning no not not so clear
they're just going to be like a position
where you promote to a queen but you
lose your knight and uh queen versus
Rook yeah so look The Rook D4 check
let's say King E7 you take on D3 uh B1
Queen now King E4 and um here if the
king is on G2 we know the Rook on E3 is
it's just a fortress here so the
question is here if block can prevent
that so there's still some winning
chances here but not not really clear if
this is just
clean yes all right let's just get oh
excuse me I'm gonna jump to the current
position uh B3 93 sidestepping now Rook
takes F3 uh Rook takes F5 uh now without
Knight on F5 black king is completely
safe no more possible checks checkmates
so black just has to
push the pawns and that's that's about
it push them baby
King F5 this is B2 right now
uh B2 I will play Rook
B7 and then A3 and then Knight C4
probably one more Rook move and then
then I'll push you too
Fair yeah
you got me on King of six there's Knight
F4 Knight C5 yeah yeah you got me there
was uh their moment there when when
alireza was really close to flagging
to one second one second
wow
his bullet skills are showing exactly
not in the 2023 but rather in the 2022
American Cup
um
the winner of the tournament Fabiano won
his first match against Jeffrey Zhang
where he left himself one second
and he was that close to uh going to the
elimination bracket
um B2 Rook Rook B7
and this is really
yeah this is not enough counter play
anymore A5 I think pretty much
everything here should be winning for
black yeah but A3 really looks really
good maybe King C8 Rook D7 any other
uh there must be a lot of different ways
of winning the seven actually it looks
very good yeah it does doesn't it just
feels like how many squares do you have
on the B file that you could go to if I
go Rook D7 offering a trade of Rooks
King C8 also looks good yes exactly this
just there's not that many
squares
yeah Wesley knows he's winning so he's
taking his time and by the way you told
me he didn't have that much time yeah
he's down to 42 seconds right now okay
but I don't think he is
nervous about his clock because any move
he makes is still winning one of the
strangest things and I just cannot
account for it is sometimes you're
sitting at the board you're calculating
and you forget about the clock as we saw
in the world championship with dingler
in I mean he came incredibly close to
losing and he just ended up pitching the
game badly because he suddenly realized
he was going to lose on time by the way
the move rope D4 I think we spoke about
this in a different position where the
move Rook D4 was incredibly strong
because we were just going to play
before and off for a trade of Brooks and
wide plain id1 okay he played
so he's inviting Rook takes F4 check
which happened very quickly because
we're going to get this King to C8 to
make sure we don't fall into any mating
patterns and then and now White's only
hope is to sacrifice the night for the
two Pawns and you got no chance no
chances that that's going to actually uh
pan out Rook takes I'm assuming no yeah
the King has to go through g-file right
you can't go King E6 because
C5 check oh oh this book takes F2
should be something yeah I understand I
was thinking King C8 followed by Rook C4
it just to kind of you know like I want
to lure your Rook here
so that
I've got the old double attack uh
business do we want that let's say if I
play Knight A3
Rook C5 I will take okay okay okay I'll
uh I'll throw in yeah just to be a
little bit voice on the safer side but
yeah
what's up
he said took my advice
oh
you know
how can winning a pawn ever be back by
the way it just seems like the the table
base just came up
like okay
sorry just option Knight A3
now the easiest way to win is just rock
F1 and Rook A1 which is it
yeah
because you're gonna see a handshake
very soon agreed
there we go we go
what a game wow wow well it may have
been the last to finish but it was
definitely worth was watching it
throughout the black pieces
we mentioned that when Wesley
has that feeling that you know he's in
the winning position he is a really
excellent closure and uh
good game VAR absolutely great game by
Wesley and it was slightly worse for the
long time in this game but managed to
actually outplay this opponent and I
think G5 was a critical moment where he
took over the game maybe perhaps this
was a little bit of a surprise for
alireza when he saw the smooth G5 yeah I
remember when I played tournaments in
Yugoslavia
and whenever there was a win and the
round was going on the audience went
went nuts applause applause applause and
the Arbiters would you know silence and
you know quiet and everything else
and they calmed down and think the
tournament would continue
but when you were the last to finish
and you won then they really went
berserk because there was nobody there
to calm him down and it was sort of like
the audience really wanted to show their
pleasure and their support and I thought
that was just something special
Yugoslavia for chess players was just a
very very special country it doesn't
exist anymore but they love their chess
and here we I'm I'm ashamed of you all
none of you had Wesley
I'm still okay you're still okay okay
everyone's still okay everybody's it's a
long tournament yes sir it's a long
tournament that's a oh we got by the way
we're going to take a sneak peek once
again at tomorrow's pairings and then
for Russian you gotta tell us what you
thought about the first round and here
we are for tomorrow what do we have we
have Maxima Sheila Graf playing our
tournament leader Wesley cell Anish giri
playing alireza we'll see if he will
recover by tomorrow exactly Richard
rapper against Judah dick against
nipomishi and Lindy ran against Fabiano
caruana well we got some of the clashes
of the
of the favorites that we've Chosen and
um
VAR uh very nice opening first round I
thought the games had a lot of content
to them absolutely yeah sir I mean the
games are very interesting despite
having four draws they were very
interesting and especially do that game
against Anish with all this bishop C3
and B7 IDs very interesting and again
but the game of the day of course is
Wesley sauce win with the black pieces
he played a great game you know he was
slightly worse but played some really
precise moves and at the right moment he
took his chances with the move G5 and
the force alireza to make a mistake on
the Move 41st and after that his
technique was I think pretty precise
even though it could have been a little
bit more cleaner but I think he always
had the control of the game and got the
big win it certainly was a huge win and
I'm just kind of surprised that
well you know the move G5 is fine and uh
but I kind of have a feeling there's a
bit of a collapse on the side of faruga
great you played G5 it doesn't mean I
should be destroyed they're after HG HG
they got this position and I think he
just underestimated felt felt it and
found the exact right moment to put some
pressure on ferocia right and G5 was it
yeah but like here again suppose uh uh I
mean I'm not putting too much in but the
idea of Rook E3 so like if you play G4
and I don't know I go maybe a rook F7
first Rook F7 forced so now again you
are threatening and if I go Queen here
in G4 and maybe D4 is hanging
it might not be
it just feels like I shouldn't collapse
right just because you go G5 and you
kick my knight out of Dodge but it just
felt that after Queen D2 G4 Knight H4
Queen E4 Queen and this was it this was
actually King H2O
yes the key moment King G1 might have
kept the position still competitive King
H2 is where it all fell apart now it's
already
underestimated blocks chances in this
position I think he did yes
but let's jump to Bucharest who
Christian is with our tournament leader
Wesley first of all congratulations a
big victory with the black pieces
against uh the defending Champion the
2022 grantchester Champion alireza
always such a dangerous opponent I
almost forgot yeah he's very dangerous I
mean very happy to get a Revenge from
that important game the thing felt cup
and again I'll glare tajita for the win
but uh he was he's he was playing very
ambitiously uh
okay there were several interesting
moments of the game also the opening was
quite interesting in the middle game but
yeah you try this again with Bishop to
B6 and then E5 yeah I think he got
ambitious because
last year he was playing for a win every
single game with all colors if you
remember his game against Maxim yeah
um
from last year yeah so um but he's a
very good very very young player so tell
us a bit about this idea with Bishop 6a5
we generally see Bish B6 with 97 ideas
Fabiano who first played this who made
this bishop B6 more popular I think
started playing in Paris two years ago
and well
after play detail I realized he was
gonna play in Bishop G5 no matter what
and I didn't really prepare that much so
that's why I went for this move order I
think Richard report played a similar
line before leaving the Knight on G8 for
for the moment yeah so that he cannot
play the pin because every time plays
Bishop G5 you can meet it with F6
or Knight G7 very interesting but uh
yeah I mean there were several
interesting moments I thought Knight G7
was also possible but maybe it's not
but uh
anyway I think the chocolate piano you
can play it in so many ways right it
becomes confusing uh at times yeah yeah
I finished gear for advice because if he
made the adjustable course on this
Italian with A4 stuff but uh I thought
that was slightly worse out of the
opening but nothing special I like the
movie Bishop E6 uh I mean he was still
playing quickly but uh
but he decided to force matters yes
yes E4 I thought White's a bit better
here but then I equalized very quickly
on after an ibd2 like I wasn't sure how
to play I
think Gwyneth for me maybe a slight
mistake so you were assessing this
position as more or less balanced equal
very close to equality very close to
equality but I don't think I was playing
well because I was moving my queen back
and forth
so it wasn't at this point he had a
golden opportunity I think it was this
moment Queen to F6 it felt like you were
more or less maintaining the balance in
the position and this move Queen to G6
he had this idea of Queen to D1 did you
spot it yeah yeah Queen G6 probably
played it too quickly I was about three
minutes you spent three minutes on this
one yeah because I know if he was trying
to hit me on the clock so I started
moving faster
uh but I guess after Queen D1
what did I miss here oh Queen D1
uh well the idea is that he cannot I
mean he can take on A4 but you have
Queen to be one ideas right yeah and I
think Rook 2 d8 was a move that the
engine was recommending Queen V1 yeah I
even off The Rook today it's not looking
great somehow I missed
yeah me I saw Queen the one but I
totally underestimated it uh oh because
the idea is that
I guess the king
on G2
yeah did you just play slow like this
and then at the right moment you stick
on A4 no I was weird but windy one I
just decided to make a move
um but uh because I thought I was
equalizing here maybe Queen E6 is more
accurate and then take and then try to
force matters yeah yeah I mean gets to
play Queen C1
it felt like you were happy with the
repetition obviously with the black
pieces not a bad result yeah if my if my
pawns on A6 or A5 maybe black can play
for Advantage but
so very hard to protect when did you
feel like you're finally starting to
have something you play this ambitious
move G5 but yeah I think he was he just
missed G5 because the idea is that
compared to the other position
uh
if I go Queen Rook takes the idea of The
Rook on E7 he's got Queen A8 or
something
oh but maybe it doesn't work okay never
mind
I think we yeah okay I think this is
still some still okay
I will throw him with G5 but this was a
very good practical try like yeah right
now you're starting to put the pressure
on here yeah at least from a practical
perspective right yeah a little time
and it looks very good maybe hg5 in here
oh you can still make a door with 95 95
sacrifice Upon take sticks take Stakes
season to take with the queen then Queen
to B4 just Target both Pawns
but yeah who often happy when I play G5
if it takes like this maybe just take on
C7 or cool C7 oh no never mind okay but
this is such a difficult move to see
yeah F1 yeah this is not easy yeah
and like it's still better to say the
least yes so he played Knight H4 which
gave you questions
with another blender yeah because the
point is that if I take with
the quick after is protected
yeah so on F2 is protected very nice as
they say blenders mistakes come in the
robes
especially in time travel yeah right
well okay he reached move 40 so you
should have found King G1 but he was
playing quickly
did that surprise you at all did you
feel because he hasn't played since the
singfield cup uh In classical
tournaments did you feel like he's a
little bit Rusty
maybe maybe I mean I wasn't taking any
chances I was just playing it like a
normal game you cannot underestimate
Fields especially after he reached he
had that monster tournament a few months
ago where he reached 2800
so maybe he's a little bit uh Rusty
um I mean I noticed he plays
on title juicy here and there feel for
me the only place he plays
but uh
but he'll get there you know I mean
chess requires really a lot of focus
he's a brilliant player he's a very
talented but uh
if you
want to be the best in the world
together really focus on the game
there's something about Bucharest for
you you always seem to be very
comfortable here you score quite well as
well what is it about it
uh well I I know the people
I
have friends here I live my fourth time
uh the organization is great you played
every single year yeah yeah
I won't miss it for anything and uh no
it's good to know I like it I like
overboard tournaments because it's nice
to meet familiar faces you know so
Wesley will let you get some rest it was
a long game and we'll see you tomorrow
yeah thank you guys back are you
Christian congratulations Wesley and a
very happy Wesley as we can see because
of the standings right we have a
tournament later Wednesday so and uh
rest of the players all Drew today
all of them tied for first sorry tight
for a second and we have alrisha with
zero but I'm sure he'll have a comeback
yo absolutely a quick peek at tomorrow's
pairings if we will
right we have by Sheila Grove against
Wesley
Robert against Duda diac against
nepomishi ding versus Carolina and that
is a big matchup that I'm really looking
forward to let's see how Abby does it
gets the new world champion and verusian
uh I know this is one of your first uh
um uh commentating uh but you gotta you
gotta sum up the round for us yeah thank
you I said yeah this was this was a lot
of fun working with you guys I really
really enjoy it and the games were very
interesting and uh even though they were
there were four draws still there was
some very very interesting content some
interesting opening ideas uh of course
Fabiano was very close to Windows he
probably gonna be a little bit upset
after analyzing the game I think he
probably had a clear win at some point
if he had taken on C5 but big win for
Wesley Seoul and I think winning with
black against firusha is going to give
him a lot of confidence so I think uh
he's playing good chess and he's
definitely the favorite right now so I'm
looking forward for tomorrow's games
wonderful and this is stars to Bucharest
once more to get the view of a Christian
in Bucharest
well I think you guys summed it up quite
well it was a fantastic first day of
Chess here in Bucharest and the games
were maybe slow at times but definitely
they sped up towards the end and you
know Fabiano did have his chances he's
definitely going to be disappointed
tonight but he has a great opportunity
to show his medal tomorrow in the game
against the new world champion whenever
you're facing a new world champion you
definitely want to show What You're Made
Of and this is exactly what Fabiano is
going to go for tomorrow and I have to
say I mean look Wesley is just playing
well in Bucharest he loves being here he
loves the atmosphere and he's just
feeling very very comfortable and I'm
seeing him all the time he's just like
walking around with his mom who is his
support system all the time he just
seems relaxed so definitely whenever you
see a relaxed Wesley that's a dangerous
Wesley we have an incredible tournament
on our hands we have the world champion
here and I'm excited to see what
tomorrow is going to bring thank you
Christian and Naji I know it was your
first experience commentating but
seriously you were terrific thank you so
much it's fantastic I look forward to
working with you tomorrow and as we say
our goodbyes we implore you tell your
friends where you're hanging out we'll
see you all tomorrow same time same
station for round two of Bucharest see
you tomorrow
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited